machine learning has increased in
popularity and has become more visible
in the last few years
companies around the world are looking
to integrate machine learning into their
functions
machine learning is a form of artificial
intelligence that teaches computers to
think in a similar way to humans
it uses machine learning algorithms to
build predictive models and continuously
improve itself over time with machine
learning it is possible to quickly and
automatically generate statistical
models that can utilize washed complex
data and deliver faster and more
accurate results the self-driving car by
google is a great example of machine
learning
online product and movie recommendations
from amazon and netflix are other
machine learning applications for
everyday life smartphones detect faces
by taking photographs or unlocking
themselves as an application of machine
learning as well fraud detection in
banking and financial services also used
for shield learning
event retail oil and gas healthcare
logistics companies use machine learning
in their day-to-day business machine
learning can help solve regression
classification and clustering problems
some of the popular algorithms used in
the industries to build predictive
models are linear regression logistic
regression support vector machines
decision trees and k-means clustering
we will be covering all the crucial
machine learning algorithms used in the
industries in this full course video
machine learning is becoming a core
technology that has been implemented
throughout all business sectors to solve
complex business problems while
improving the effectiveness and
scalability of an organization
with this basic understanding of machine
learning the applications and its
importance let's now start with learning
about supervised and unsupervised
learning algorithms
we know humans learn from their past
experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from the past data and
do what humans can do and much faster
well that's called machine learning but
it's a lot more than just learning it's
also about understanding and reasoning
so today we will learn about the basics
of machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this on the basis of the
song's tempo
genre
intensity and the gender of voice for
simplicity let's just use tempo and
intensity for now so here tempo is on
the x-axis ranging from relaxed to fast
whereas intensity is on the y-axis
ranging from light to soaring we see
that paul likes the song with fast tempo
and soaring intensity while he dislikes
the song with relaxed tempo and light
intensity so now we know paul's choices
let's say paul listens to a new song
let's name it as song a song a has fast
tempo and a soaring intensity so it lies
somewhere here looking at the data can
you guess whether paul will like the
song or not correct so paul likes this
song by looking at paul's past choices
we were able to classify the unknown
song very easily right let's say now
paul listens to a new song let's label
it as song p so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess whether paul likes it or not
not able to guess whether paul will like
it or dislike it are the choices unclear
correct we could easily classify song a
but when the choice became complicated
as in the case of song b yes and that's
where machine learning comes in let's
see how in the same example for song b
if you draw a circle around the song b
we see that there are four words for
like whereas one word for dislike if we
go for the majority votes we can say
that paul will definitely like the song
that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called k
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
predict for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you one
million coins of three different
currencies say one rupee one euro and
one dirham each coin has different
weights for example a coin of one rupee
weighs three grams one euro weighs seven
grams and one dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here your weight becomes the
feature of coins while currency becomes
the label when you feed this data to the
machine learning model it learns which
feature is associated with which label
for example it will learn that if a coin
is of three grams it will be a one rupee
coin let's give a new coin to the
machine on the basis of the weight of
the new coin your model will predict the
currency hence supervised learning uses
labeled data to train the model here the
machine knew the features of the object
and also the labels associated with
those features on this note let's move
to unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have cricket data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while runs on the y-axis while
looking at the data you will clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored high
runs and took less wickets while the
other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen and bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsmen and bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
a reward based learning or we can say
that it works on the principle of
feedback here let's say you provide the
system with an image of a dog and ask it
to identify it the system identifies it
as a cat so you give a negative feedback
to the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns i hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario one facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario 2 netflix recommends new movies
based on someone's past movie choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody is
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered surge pricing often where it
says the fare of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please i'm
getting late for office
well that's an interesting machine
learning model which is used by global
taxi giant uber and others where they
have differential pricing in real time
based on demand the number of cars
available bad weather rush r etc so they
use the search pricing model to ensure
that those who need a cab can get one
also it uses predictive modeling to
predict where the demand will be high
with the goal that drivers can take care
of the demand and search pricing can be
minimized great hey siri can you remind
me to book a cab at 6 pm today ok i'll
remind you thanks no problem comment
below some interesting everyday examples
around you where machines are learning
and doing amazing jobs
hi guys this is a picture from simply
learn and we are going to talk about the
two types of machine learning supervised
and unsupervised learning their types
and applications but before we talk
about them let's quickly understand what
is machine learning these days
applications use artificial intelligence
and machine learning to optimize speech
recognition i usually ask siri things i
want to know like hey siri how far is
the nearest subway so whenever we ask
something to siri a powerful speech
recognition kicks off and converts the
audio into its corresponding textual
form which is then sent to the apple
servers for further processing then
neural language processing algorithms
are run to understand the user's intent
and then finally siri tells you the
answer well this is what machine
learning is all about making the
machines learn and act like humans by
feeding them with data and information
without being explicitly programmed as
we saw in the previous example when the
data comes in machines immediately
starts analyzing the data and eventually
gets trained on it and learns it now
when a new data point comes in machine
accurately makes prediction and
decisions based on the past data now
that you know what is machine learning
let's talk about supervised and
unsupervised learning supervised
learning as the name suggests works
under supervision that is it's a
learning in which machine is trained
with data which is well labeled and then
predicts with the help of the label data
set but what is a label data set data
for which you already know the target
answer is called a label data like i
show you an image and tell you that it's
a dog then it's a label data while if i
show you an image without telling you
what exactly it is then it's an
unlabeled data now let's say we have
images which are labeled as spoon or
knife we then feed it to the machine
which analyzes and learns the
association of these images with its
labels based on its features such as
shape size sharpness etc now when a new
image is fed to the machine without any
label with the help of the past data the
machine is able to predict accurately
and tell that it's a spoon hence in
supervised machine learning the
algorithm teaches the model to learn
from the labeled example that we provide
so supervised learning can be further
divided into classification and
regression it is a classification
problem when the output variable is
categoric such as red or blue disease or
no disease male or female whereas it's a
regression problem when the output
variable is a real or continuous value
for example salary based on work
experience weight based on height so it
creates a predictive model showing
trends and data so now if i say will i
get a salary raise or not that's
classification but if i say how much
salary raise will i get that is
regression now let's understand
classification with the help of an
example in order to predict whether an
email is a spam or not first we need to
teach our machine what a spam mail looks
like this is done based on a lot of spam
filters like firstly reviewing the
content of the email then review the
email header and search if it contains
any falsified information this is done
based on some keywords like free
lottery
price claim etc then general blacklist
filters to stop emails that come from
already blacklisted known spammers and
etc so all these filters scores the
email which is known as spam score the
lower the total spam score of the email
it is more likely that the email will
land in subscribers in boxes so based on
the content labels and spam score of the
new incoming mail the algorithm decides
whether it should land in inbox or the
spam folder
now let's quickly understand regression
so let's say we have two variables that
is temperature and humidity where
temperature is the independent variable
and humidity is the dependent variable
such that as the temperature increases
humidity decreases hence they are
correlated when we feed this data to a
regression model it will understand the
relationship between these two variables
and how one variable depends on the
other after the machine is trained it
can easily predict the humidity based on
the given temperature well that was
about regression now let's see some
real-life applications where supervised
learning is used so supervised learning
is used in risk assessment to assess
risk in financial services or an
insurance domain to minimize the risk
portfolio of the companies image
classification facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photos so image classification is
one of the key use cases of
demonstrating supervised machine
learning algorithms obviously a lot more
goes into all these like convolutional
neural networks etc fraud detection
whether the transactions made by the
user are authentic or not and visual
recognition the ability of a machine
learning model to identify objects
places people and actions and images now
let's quickly talk about unsupervised
learning in unsupervised learning there
is no supervision that is no training
will be given to the machine allowing it
to act on the data which is not labeled
hence machine tries to identify patterns
and gives the response let's take a
similar example as before but this time
we do not tell the machine whether it's
a spoon or a knife the machine
identifies patterns from the given set
and groups them based on their patterns
similarities etc again unsupervised
learning can be further grouped into
clustering and association clustering is
basically where the machine forms groups
based on the behavior of the data
secondly association it is a rule-based
machine learning to discover interesting
relation between variables in large data
sets for example which customer made
similar product purchases is clustering
whereas association is which products
were purchased together now let's
understand clustering with the help of
an example to reduce their churn rate a
telecom company studies the behavior of
the customers based on average call
duration and internet usage and observes
that while some customers call duration
is quite high others have heavy internet
usage the customers are grouped based on
their observed behavior and a strategy
is adopted to minimize churn rate and
maximize profit by suitable promotions
and campaigns
as you can see in the chart on the right
hand side customers in group a uses more
data and also have high quality group b
customers are heavy internet users while
group c customers have high call
duration so group b will be given more
data benefit plans while group c will be
given cheaper call rates to buy their
loyalty so this was the example of
clustering now let's understand
association with another example let's
say customer one goes to a supermarket
and buys these products say bread milk
fruits wheat then customer 2 goes and
buys bread milk rice and butter
now when customer 3 goes and buys bread
it is highly likely that he will also
buy milk hence relationship is
established based on customer behavior
and recommendations are made now let's
look at some real life applications of
unsupervised learning market basket
analysis is a machine learning model
based on the algorithm that if you buy a
certain group of items you are less more
likely to buy another group of items
semantic clustering semantically similar
words share similar contexts people post
their queries on websites in their own
ways semantic clustering groups all
responses in a cluster with same meaning
to ensure that the customer finds the
information they want quickly and easily
it plays an important role in
information retrieval good browsing
experience and comprehension
delivery store optimization machine
learning models are used to predict the
demand and keep up with the supply also
to open stores where demand is more and
optimizing rules for more efficient
deliveries according to past data and
behavior we can also use unsupervised
machine learning models to identify
accident prone areas based on the
intensity of those accidents and the
area in order to introduce safety
measures by now i hope you've understood
supervised and unsupervised learning for
a quick recap let's see a few
differences between the two the most
fundamental difference is that
supervised learning uses known and
labeled data and unsupervised learning
uses unlabeled data as their input
secondly supervised learning follows a
feedback mechanism while unsupervised
learning does not also the most commonly
used algorithms in supervised learning
are decision tree logistic regression
support vector machine etc and at
unsupervised learning their k-means
clustering hierarchical clustering a
priori algorithm and many more welcome
to linear regression my name is richard
kirchner i'm with simply learn let's
look at an example of a common use for
linear regression profit estimation of a
company if i was going to invest in a
company i would like to know how much
money i could expect to make so we'll
take a look at a venture capitalist firm
and try to understand which companies
they should invest in so we'll take the
idea that we need to decide the
companies to invest in we need to
predict the profit the company makes and
we're going to do it based on the
company's expenses and even just a
specific expense in this case we have
our company we have the different
expenses so we have our rnd which is
your research and development we have
our marketing uh we might have the
location we might have what kind of
administration is going through based on
all this different information we would
like to calculate the profit now in
actuality there's usually about 23 to 27
different markers that they look at if
they're a heavy duty investor we're only
going to take a look at one basic one
we're going to come in and for
simplicity let's consider a single
variable r and d and find out which
companies to invest in based on that so
we take r and d and we're plotting the
profit based on the r d expenditure how
much money they put into the research
and development and then we look at the
profit that goes with that we can
predict a line to estimate the profit so
we draw a line right through the data
when you look at that you can see how
much they invest in the rnd is a good
marker as to how much profit they're
going to have we can also note that
companies spending more on r d make good
profit so let's invest in the ones that
spend a higher rate in their r d what's
in it for you first we'll have an
introduction to machine learning
followed by machine learning algorithms
these will be specific to linear
regression and where it fits into the
larger model then we'll take a look at
applications of linear regression
understanding linear regression and
multiple linear regression finally we'll
roll up our sleeves and do a little
programming in use case profit
estimation of companies let's go ahead
and jump in let's start with our
introduction to machine learning along
with some machine learning algorithms
and where that fits in with linear
regression let's look at another example
of machine learning based on the amount
of rainfall how much would be the crop
yield so here we have our crops we have
our rainfall and we want to know how
much we're going to get from our crops
this year so we're going to introduce
two variables independent and dependent
the independent variable is a variable
whose value does not change by the
effect of other variables and is used to
manipulate the dependent variable it is
often denoted as x in our example
rainfall is the independent variable
this is a wonderful example because you
can easily see that we can't control the
rain but the rain does control the crop
so we talk about the independent
variable controlling the dependent
variable let's define dependent variable
as a variable whose value change when
there is any manipulation the values of
the independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in this is kind of
random data from any kind of project we
want to divide it up into numerical and
categorical so numerical is numbers age
salary height where categorical would be
a description the color a dog's breed
gender categoricals limited to very
specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at our different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why we multiple linear
regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance i'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors the
first important one is which variables
in particular are significant predictors
of the outcome variable and the second
one that we need to look at closely is
how significant is the regression line
to make predictions with the highest
possible accuracy if it's inaccurate we
can't use it so it's very important we
find out the most accurate line we can
get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and x being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever x is m
in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y 2
minus y 1 and x 2 minus x 1 and finally
we have c which is the coefficient of
the line or where it happens to cross
the zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math that
you're going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
wiz and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e that's
opened up that just means summation
that's all that is so when you see the
sigma character it just means we're
adding everything in that row and for
computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the xy points and create
all the information you need so in the
top half you can see where we've broken
that down into pieces and as it goes
through the first two points it computes
the squared value of x the squared value
of y and x times y and then it takes all
of x and adds them up all of y adds them
up all of x squared adds them up and so
on and so on and you can see we have the
sum of equal to 15 the sum is equal to
20 all the way up to x times y where the
sum equals 66. this all comes from our
formula for calculating a straight line
where y equals the slope times x plus
the coefficient c so we go down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum
of x times y which we computed one line
at a time there and that's just the 66
and take all that and you subtract it
from the sum of x times the sum of y and
those have both been computed so you
have 15 times 20. and on the bottom we
have the number of lines times the sum
of x squared easily computed as 86 for
the sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values
and we're going to go ahead and plot
them we're going to predict them so y
equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit lines should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see why what we actual
values were and you can see why predict
it you can easily see where we take y
minus y predicted and we get an answer
what is the difference between those two
and if we square that y minus y
prediction squared we can then sum those
squared values that's where we get the
0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the way
down until we have a summation equals
2.4 so the sum of squared errors for
this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have well we'll start with
the simple linear regression where we
had y equals m plus x plus c and we're
trying to find the value of y now with
multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just x we have x1 x2 x3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
m1 times x1 plus m2 times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it it's such
a visual to look at and so easy to use
um just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupyter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as in p and then i want you to
skip one line and look at import pandas
as pd these are very common tools that
you need with most of your linear
regression the numpy which stands for
number python is usually denoted as np
and you have to almost have that for
your sk learn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning pandas
although you don't have to have it for
your sklearn libraries it does such a
wonderful job of importing data setting
it up into a data frame so we can
manipulate it rather easily and it has a
lot of tools also in addition to that so
we usually like to use the pandas when
we can and i'll show you what that looks
like the other three lines are for us to
get a visual of this data and take a
look at it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber scion map plot library
inline that is only because i'm doing an
inline ide my interface in the anaconda
jupiter notebook requires i put that in
there or you're not going to see the
graph when it comes up let's go ahead
and run this it's not going to be that
interesting so we're just setting up
variables in fact it's not going to do
anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies dot csv you're
going to have to change this to fit
whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that i have companies equals
pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the i location
and because this is companies as a pd
data set i can use this nice notation
that says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is or we have a colon minus
one and we want the values set into
there so x is no longer a data set a
pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carrier's
return i don't know about you but i'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
349 dollars and 20 cents compared to the
administration cost of a hundred and
thirty six thousand eight hundred ninety
seven dollars and eighty cents so on so
on it helps to create the profit of 192
261 and 83 cents that makes no sense to
me whatsoever no pun intended so let's
flip back here and take a look at our
next set of code where we're going to
graph it so we can get a better
understanding of our data and what it
means so at this point we're going to
use a single line of code to get a lot
of information so we can see where we're
going with this let's go ahead and paste
that into our notebook and see what we
got going and so we have the
visualization and again we're using sns
which is pandas as you can see we
imported the matplot library dot pi plot
as plt which then the seaborn uses and
we imported the seaborn as sns and then
that final line of code helps us show
this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file in other means and that's the matte
plot library in line with the amber sign
at the beginning so here we come down to
the single line of code seaborne is
great because it actually recognizes the
panda data frame so i can just take the
companies dot core for coordinates and i
can put that right into the seaborn and
when we run this we get this beautiful
plot and let's just take a look at what
this plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one uh we have the columns and
the rows we have r and d spending we
have administration we have marketing
spending and profit and if you cross
index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r and d spending is
going to be the same as r and d spending
and the same thing with administration
costs so right down the middle you get
this dark row or dark um diagonal row
that shows that this is the highest
corresponding data that's exactly the
same and as it becomes lighter there's
less connections between the data so we
can see with profit obviously profit is
the same as profit and next it has a
very high correlation with r d spending
which we looked at earlier and it has a
slightly less connection to marketing
spending and even less to how much money
we put into the administration so now
that we have a nice look at the data
let's go ahead and dig in and create
some actual useful linear regression
models so that we can predict values and
have a better profit now that we've
taken a look at the visualization of
this data we're going to move on to the
next step instead of just having a
pretty picture we need to generate some
hard data some hard values so let's see
what that looks like we're going to set
up our linear regression model in two
steps the first one is we need to
prepare some of our data so it fits
correctly and let's go ahead and paste
this code into our jupyter notebook and
what we're bringing in is we're going to
bring in the sklearn pre-processing
where we're going to import the label
encoder and the one hot encoder to use
the label encoder we're going to create
a variable called label encoder and set
it equal to capital l label capital e
encoder this creates a class that we can
reuse for transferring the labels back
and forth now about now you should ask
what labels are we talking about let's
go take a look at the data we processed
before and see what i'm talking about
here if you remember when we did the
companies dot head and we printed the
top five rows of data we have our
columns going across we have column zero
which is r and d spending column one
which is administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or a one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot in order
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
as just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look at what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if i go ahead
and just do row 0 you'll see i have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers next on setting up our
data we have avoiding dummy variable
trap this is very important why
because the computer has automatically
transformed our header into the setup
and it's automatically transferred all
these different variables so when we did
the encoder the encoder created two
columns and what we need to do is just
have the one because it has both the
variable and the name that's what this
piece of code does here let's go ahead
and paste this in here and we have x
equals x colon comma one colon all this
is doing is removing that one extra
column we put in there when we did our
one hot encoder and our label encoding
let's go ahead and run that and now we
get to create our linear regression
model and let's see what that looks like
here and we're going to do that in two
steps the first step is going to be in
splitting the data now whenever we
create a predictive model of data we
always want to split it up so we have a
training set and we have a testing set
that's very important otherwise we'd be
very unethical without testing it to see
how good our fit is and then we'll go
ahead and create our multiple linear
regression model and train it and set it
up let's go ahead and paste this next
piece of code in here and i'll go ahead
and shrink it down a size or two so it
all fits on one line so from the sklearn
module selection we're going to import
train test split and you'll see that
we've created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models
you usually see that a capital x and you
see the train and the test and the
lowercase y what this is is x is our
data going in that's our rnd spin our
administration our marketing and then y
which we're training is the answer
that's the profit because we want to
know the profit of an unknown entity
that's what we're going to shoot for in
this tutorial the next part train test
split we take x and we take y we've
already created those x has the columns
with the data in it and y has a column
with profit in it and then we're going
to set the test size equals point two
that basically means twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're going to put them off
to the side so since we're using a
thousand lines of data that means that
200 of those lines we're going to hold
off to the side to test for later and
then the random state equals zero we're
going to randomize which ones it picks
to hold off to the side we'll go ahead
and run this it's not overly exciting so
it's setting up our variables but the
next step is the next step we actually
create our linear regression model now
that we got to the linear regression
model we get that next piece of the
puzzle let's go ahead and put that code
in there and walk through it so here we
go we're going to paste it in there and
let's go ahead and since this is a
shorter line of code let's zoom up there
so we can get a good look and we have
from the sklearn dot linear underscore
model we're going to import linear
regression now i don't know if you
recall from earlier when we were doing
all the math let's go ahead and flip
back there and take a look at that do
you remember this where we had this long
formula on the bottom and we were doing
all this summarization and then we also
looked at uh setting it up with the
different lines and then we also looked
all the way down to
multiple linear regression where we're
adding all those formulas together all
of that is wrapped up in this one
section so what's going on here is i'm
going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually and then we do the
regressor dot fit in this case we do x
train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor dot
predict x test going in and this gives
us y predict now because i'm in jupiter
inline i can just put the variable up
there and when i hit the run button
it'll print that array out i could have
just as easily done print why predict so
if you're in a different ide that's not
an inline setup like the jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side it's going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient
we can also do the regressor intercept
and let's run that and take a look at
that this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into where it's coming from you can see
the formula down here where y equals m1
times x1 plus m2 times x2 and so on and
so on plus c the coefficient so these
variables fit right into this formula y
equals slope one times column one
variable plus slope 2 times column 2
variable all the way to the m and to the
n and x to the n plus c the coefficient
or in this case you have minus 8.89 to
the power of 2 etc etc times the first
column and the second column and the
third column and then our intercept is
the minus one zero three zero zero nine
point boy it gets kind of complicated
when you look at it this is why we don't
do this by hand anymore this is why we
have the computer to make these
calculations easy to understand and
calculate now i told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning i said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look what that looks like
in code and so we're going to use this
from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 percent correct but you do want
that in the upper 90s oh and higher
shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the r2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 9 2 as we got
on our model remember it does have a
random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression what is logistic
regression let's say we have to build a
predictive model or a machine learning
model to predict whether the passengers
of the titanic ship have survived or not
the shipwreck so how do we do that so we
use logistic regression to build a model
for this how do we use logistic
regression so we have the information
about the passengers their id whether
they have survived or not their class
and name and so on and so forth and we
use this information where we already
know whether the person has survived or
not that is the labeled information and
we help the system to train based on
this information with based on this
labeled data this is known as label data
and during the process of building the
model we probably will remove some of
the non-essential parameters or
attributes here we only take those
attributes which are really required to
make these predictions and once we train
the model we run new data through it
whereby the model will predict whether
the passenger has survived or not all
right what is logistic regression as i
mentioned earlier positive regression is
an algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the x and y axis x is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between zero and one and as we
can imagine it is intuitive as well as
the number of years are on the lower
side maybe one year two years or three
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down the probability
of your car breaking down within two
years of your last service are 0.1
probability similarly 3 years is maybe
0.3 and so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was 6 or 7
years there is almost a certainty that
your car is going to break down that is
what this graph shows so this is an
example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variable's outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about so
here the outcome is discrete and not a
continuous value so this is how the
logistic regression curve looks let me
explain a little bit what exactly
how exactly we are going to
uh determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be said saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be 0 or 1
but based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say an output
of 0.29 is considered as 0 which means
that the car will not break down so
that's the way logistic regression works
now let's do a quick comparison between
logistic regression and linear
regression because they both have the
term regression in them so it can cause
confusion so let's try to remove that
confusion so what is linear regression
linear regression is a process is once
again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say the hr team
of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is trained and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employee's information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be the height so this is a linear
regression problem and linear regression
example now salary is a continuous value
you can get five thousand five thousand
five hundred
five thousand six hundred it is not
discrete like a cat or a dog or an apple
or a banana these are discrete or a yes
or no these are discrete values right so
this way you're trying to find
continuous values is where we use linear
regression so let's say just to extend
on the scenario we now want to find out
whether this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
that is a discrete problem right a yes
or no kind of a problem in this case we
actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have labeled data so
this is the label data so based on the
employee rating these are the ratings
and then some people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors thus
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at zero and one but still the
straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and
this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is one minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from zero
to infinity so when this probability is
zero then the odds will the value of the
odds is equal to zero and when the
probability becomes one then the value
of the odds is 1 by 0 that will be
infinity but the probability itself
remains between 0 and 1. now this is how
an equation of a straight line looks so
y is equal to beta0 plus beta 1 x where
beta0 is the y-intercept and beta1 is
the slope of the line if we take the
odds equation and take a log of both
sides then this would look somewhat like
this and the term logistic is actually
derived from the fact that we are doing
this we take a log of px by 1 minus px
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right and that
is equal to beta0 plus beta1 x which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of p x we will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of p x like this px is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta 0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta 0 plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if you want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
it's going to be sunny or not it's going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupiter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and there the image has a number
one two three four and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's take a
look at the code and see what we are
doing so i will not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images or a
sample of these images and then we split
the data into training and test as i
mentioned earlier
and we can do some exploratory analysis
and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we go we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right
so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 percent because the diagonal should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagnose the cells other than
the diagonal should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a two here there are there's
a one here but most of them are along
the diagonal this what does this mean
this means that the
number that has been fed is 0 and the
number that has been detected is also 0
so the predicted value and the actual
value are the same so along the
diagonals that is true which means that
let's let's take this diagonal right if
the maximum number is here that means
that like here in this case it is 34
which means that 34 of the images that
have been fed or rather actually there
are two misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four and out of which 34 have
been predicted correctly as number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight and another one has been predicted
as number nine so these are two
misclassifications okay so that is the
meaning of saying that the maximum
number should be in the diagonal so if
you have all of them so for an ideal
model which has let's say 100 accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
hundred percent accurate model okay so
that's uh just of how to use this matrix
uh how to use this confusion matrix i
know the name
is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix but actually it is not very
confusing it's very straightforward so
you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
or that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and the
predicted value and the actual value is
exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are i think 37 plus 5
yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of digit 3 and
the accuracy is only 37 of them have
been accurately predicted three of them
have been predicted as number seven and
two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see how the code
looks so this is the code in
in jupiter notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code
then
here we will visualize the shape of
these digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
1797 by 64. these are like 8x8 images so
that's that's what is reflected in this
shape now from here onwards we are
basically once again importing some of
the libraries that are required like
numpy and matplot and we will take a
look at uh some of the sample images
that we have uh loaded so this one for
example creates a figure and then we go
ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at zero one two three four so this is
how the image is this is how the data is
okay and uh based on this we will
actually train our logistic regression
model and then we will test it and see
how well it is able to recognize so the
way it works is the pixel information so
as you can see here this is an eight by
eight pixel kind of a image and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn
for which a number what is the pattern
of the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training we split the data
into training and test so that the
training data set is used to train the
system so we pass this probably multiple
times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20.23
that means 23 percent of that entire
data
is used for testing and the remaining 77
percent is used for training so there is
a readily available function which is uh
called train test split so we don't have
to write any special code for the
splitting it will automatically split
the data based on the proportion that we
give here which is test size so we just
give the test size automatically
training size will be determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train and y underscore train
for the training data set and what is x
underscore train these are these are the
features right which is like the
independent variable and why underscore
train is the label right so in this case
what happens is we have the input value
which is or the features value which is
in x underscore train and since this is
the labeled data for each of them each
of the observations we already have the
label information saying whether this
digit is a zero or a one or a two so
that this is what will be used for
comparison to find out whether the the
system is able to recognize it correctly
or there is an error for each
observation it will compare with this
right so this is the label so the same
way x underscore train y underscore
train is for the training data set x
underscore test y underscore test is for
the test data set okay so let me go
ahead and execute this code as well and
then we can go and check quickly what is
the how many entries are there and in
each of these so x underscore train the
shape is 13 83
by 64 and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape we see is 414 so
actually there are 414 observations in
test and 1383 observations in train so
that's basically what these four lines
of code are are saying okay then we
import the logistic regression library
and which is a part of scikit learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line
is where we are passing our data the
training data set and this is our the
the predictors and
this is our target we are passing this
data set to train our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and uh we
want to see how accurate this is so what
we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for a particular
value new input you use the predict
method okay so let's run the predict
method and we pass this particular image
and
we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10 uh seems to be fine so let me
just go ahead and test the entire data
set okay that's basically what we will
do so now we want to find out how
accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentages of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 to accurate okay so that's on this
part now what we can also do is we can
also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well
so that we can also visualize
how well this model has uh done so let
me execute this piece of code which will
basically import some of the libraries
that are required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has uh the
model has generated so we kind of create
the confusion matrix and we will print
it and this is how the confusion matrix
looks as the name suggests it is a
matrix and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is predicted if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers uh which means the accuracy is
very low the diagonal indicates a
correct prediction that this means that
the actual value is same as the
predicted value here again actual values
same as the predictive value and so on
right so the moment you see a number
here that means the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else right similarly here the
actual value is something and the
predicted value is something else so
that is basically how we read the
confusion matrix now how do we find the
accuracy you can actually add up the
total values in the diagonal so it's
like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so on and
divide that by the total number of test
observations that will give you the
percentage accuracy using a confusion
matrix now let us visualize this
confusion matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way
using a heat map so we will create a
heat map with some we'll add some colors
as well it's it's like more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea so if we let me run this
piece of code and this is how the heat
map looks
and as you can see here the diagonals
again are all the values are here most
of the values so which means reasonably
this seems to be reasonably accurate and
yeah basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as i
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test values or the
total number of observations in test
data set okay so this is the confusion
matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well uh the system
has classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we we picked up randomly a few of them
so
this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero actual
value is of course zero
then this is the image of nine
so this has also been predicted
correctly nine and actual value is nine
and this is the image of one and again
this has been predicted correctly as
like the actual value okay so this was a
quick demo of logistic regression how to
use logistic regression to identify
images what is a decision tree let's go
through a very simple example before we
dig in d decision tree is a tree shape
diagram used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
currents or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is the diameter greater than 2 if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
and the different parts we're going to
be using we'll start with entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went on
the different parts of our tree and they
call the leaf node leaf node carries the
classification or the decision so it's
the final end at the bottom the decision
node has two or more branches this is
where we're breaking the group up into
different parts and finally you have the
root node the topmost decision node is
known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals all get the jungle
today maybe you're the hunter with a gun
or if you're more into photography
you're a photographer with a camera so
let's look at this group of animals and
let's try to classify different types of
animals based on their features using a
decision tree so the problem statement
is to classify the different types of
animals based on their features using a
decision tree the data set is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so let's look at a training
set or a training data set and we're
looking at color we're looking at height
and then we have our different animals
we have our elephants our giraffes our
monkeys and our tigers and there of
different colors and shapes let's see
what that looks like and how do we split
the data we have to frame the conditions
that split the data in such a way that
the information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decreasing
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base two of
the same the percentage of that animal
let's try to calculate the entropy for
the current data set and take a look at
what that looks like and don't be afraid
of the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three drafts
a total of eight times the log usually
they use base two on the log so log base
two of three over eight plus in this
case let's say it's yellow fence two
over eight two elephants over total of
eight times log base two two over eight
plus one monkey over total of eight log
base two one over eight and plus two
over eight of the tigers log base 2 over
8. and if we plug that into our computer
our calculator i obviously can't do logs
in my head we get an entropy equal to
0.571 the program will actually
calculate the entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not going to go
through each set one at a time to see
what those numbers are we just want you
to be aware that this is a formula or
the mathematics behind it gain can be
calculated by finding the difference of
the subsequent entropy values after a
split now we will try to choose a
condition that gives us the highest gain
we will do that by splitting the data
using each condition and checking that
the gain we get out of them the
condition that gives us the highest gain
will be used to make the first split can
you guess what that first split will be
just by looking at this image as a human
is probably pretty easy to split it
let's see if you're right if you guessed
the color yellow you're correct let's
say the condition that gives us the
maximum gain is yellow so we will split
the data based on the color yellow if
it's true that group of animals goes to
the left if it's false it goes to the
right the entropy after the splitting
has
decreased considerably however we still
need some splitting of both the branches
to attain an entropy value equal to 0.
so we decide to split both the nodes
using height as the condition since
every branch now contains single label
type we can say that entropy in this
case has reached the least value and
here you see we have the giraffes the
tigers the monkey and the elephants all
separated into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the dataset with a
hundred percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for this bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupyter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics for accuracy score we
need to score our setup that's the whole
reason we're splitting it between the
training and testing data and finally we
still need the sklearn import tree and
that's just the basic tree function is
needed for the decision tree classifier
and finally we're going to load our data
down here and i'm going to run this and
we're going to get two things on here
one we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name
and you'll see it's on my c drive and
this is very lengthy setup on here where
i stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer will be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i want to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it can be moved in favor of the
model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sklearn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet this
is what it looks like as a basic text
file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score house
number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with uh the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head this is one of
the nice things when we did the uh
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head it prints the first five lines of
the data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
excel spreadsheet or open office cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero zero
is a yes or no
and that's whether the loan went default
or not so we want to start with one if
we go back up here that's the initial
payment and it goes all the way through
the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x-trade or the y-train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropal decision tree classifier it
automatically prints out what's in that
decision tree there's a lot of variables
you can play within here and it's quite
beyond the scope of this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of three
now the max depth if you remember above
when we were doing the different graphs
of animals means it's only going to go
down three layers before it stops and
then we have minimal samples of leaves
is five so it's going to have at least
five leaves at the end so i'll have at
least three splits i'll have no more
than three layers and at least five end
leaves with the final result at the
bottom now that we've created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules that
their different tools have the predict
when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use an
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not
in this case though we need to test out
the data and just see how good our
sample is how good of our tree does at
predicting the loan payments and finally
since anaconda jupiter notebook works as
a command line for python we can simply
put the y predict e n to print it i
could just as easily have put the print
and put brackets around y predict e in
to print it out we'll go ahead and do
that it doesn't matter which way you do
it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 of a thousand so you
should have about 300 answers in here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage and let's run that
and see what it looks like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit is going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not we're going to be looking
at random forest one of the many
powerful tools in the machine learning
library before we dive into the topic
let's start by looking at a few of the
uses for random forest currently today
is used in remote sensing for example
they're used in the etm devices if
you're a space buff that's the enhanced
thermatic mapper they use on satellites
which see
far outside the human spectrum for
looking at land masses and they acquire
images of the earth's surface the
accuracy is higher and training time is
less than many other machine learning
tools out there also object detection
multi-class object detection is done
using random forest algorithms a good
example is a traffic where you try to
sort out the different cars buses and
things and it provides a better
detection in complicated environments
very complicated up there and then we
have uh another example connect and
let's take a little closer look at
connect connect they use a random forest
as part of the game console
and what it does is it tracks the body
movements and it recreates it in the
game and let's see what that looks like
we have a user who performs a step in
this case it looks like elvis presley
going there
that is then recorded so the connect
registers the movement
and then it marks the user based on
accuracy and it looks like we have
prints going on this one
from
elvis press leader prints that's great
so mark's user based on the accuracy if
we look at that a little closer we have
a training set to identify body parts
where are the hands where the feet
what's going on with the body
that then goes into a random forest
classifier that learns from it
once we've trained the classifier
and then identifies the body parts while
the person's dancing it's able to
represent that in a computer format and
then based on that it scores the game
and how accurate you are as being elvis
presley or prince in your dancing so why
random forest it's always important to
understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with
the random forest the first one is
there's no overfitting if you use of
multiple trees reduce the risk of
overfitting training time is less
overfitting means that we have fit the
data so close to what we have as our
sample that we pick up on all the weird
parts and instead of predicting the
overall data you're predicting the weird
stuff which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area
and they took a slightly different set
of statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works
and let's look at what is a random
forest random forest or random decision
forest is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as a final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switch from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training
we can look at that we know that that's
what's going to come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy
everything on the decision tree and how
it makes those decision is based on
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set
then they also have information gain the
leaf node the decision node and the root
node we'll cover these other four terms
as we go down the tree but let's start
with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit so the first thing we
want to do is we want to split this
apart and we take the initial data set
we're going to create a data set 1 and a
data set 2 we just split it into and if
you look at these new data sets after
splitting them the entropy of each of
those sets is much less
so for the first one whatever comes in
there it's going to sort that data and
it's going to say okay if this data goes
this direction it's probably an apple
and if it goes into the other direction
it's probably a lemon so that brings us
up to information gain it is the measure
of decrease in the entropy after the
data set is split what that means in
here is that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
will either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision we should
have a name for the nodes above it and
they call those decision nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this bowl was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
three three one three three one and we
have a label apple lemon grapes apple
lemon grapes and how do we split the
data we have to frame the conditions to
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest
it's very key to note that we're looking
for the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hardy
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl full of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at there
very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of 0
as you can see there's only one kind of
label left for this branch so no further
splitting is required for this node
however this node on the right is still
requires a split to decrease the entropy
further so we split the right node
further based on color if you look at
this if i split it on color that pretty
much cuts it right down the middle it's
the only thing we have left in our
choices of color and diameter too and if
the color is yellow
it's going to go to the ripe bowl and if
it's false it's going to go to the left
bowl so the entropy in this case is now
zero so now we have three bowls with
zero entropy there's only one type of
data in each one of those bowls so we
can predict a lemon with a hundred
percent accuracy and we can predict the
apple also with 100 accuracy along with
our grapes up there so we've looked at
kind of a basic tree in our forest but
what we really want to know is how does
a random forest work as a whole so to
begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this just like we did in the
example this tree looks at the diameter
if it's greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange it's going to go to the
right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false we build a
second tree very similar but split
differently instead of the first one
being split by a diameter this one when
they created it if you look at that
first bowl it has a lot of red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right and then it looks
at the shape false are true and so on
and so on and tree three is the diameter
equal to one and it came up with this
because there's a lot of cherries in
this bowl so that would be the biggest
split on there is is the diameter equal
to one that's going to drop the entropy
the quickest and as you can see it
splits it into true if it goes false and
they've added another category does it
grow in the summer and if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees so you can see
them all in one image so this would be
three completely different trees
categorizing a fruit and let's take a
fruit now let's try this and this fruit
if you look at it we've blackened it out
you can't see the color on it so it's
missing data remember one of the things
we talked about earlier is that a random
forest works really good if you're
missing data if you're missing pieces so
this fruit has an image but maybe the
person had a black and white camera when
they took the picture and we're going to
take a look at this and it's going to
have
to put the color in there so ignore the
color down there but the diameter equals
3 we find out it grows in the summer
equals yes and the shape is a circle and
if you go to the right you can look at
what one of the decision trees did this
is the third one is the diameter greater
than equal to three is the color orange
well it doesn't really know on this one
but if you look at the value it's a true
and go to the right tree two classifies
it as cherries is the color equal red
is the shape a circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry
when you add that all together the
majority of the vote says orange so the
answer is it's classified as an orange
even though we didn't know the color and
we're missing data on it i don't know
about you but i'm getting tired of fruit
so let's switch and i did promise you
we'd start looking at a case example and
get into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn.ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the
other modules that we bring in and one
is going to be pandas we're going to
import pandas as pd pd is a common term
used for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us where when
you create a pandas data frame it looks
like an excel spreadsheet and you'll see
that in a minute when we start digging
deeper into the code panda is just
wonderful because it plays nice with all
the other modules in there and then we
have numpy which is our numbers python
and the numbers python allows us to do
different mathematical sets on here
we'll see right off the bat we're going
to take our np and we're going to go
ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupyter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the imports and i'm
going to paste the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if you
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet
and in this excel spreadsheet we have
set the columns so up on the top you can
see the four different columns and then
we have the data iris.data down below
it's a little confusing without knowing
where this data is coming from so let's
look at the bigger picture and i'm going
to go print i'm just going to change
this for a moment and we're going to
print all of iris and see what that
looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary you'll have a
key or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it so
feature names which we actually used
over here under columns is equal to an
array of sepal length sepal width petal
length petal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns and if you scroll down
far enough you'll also see data down
here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
dot data frame dot head it'll print the
first five lines of the data set in
there along with the headers if you have
it in this case we have the column
header set to iris features and in here
you'll see that we have 0 1 2 3 4 in
python most arrays always start at zero
so when you look at the first five it's
going to be zero one two three four not
one two three four five so now we've got
our iris data imported into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code we're going to take a look
at the target and let's go ahead and get
this into our notebook this piece of
code so we can discuss it a little bit
more in detail so here we are in our
jupyter notebook i'm going to put the
code in here and before i run it i want
to look at a couple things going on so
we have uh df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target now these are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do either one i could have just as
easily done iris and then in brackets
target depending on what i'm working on
both are
acceptable
let's go ahead and run this code and see
how this changes and what we've done is
we've added the target from the iris
data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're going to add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you that where you
where that's different where you can
alter that and do it slightly
differently but let's go ahead and put
this into our script up to that now and
here we go we're gonna put that down
here
and we're gonna run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1 and we're going to do it
for each of the rows that's where the
length df comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved and we're
going to use that to train it and then
the other 25 we're going to hold off to
the side and use that to test it later
on so let's flip back on over and see
what the next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test 75 and train 25
percent and test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is train equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is trained equals false it goes in
the test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in
and you'll see here we've done a couple
very basic things we know that the
columns in our data frame again this is
a panda thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width pedal
length and pedal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window
if you just put the name of it it'll
print it out this is the same as doing
print
features
and the short hand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupiter notebooks
is i'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead and convert the species on
here into something the computer
understands so let's put this code into
our script and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd.factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what's factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and vera
veracolor
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species
of zero because this is in the format of
a of an array of arrays so you have to
have the zero on the end and then
species is just that column factorize
goes in there and looks at the fact that
there's only three of them so when i run
this you'll see that y generates an
array that's equal to in this case it's
the training set and it's zeros ones and
twos representing the three different
kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
0 is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more
clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is the
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set
let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and i printed out y instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these different meanings of
all these different settings on here
some of them are self-explanatory if you
kind of think about it a little bit like
max features as auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
gonna automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we have the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this we're looking at a
lot of stuff here so you might have in
this case there's probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf nodes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay it only goes so far and
then we're going to use all of our
resources on processing this and that
really is what most of these are about
is limiting the process and making sure
we don't overwhelm a system and there's
some other settings in here again we're
not going to go over all of them warm
start equals false warm start is if
you're programming it one piece at a
time externally since we're not we're
not going to have like we're not going
to continually train this particular
learning tree and again like i said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the sk learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit or train our features and our target
y so now we have our training model
what's next if we're going to create a
model we now need to test it remember we
set aside the test feature test group 25
of the data so let's go ahead and take
this code and let's put it into our
script and see what that looks like okay
here we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length simple width petal
length petal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here seeing what
features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2 and
we're going to put those in and we're
going to predict what our new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts 0 0 zero one two one one two
two two and and uh again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf.predict
probability so we're running it just
like we ran it up here but this time
with this we're going to get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here that this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a one
for setosa it predicts a 0 for virginica
and it predicts a 0 for versa color and
so on and so on and so on and let's um
you know what i'm going to change this
just a little bit let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says setosa
gets zero votes virginica gets .5 votes
versacolor gets 0.5 votes but let's just
go with the virginica since these two
are equal and so on and so on down the
list you can see how they vary on here
so now we've looked at both how to do a
basic predict of the features and we've
looked at the predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and
if you remember correctly this was the
the names that we've been talking about
this whole time the setosa virginica
versus color and then we're going to go
ahead and do the prediction again we've
run we could have just set a variable
equal to this instead of re-running it
each time but we're going to run it
again clf dot predict test features
remember that returns the zeros the ones
and the twos and then we're going to set
that equal to predictions so this time
we're actually putting it in a variable
and when i run this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versa color
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
let's put that down here and paste it
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together
the first one
is our predictions and i went ahead and
did uh predictions through 25 let's just
do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species i remember i could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says setosa satosa setosa
setosa and they match
so the first one is what our
forest is doing and the second one is
what the actual data is now is we need
to combine these so that we can
understand what that means we need to
know how good our forest is how good it
is at predicting the features so that's
where we come up to the next step which
is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm going to because i'm on
the jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're going to create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas and
we're doing a cross tab this function
takes two sets of data and creates a
chart out of them so when i run it
you'll get a nice chart down here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you add 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
percent accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting before we wrap it up so let's
flip back on over to my script in here
we're going to take this line of code
from up above i don't know if you
remember it but predix equals the
iris.target underscore names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this introducing naive
bayes classifier have you ever wondered
how your mail provider implements spam
filtering or how online news channels
perform news text classification or how
companies perform sentimental analysis
of their audience on social media all of
this and more is done through a machine
learning algorithm called naive bayes
classifier welcome to naive bayes
tutorial my name is richard kirschner
i'm with the simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead what's in it for you we'll start
with what is naive bayes a basic
overview of how it works we'll get into
naive bayes and machine learning where
it fits in with our other machine
learning tools why do we need naive
bayes and understanding naive bayes
classifier a much more in depth of how
the math works in the background finally
we'll get into the advantages of the
nave bayes classifier in the machine
learning setup and then we'll roll up
our sleeves and do my favorite part
we'll actually do some python coding and
do some text classification using the
naive bayes what is naive bayes let's
start with a basic introduction to the
bayes theorem named after thomas bayes
from the 1700s who first coined this in
the western literature naive bayes
classifier works on the principle of
conditional probability as given by the
bayes theorem before we move ahead let
us go through some of the simple
concepts in the probability that we will
be using let us consider the following
example of tossing two coins here we
have two quarters and if we look at all
the different possibilities of what they
can come up as we get that they could
come up as head heads they come up as
head tail tail head and tell tell when
doing the math on probability we usually
denote probability as a p a capital p so
the probability of getting two heads
equals one fourth you can see on our
data set we have two heads and this
occurs once out of the four
possibilities and then the probability
of at least one tail occurs
three-quarters of the time you'll see in
three of the coin tosses we have tails
in them and out of four that's
three-fourths and then the probability
of the second coin being head given the
first coin is tail is one half and the
probability of getting two heads given
the first coin is a head is one half
we'll demonstrate that in just a minute
and show you how that math works now
when we're doing it with two coins it's
easy to see but when you have something
more complex you can see where these pro
these formulas really come in and work
so the bayes theorem gives us the
conditional probability of an event a
given another event b has occurred in
this case the first coin toss will be b
and the second coin toss a this can be
confusing because we've actually
reversed the order of them and go from b
to a instead of a to b you'll see this a
lot when you work in probabilities the
reason is we're looking for event a we
want to know what that is so we're going
to label that a since that's our focus
and then given another event b has
occurred in the bayes theorem as you can
see on the left the probability of a
occurring given b has occurred equals
the probability of b occurring given a
has occurred times a probability of a
over the probability of b this simple
formula can be moved around just like
any algebra formula and we could do the
probability of a after a given b times
probability of b equals the probability
of b given a times probability of a you
can easily move that around and multiply
it and divide it out let us apply bayes
theorem to our example here we have our
two quarters and we'll notice that the
first two probabilities of getting two
heads and at least one tail we compute
directly off the data so you can easily
see that we have
one example h out of four one fourth and
we have three with tails in them giving
us three quarters or three four seventy
five percent
the second condition the second uh set
three and four we're gonna explore a
little bit more in detail now we stick
to a simple example with two coins
because you can easily understand the
math the probability of throwing a tail
doesn't matter what comes before it and
the same with the head so it's still
going to be 50 percent or one half but
when that come when that probability
gets more complicated let's say you have
a d6 dice or some other instance then
this formula really comes in handy but
let's stick to the simple example for
now in this sample space let a be the
event that the second coin is head and b
be the event that the first coin is
tells again we reversed it because we
want to know what the second event is
going to be so we're going to be
focusing on a and we write that out as a
probability of a given b and we know
this from our formula that that equals
the probability of b given a times the
probability of a over the probability of
b and when we plug that in we plug in
the probability of the first coin being
tails given the second coin is heads and
the probability of the second coin being
heads given the first coin being over
the probability of the first coin being
tails when we plug that data in and we
have the probability of the first coin
being tails given the second coin is
heads times the probability of the
second coin being heads over the
probability of the first coin being
tails you can see it's a simple formula
to calculate we have one half times one
half over one half or one half equals
point five or one fourth so the bayes
theorem basically calculates the
conditional probability of the
occurrence of an event based on prior
knowledge of conditions that might be
related to the event we will explore
this in detail when we take up an
example of online shopping further in
this tutorial understanding naive bayes
and machine learning like with any of
our other machine learning tools it's
important to understand where the naive
bayes fits in the hierarchy so under the
machine learning we have supervised
learning and there is other things like
unsupervised learning there's also
reward system this falls under the
supervised learning and then under the
surprise learning there's classification
there's also regression but we're going
to be in the classification side and
then under classification is your naive
bayes let's go ahead and glance into
where is naive bayes used let's look at
some of the use scenarios for it as a
classifier we use it in face recognition
is this cindy or is it not cindy or
whoever or it might be used to identify
parts of the face that they then feed
into another part of the face
recognition program this is the eye this
is the nose this is the mouth weather
prediction is it going to be rainy or
sunny medical recognition news
prediction it's also used in medical
diagnosis we might diagnose somebody as
either as high risk or not as high risk
for cancer or heart disease or other
ailments and news classification we look
at the google news and it says well is
this political or is this world news or
a lot of that's all done with a naive
bayes understanding naive bayes
classifier now we already went through a
basic understanding with the coins and
the two heads and two tails and head
tail tail heads etc we're going to do
just a quick review on that and remind
you that the naive bayes classifier is
based on the bayes theorem which gives a
conditional probability of event a given
event b and that's where the probability
of a given b equals the probability of b
given a times probability of a over
probability of b remember this is an
algebraic function so we can move these
different entities around we can
multiply by the probability of b so it
goes to the left hand side and then we
can divide by the probability of a given
b and just as easily come up with a new
formula for the probability of b to me
staring at these algebraic functions
kind of gives me a slight headache
it's a lot better to see if we can
actually understand how this data fits
together in a table and let's go ahead
and start applying it to some actual
data so you can see what that looks like
so we're going to start with the
shopping demo problem statement and
remember we're going to solve this first
in
table form so you can see what the math
looks like and then we're going to solve
it in python and in here we want to
predict whether the person will purchase
a product are they going to buy or don't
buy very important if you're running a
business you want to know how to
maximize your profits or at least
maximize the purchase of the people
coming into your store and we're going
to look at a specific combination of
different variables in this case we're
going to look at the day the discount
and the free delivery and you can see
here under the day we want to know
whether it's on the weekday you know
somebody's working they come in after
work or maybe they don't work weekend
you can see the bright colors coming
down there celebrating not being in work
or holiday and did we offer a discount
that day yes or no did we offer free
delivery that day yes or no and from
this we want to know whether the person
is going to buy based on these traits so
we can maximize them and find out the
best system for getting somebody to come
in and purchase our goods and products
from our store now having a nice visual
is great but we do need to dig into the
data so let's go ahead and take a look
at the data set we have a small sample
data set of 30 rows we're showing you
the first 15 of those rows for this demo
now the actual data file you can request
just type in below under the comments on
the youtube video and we'll send you
some more information and send you that
file as you can see here the file is
very simple columns and rows we have the
day the discount the free delivery and
did the person purchase or not and then
we have under the day whether it was a
weekday a holiday was it the weekend
this is a pretty simple set of data and
long before computers people used to
look at this data and calculate this all
by hand so let's go ahead and walk
through this and see what that looks
like when we put that into tables also
note in today's world we're not usually
looking at three different variables in
30 rows nowadays because we're able to
collect data so much we're usually
looking at 27 30 variables across
hundreds of rows the first thing we want
to do is we're going to take this data
and based on the data set containing our
three inputs day discount and free
delivery we're going to go ahead and
populate that to frequency tables for
each attribute so we want to know if
they had a discount how many people
buy and did not buy did they have a
discount yes or no do we have a free
delivery yes or no on those dates how
many people made a purchase how many
people didn't and the same with the
three days of the week was it a weekday
a weekend a holiday and did they buy yes
or no as we dig in deeper to this table
for our bayes theorem let the event buy
ba now remember we looked at the coins i
said we really want to know what the
outcome is did the person buy or not and
that's usually event a is what you're
looking for and the independent
variables discount free delivery and day
bb so we'll call that probability of b
now let us calculate the likelihood
table for one of the variables let's
start with day which includes weekday
weekend and holiday and let us start by
summing all of our rows so we have the
weekday row and out of the weekdays
there's nine plus two so it's 11
weekdays there's eight weekend days and
11 holidays wow it's a lot of holidays
and then we want to sum up the total
number of days so we're looking at a
total of 30 days let's start pulling
some information from our chart and see
where that takes us and when we fill in
the chart on the right you can see that
9 out of 24 purchases are made on the
weekday 7 out of 24 purchases on the
weekend and 8 out of 24 purchases on a
holiday and out of all the people come
in 24 out of 30 purchase you can also
see how many people do not purchase on
the weekdays two out of six didn't
purchase and so on and so on we can also
look at the totals and you'll see on the
right we put together some of the
formulas the probability of making a
purchase on the weekend comes out 11 out
of 30. so out of the 30 people who came
into the store throughout the weekend
weekday and holiday 11 of those
purchases were made on the weekday and
then you can also see the probability of
them not making a purchase and this is
done for doesn't matter which day of the
week so we call that probability of no
buy would be six over 30 or 0.2 so
there's a 20 chance that they're not
going to make a purchase no matter what
day of the week it is and finally we
look at the probability of b of a in
this case we're going to look at the
probability of the weekday and not
buying two of the no buys were done out
of the weekend out of the six people who
did not make purchases so when we look
at that probability of the weekday
without a purchase is going to be 0.33
or 33 percent let's take a look at this
at different probabilities and based on
this likelihood table let's go ahead and
calculate conditional probabilities as
below the first three we just did the
probability of making a purchase on the
weekday is 11 out of 30 or roughly 36 or
37 percent 0.367 the probability of not
making a purchase at all doesn't matter
what day of the week is roughly 0.2 or
20 percent and the probability of a
weekday no purchase is roughly two out
of six so two out of six of our no
purchases were made on the weekday and
then finally we take our p of a b
if you look we've kept the symbols up
there we got p of probability of b
probability of a probability of b if a
we should remember that the probability
of a if b
is equal to the first one times the
probability of no buys over the
probability of the weekday so we could
calculate it both off the
table we created we can also calculate
this by the formula and we get the 0.367
which equals or 0.33 times 0.2 over
0.367 which equals 0.179
or roughly uh 17 to 18 percent and
that'd be the probability of no purchase
done on the weekday and this is
important because we can look at this
and say as the probability of buying on
the weekday is more than the probability
of not buying on the weekday we can
conclude that customers will most likely
buy the product on a weekday now we've
kept our charts simple and we're only
looking at one aspect so you should be
able to look at the table and come up
with the same information or the same
conclusion that should be kind of
intuitive at this point next we can take
the same setup we have the frequency
tables of all three independent
variables now we can construct the
likelihood tables for all three of the
variables we're working with we can take
our day like we did before we have
weekday weekend and holiday we filled in
this table and then we can come in and
also do that for the discount yes or no
did they buy yes or no and we fill in
that full table so now we have our
probabilities for a discount and whether
the discount leads to a purchase or not
and the probability for free delivery
does that lead to a purchase or not and
this is where it starts getting really
exciting let us use these three
likelihood tables to calculate whether a
customer will purchase a product on a
specific combination of day discount and
free delivery or not purchase here let
us take a combination of these factors
day equals holiday discount equals yes
free delivery equals yes let's dig
deeper into the math and actually see
what this looks like and we're going to
start with looking for the probability
of them not purchasing on the following
combinations of days we're actually
looking for the probability of a equal
no buy no purchase and our probability
of b we're going to set equal to is it a
holiday did they get a discount yes and
was it a free delivery yes before we go
further let's look at the original
equation the probability of a if b
equals the probability of b given the
condition a and the probability times
probability of a over the probability of
b occurring now this is basic algebra so
we can multiply this information
together so when you see the probability
of a
given b in this case the condition is b
c and d or the three different variables
we're looking at and when you see the
probability of b that would be the
conditions we're actually going to
multiply those three separate conditions
out probability of you'll see that in a
second in the formula times the full
probability of a over the full
probability of b so here we are back to
this and we're going to have let a equal
no purchase and we're looking for the
probability of b on the condition a
where a sets for three different things
remember that equals the probability of
a given the condition b
and in this case we just multiply those
three different variables together so we
have the probability of the discount
times the probability of free delivery
times the probability is the day equal a
holiday those are our three variables of
the probability of a if b and then that
is going to be multiplied by the
probability of them not making a
purchase and then we want to divide that
by the total probabilities and they're
multiplied together so we have the
probability of a discount the
probability of a free delivery and the
probability of it being on a holiday
when we plug those numbers in we see
that one out of six were no purchase on
a discounted day two out of six were a
no purchase on a free delivery day and
three out of six were a no purchase on a
holiday those are our three
probabilities of a if b multiplied out
and then that has to be multiplied by
the probability of a no purchase and
remember the prop probability of a no by
is across all the data so that's where
we get the 6 out of 30. we divide that
out by the probability of each category
over the total number so we get the 20
out of 30 had a discount 23 out of 30
had a yes for free delivery and 11 out
of 30 were on a holiday we plug all
those numbers in we get point one seven
eight so in our probability math we have
a point one seven eight if it's a no buy
for a holiday a discount and a free
delivery let's turn that around and see
what that looks like if we have a
purchase i promise this is the last page
of math before we dig into the python
script so here we're calculating the
probability of the purchase using the
same math we did to find out if they
didn't buy now we want to know if they
did buy and again we're going to go by
the day equals a holiday discount equals
yes free delivery equals yes and let a
equal buy now right about now you might
be asking why are we doing both
calculations why why would we want to
know the no buys and buys for the same
data going in well we're going to show
you that in just a moment but we have to
have both of those pieces of information
so that we can figure it out as a
percentage as opposed to a probability
equation and we'll get to that
normalization here in just a moment
let's go ahead and walk through this
calculation and as you can see here the
probability of a on the condition of b b
being all three categories did we have a
discount with a purchase do we have a
free delivery with a purchase and did we
is a day equal to holiday and when we
plug this all into that formula and
multiply it all out we get our
probability of a discount probability of
a free delivery probability of the day
being a holiday times the overall
probability of it being a purchase
divided by again multiplying the three
variables out the full probability of
there being a discount the full
probability of being a free delivery and
the full probability of there being a
day equal holiday and that's where we
get this 19 over 24 times 21 over 24
times 8 over 24 times the p of a 24 over
30 divided by the probability of the
discount the free delivery times the day
or 20 over 30 23 over 30 times 11 over
30 and that gives us our 0.986
so what are we going to do with these
two pieces of data we just generated
well let's go ahead and go over them we
have a probability of purchase equals
0.986 we have a probability of no
purchase equals 0.178
so finally we have a conditional
probabilities of purchase on this day
let us take that we're going to
normalize it and we're going to take
these probabilities and turn them into
percentages this is simply done by
taking the sum of probabilities which
equals 0.98686
plus 0.178 and that equals the 1.164
if we divide each probability by the sum
we get the percentage and so the
likelihood of a purchase is 84.71
percent and the likelihood of no
purchase is 15.29
given these three different variables so
it's if it's on a holiday if it's a with
a discount and has free delivery then
there's an 84.71 percent chance that the
customer is going to come in and make a
purchase hooray they purchased our stuff
we're making money if you're owning a
shop that's like is the bottom line is
you want to make some money so you keep
your shop open and have a living now i
promised you that we were going to be
finishing up the math here with a few
pages so we're going to move on and
we're going to do two steps the first
step is i want you to understand
why you want to under why you want to
use the naive bayes what are the
advantages of naive bayes and then once
we understand those advantages we'll
just look at that briefly then we're
going to dive in and do some python
coding advantages of naive bayes
classifier so let's take a look at the
six advantages of the naive bayes
classifier and we're going to walk
around this lovely wheel looks like an
origami folded paper the first one is
very simple and easy to implement
certainly you could walk through the
tables and do this by hand you got to be
a little careful because the notations
can get confusing you have all these
different probabilities and i certainly
mess those up as i put them on you know
is it on the top of the bottom got to
really pay close attention to that when
you put it into python it's really nice
because you don't have to worry about
any of that you let the python handle
that the python module but understanding
it you can put it on a table and you can
easily see how it works and it's a
simple algebraic function it needs less
training data so if you have smaller
amounts of data this is great powerful
tool for that handles both continuous
and discrete data it's highly scalable
with number of predictors and data
points so as you can see you just keep
multiplying different probabilities in
there and you can cover not just three
different variables or sets you can now
expand this to even more categories
number five it's fast it can be used in
real time predictions this is so
important this is why it's used in a lot
of our predictions on online shopping
carts uh referrals spam filters is
because there's no time delay as it has
to go through and figure out a neural
network or one of the other mini setups
where you're doing classification and
certainly there's a lot of other tools
out there in the machine learning that
can handle these
but most of them are not as fast as a
naive bayes and then finally it's not
sensitive to irrelevant features so it
picks up on your different probabilities
and if you're short on date on one
probability you can kind of it
automatically adjust for that those
formulas are very automatic and so you
can still get a very solid
predictability even if you're missing
data or you have overlapping data for
two completely different areas we see
that a lot in doing census and studying
of people and habits where they might
have one study that covers one aspect
another one that overlaps and because
the two overlap they can then predict
the unknowns for the group that they
haven't done the second study on or vice
versa so it's very powerful in that it
is not sensitive to the irrelevant
features and in fact you can use it to
help predict features that aren't even
in there so now we're down to my
favorite part we're going to roll up our
sleeves and do some actual programming
we're going to do the use case text
classification now i would challenge you
to go back and send us a note on the
notes below underneath the video and
request the data for the shopping cart
so you can plug that into python code
and do that on your own time so you can
walk through it since we walk through
all the information on it but we're
going to do a python code doing text
classification very popular for doing
the naive bayes so we're going to use
our new tool to perform a text
classification of news headlines and
classify news into different topics for
a news website as you can see here we
have a nice image of the google news and
then related on the right subgroups i'm
not sure where they actually pulled the
actual data we're going to use from it's
one of the standard sets but certainly
this can be used on any of our news
headlines in classification so let's see
how it can be done using the naive bayes
classifier now we're at my favorite part
we're actually going to write some
python script roll up our sleeves and
we're going to start by doing our
imports these are very basic imports
including our news group and we'll take
a quick glance at the target names then
we're going to go ahead and start
training our data set and putting it
together we'll put together a nice graph
because it's always good to have a graph
to show what's going on and once we've
traded it and we've shown you a graph of
what's going on then we're going to
explore how to use it and see what that
looks like now i'm going to open up my
favorite editor or inline editor for
python you don't have to use this you
can use whatever your editor that you
like whatever interface ide you want
this just happens to be the anaconda
jupiter notebook and i'm going to paste
that first piece of code in here so we
can walk through it let's make it a
little bigger on the screen so you have
a nice view of what's going on uh and
we're using python 3 in this case 3.5 so
this would work in any of your 3x
if you have it set up correctly it
should also work in a lot of the 2x you
just have to make sure all of the
versions of the modules match your
python version and in here you'll notice
the first line is your percentage matte
plot library inline now three of these
lines of code are all about plotting the
graph
this one lets the notebook notes as an
inline setup that we want the graphs to
show up on this page without it in a
notebook like this which is an explorer
interface it won't show up now a lot of
ides don't require that a lot of them
like on if i'm working on one of my
other setups it just has a pop-up and
the graph pops up on there so you have a
that setup also but for this we want the
matplot library inline and then we're
going to import numpy as np that's
number python which has a lot of
different formulas in it that we use for
both of our sklearn module and we also
use it for any of the upper math
functions in python and it's very common
to see that as np numpy as np the next
two lines are all about our graphing
remember i said three of these were
about graphing well we need our
mapplotlibrary.pi plot as plt and you'll
see that plt is a very common setup as
is the sns and just like the np and
we're going to import seaborn as sns and
we're going to do the sns.set
now seaborn sits on top of pi plot and
it just makes a really nice heat map
it's really good for heat maps and if
you're not familiar with heat maps that
just means we give it a color scale the
term comes from the brighter red it is
the hotter it is in some form of data
and you can set it to whatever you want
and we'll see that later on so those
you'll see that those three lines of
code here are just importing the graph
function so we can graph it and as a
data science test you always want to
graph your data and have some kind of
visual it's really hard just to shove
numbers in front of people and they look
at it and it doesn't mean anything and
then from the sklearn.datasets
we're going to import the fetch 20 news
groups very common one for analyzing
tokenizing words and setting them up and
exploring how the words work and how do
you categorize different things when
you're dealing with documents and then
we set our data equal to fetch 20 news
groups so our data variable will have
the data in it and we're going to go
ahead and just print the target names
data.target names and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see here we
have alt atheism comp graphics comp osms
windows dot miscellaneous and it goes
all the way down to talk politics dot
miscellaneous talk religion dot
miscellaneous these are the categories
they've already assigned to this news
group and it's called fetch 20 because
you'll see there's i believe there's 20
different topics in here or 20 different
categories as we scroll down now we've
gone through the 20 different categories
and we're going to go ahead and start
defining all the categories and set up
our data so we're actually getting here
going to go ahead and get it get the
data all set up and take a look at our
data and let's move this over to our
jupyter notebook
and let's see what this code does
first we're going to set our categories
now if you noticed up here i could have
just as easily set this equal to
data.target underscore names because
it's the same thing but we want to kind
of spell it out for you so you can see
the different categories it kind of
makes it more visual so you can see what
your data is looking like in the
background once we've created the
categories
we're going to open up a train set so
this training set of data is going to go
into fetch 20 news groups and it's a
subset in there called train and
categories equals categories so we're
pulling out those categories that match
and then if you have a train set you
should also have the testing set we have
test equals fetch 20 news group subset
equals test and categories equals
categories let's go down one size so it
all fits on my screen there we go and
just so we can really see what's going
on let's see what happens when we print
out
one part of that data so
it creates train and under train it
creates train dot data and we're just
going to look at data piece number five
and let's go ahead and run that and see
what that looks like and you can see
when i print train dot data number five
under train it prints out one of the
articles this is article number five you
can go through and read it on there and
we can also go in here and change this
to test which should look identical
because it's splitting the data up into
different groups train and test and
we'll see test number five is a
different article but it's another
article in here and maybe you're curious
and you want to see just how many
articles are in here we could do
length
of train dot data and if we run that
you'll see that the training data has 11
314 articles so we're not going to go
through all those articles that's a lot
of articles but we can look at one of
them just you can see what kind of
information is coming out of it and what
we're looking at and we'll just look at
number five for today and here we have
it rewording the second amendment ids
vtt line 58 lines 58 in article
etc you can scroll all the way down and
see all the different parts to there now
we've looked at it and that's pretty
complicated when you look at one of
these articles to try to figure out how
do you weight this if you look down here
we have different words and maybe the
word from well from is probably in all
the articles so it's not going to have a
lot of meaning as far as trying to
figure out whether this article fits one
of the categories or not so trying to
figure out which category fits in based
on these words is where the challenge
comes in now that we've viewed our data
we're going to dive in and do the actual
predictions this is the actual naive
bayes and we're going to throw another
model at you or another module at you
here in just a second we can't go into
too much detail but it deals
specifically working with words and text
and what they call tokenizing those
words
so let's take this code and let's uh
skip on over to our jupiter notebook and
walk through it and here we are in our
jupyter notebook let's paste that in
there and i can run this code right off
the bat it's not actually going to
display anything yet but it has a lot
going on in here so the top we have the
print module from the earlier one i
didn't know why that was in there so
we're going to start by importing our
necessary packages and from the sklearn
features extraction dot text we're going
to import tf idf vectorizer i told you
we're going to throw a module at you we
can't go too much into the math behind
this or how it works you can look it up
the notation for the math is usually
tf.idf
and that's just a way of weighing the
words and it weighs the words based on
how many times they're used in a
document how many times or how many
documents they're used in and it's a
well used formula that's been around for
a while it's a little confusing to put
this in here
but let's let her know that it just goes
in there and waits the different words
in the document for us that way we don't
have to wait and if you put a weight on
it if you remember i was talking about
that up here earlier if these are all
emails they probably all have the word
from in them from probably has a very
low weight it has very little value in
telling you what this document's about
same with words like in an article in
articles in cost of on maybe cost might
or where words like criminal weapons
destruction these might have a heavier
weight because they describe a little
bit more what the article is doing well
how do you figure out all those weights
in the different articles that's what
this module does that's what the tf idf
vectorizer is going to do for us and
then we're going to import our
sklearn.naive bayes and that's our
multinomial nb
multinomial naive bayes pretty easy to
understand that where that comes from
and then finally we have the skylearn
pipeline import make pipeline now the
make pipeline is just a cool piece of
code because we're going to take the
information we get from the tf idf
vectorizer and we're going to pump that
into the multinomial nb
so a pipeline is just a way of
organizing how things flow it's used
commonly you probably already guessed
what it is if you've done any businesses
they talk about the sales pipeline
if you're on a work crew or project
manager you have your pipeline of
information that's going through or your
projects and what has to be done in what
order that's all this pipeline is
we're going to take the tfid vectorizer
and then we're going to push that into
the multinomial nb now we've designated
that as the variable model we have our
pipeline model and we're going to take
that model and this is just so elegant
this is done in just a couple lines of
code model dot fit and we're going to
fit the data and first the train data
and then the train target
now the train data has the different
articles in it you can see the one we
were just looking at and the train dot
target is what category they already
categorized that that particular article
as and what's happening here is the
train data is going into the tf id
vectorizer so when you have one of these
articles that goes in there it weights
all the words in there so there's
thousands of words with different
weights on them i remember once running
a model on this and i literally had 2.4
million tokens go into this
so when you're doing like large document
bases you can have a huge number of
different words it then takes those
words gives them a weight and then based
on that weight based on the words and
the weights and then puts that into the
multinomial in b and once we go into our
naive bayes
we want to put the train target in there
so the train data that's been mapped to
the tfid vectorizer is now going through
the multinomial in b and then we're
telling it well these are the answers
these are the answers to the different
documents so this document that has all
these words with these different weights
from the first part is going to be
whatever category it comes out of maybe
it's the
talk show or the article on religion
miscellaneous once we fit that model we
can then take labels and we're going to
set that equal to model.predict
most of the sklearn used the term dot
predict to let us know that we've now
trained the model and now we want to get
some answers and we're going to put our
test data in there because our test data
is the stuff we held off to the side we
didn't train it on there and we don't
know what's going to come up out of it
and we just want to find out how good
our labels are do they match what they
should be now i've already run this
through there's no actual output to it
to show this is just setting it all up
this is just training our model creating
the labels so we can see how good it is
and then we move on to the next step to
find out what happened to do this we're
going to go ahead and create a confusion
matrix and a heat map so
the confusion matrix which is confusing
just by its very name is basically going
to ask how confused is our answer did it
get it correct or did it miss some
things in there or have some mis labels
and then we're going to put that on a
heat map so we'll have some nice colors
to look at to see how that plots out
let's go ahead and take this code and
see how that take a walk through it and
see what that looks like so back to our
jupiter notebook i'm going to put the
code in there and let's go ahead and run
that code
take it just a moment and remember we
had the inline that way my graph shows
up on the inline here
and let's walk through the code and then
we'll look at this and see what that
means so let me get a little bit bigger
there we go no reason not to use a whole
screen too big so we have here from sk
learn metrics import confusion matrix
and that's just going to generate a set
of data that says i the prediction was
such the actual
truth was either agreed with it or is
something different and it's going to
add up those numbers so we can take a
look and just see how well it worked and
we're going to set a variable matt equal
to confusion matrix we have our test
target our test data that was not part
of the training
very important in data science we always
keep our test data separate
otherwise it's not a valid model if we
can't properly test it with new data and
this is the labels we created from that
test data these are the ones that we
predict it's going to be so we go in and
we create our sn heat map the sns is our
seaborn which sits on top of the pi plot
so we create a sns dot heat map we take
our confusion matrix and it's going to
be mat dot t and do we have other
variables that go into the sns.heat map
we're not going to go into detail what
all the variables mean the annotation
equals true that's what tells it to put
the numbers here so you have the 166 the
one the zero zero zero one format d and
c bar equals false have to do with the
uh format if you take those out you'll
see that some things disappear and then
the x tick labels and the y tick labels
those are our target names and you can
see right here that's the alt atheism
comp graphics comp osms windows dot
miscellaneous and then finally we have
our plt dot x label remember the sns or
the seaborn sits on top of our matplot
library our plt and so we want to just
tell it x label equals a true is is true
the labels are true and then the y label
is prediction label so we say a true
this is what it actually is and the
prediction is what we predicted and
let's look at this graph because that's
probably a little confusing the way i
rattled through it and what i'm going to
do is i'm going to go ahead and flip
back to the slides because they have a
black background they put in there that
helps it shine a little bit better so
you can see the graph a little bit
easier so in reading this graph what we
want to look at is how the color scheme
has come out and you'll see a line right
down the middle diagonally from upper
left to bottom right what that is is if
you look at the labels we have our
predicted label on the left and our true
label on the right those are the numbers
where the prediction and the true come
together and this is what we want to see
is we want to see those lit up that's
what that heat map does as you can see
that it did a good job of finding those
data and you'll notice that there's a
couple of red spots on there where it
missed you know it's a little confused
we talk about talk religion
miscellaneous versus talk politics
miscellaneous social religion christian
versus alt atheism it mislabeled some of
those and those are very similar topics
so you could understand why it might
mislabel them but overall it did a
pretty good job if we're going to create
these models we want to go ahead and be
able to use them so let's see what that
looks like to do this let's go ahead and
create a definition a function to run
and we're going to call this function
let me just expand that just a notch
here there we go i like mine in big
letters predict categories we want to
predict the category we're going to send
it s a string and then we're sending it
train equals train we have our training
model and then we had our pipeline model
equals model this way we don't have to
resend these variables each time
the definition knows that because i said
train equals train and i put the equal
for model and then we're going to set
the prediction equal to the
model.predict s so it's going to send
whatever
string we send to it it's going to push
that string through the pipeline the
model pipeline it's going to go through
and tokenize it and put it through the
tf idf convert that into numbers and
weights for all the different documents
and words and then i'll put that through
our naive bayes and from it we'll go
ahead and get our prediction we're going
to predict what value it is and so we're
going to return train dot target names
predict of zero and remember that the
train dot target names that's just
categories i could have just as easily
put categories in there dot predict of
zero so we're taking the prediction
which is a number and we're converting
it to an actual category we're
converting it from i don't know what the
actual numbers are but let's say zero
equals alt atheism so we're going to
convert that zero to the word or
one maybe it equals comp graphics so
we're going to convert number one into
comp graphics that's all that is and
then we gotta go ahead and and then we
need to go ahead and run this so i load
that up and then once i run that we can
start doing some predictions let me go
ahead and type in predict category
and let's just do predict category jesus
christ and it comes back and says it's
social religion christian that's pretty
good
now note i didn't put print on this one
the nice things about the jupiter
notebook editor and a lot of inline
editors is if you just put the name of
the variable out as returning the
variable train dot target underscore
names it'll automatically print that for
you in your own id you might have to put
in print let's see where else we can
take this and maybe you're a space
science buff so how about sending
load to
international
space station
and if we run that
we get science space
or maybe you're a
automobile buff and let's do oh they're
going to tell me audi is better than bmw
but i'm going to do bmw is better
than an audi so maybe your car buff and
we run that and you'll see it says
recreational i'm assuming that's what
rec stands for autos so i did a pretty
good job labeling that one how about if
we have something like a caption running
through there president of india and if
we run that
it comes up and says talk politics
miscellaneous so when we take our
definition our function and we run all
these things through kudos we made it we
were able to correctly classify texts
into different groups based on which
category they belong to using the naive
bayes classifier now we did throw in the
pipeline the tf idea vectorizer we threw
in the graphs those are all things that
you don't necessarily have to know to
understand the naive bayes setup or
classifier but they're important to know
one of the main uses for the naive bayes
is with the tf idf tokenizer vectorizer
where tokenizes the word and as labels
and we use the pipeline because you need
to push all that data through and it
makes it really easy and fast you don't
have to know those to understand naive
bayes but they certainly help for
understanding the industry and data
science and we can see our categorizer
our naive bayes classifier we were able
to predict the category religion space
motorcycles autos politics and properly
classify all these different things we
pushed into our prediction and our
trained model before we dive into the
svm let's take a look at applications of
the support vector machine at least some
general ones that are commonly used with
it face detection text and hyper text
categorization classification of images
and bioinformatics these are only about
a few of those that are used with this
svm as we go through this lesson see if
you can figure out what other ones you
could apply it to and also what you
would want to use some other tools for
so in this example last week my son and
i visited a fruit shop dad is that an
apple or a strawberry so the question
comes up what fruit do they just pick up
from the fruit stand after a couple of
seconds you can figure out that it was a
strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh why not build
a model which can predict an unknown
data and in this we're going to be
looking at some sweet strawberries or
crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and already labeled as such
we already have a bunch of apples we
know our apples and are labeled as such
then once we train our model that model
then can be given the new data and the
new data is this image in this case you
can see a question mark on it and it
comes through and goes it's a strawberry
in this case we're using the support
vector machine model svm is a supervised
learning method that looks at data and
sorts it into one of two categories and
in this case we're sorting the
strawberry into the strawberry site at
this point you should be asking the
question how does the prediction work
before we dig into an example with
numbers let's apply this to our fruit
scenario we have our support vector
machine we've taken it and we've taken
labeled sample of data strawberries and
apples and we draw on a line down the
middle between the two groups this split
now allows us to take new data in this
case an apple and a strawberry and place
them in the appropriate group based on
which side of the line they fall in and
that way we can predict the unknown as
colorful and tasty as the fruit example
is let's take a look at another example
with some numbers involved and we can
take a closer look at how the math works
in this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set of female
where you have their height and weight
174 65 174 88 and so on and we'll need a
sample data set of the male they have a
height 179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's
go ahead and put this on a graph so we
have a nice visual so you can see here
we have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we draw in two lines through the data in
the middle that separates them in from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as possible in technical terms we
can say the distance between the support
vector and the hyperplane should be as
far as possible and this is where the
support vectors are the extreme points
in the data set and if you look at this
data set they have circled two points
which seem to be right on the outskirts
of the woman and one on the outskirts of
the men and hyperplane has a maximum
distance to the support vectors of any
class now you'll see the line down the
middle and we call this the hyperplane
because when you're dealing with
multiple dimensions it's really not just
a line but a plane of intersections and
you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest negative point
which is on the women's side the sum of
d plus and d minus is called the
distance margin or the distance between
the two support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender hopefully that's clear how
that works on a visual level as a data
scientist you should also be asking what
happens if the hyperplane is not optimal
if we select a hyperplane having low
margin then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called referred to as the ls vm so
far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a 1d view of the data to
a two-dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1d input and
transfer it to a two-dimensional output
as you can see in this picture here the
1d when transferred to a two-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets what if we
make it even more complicated how do we
perform an svm for this type of data set
here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and document so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be over fitted to
a very specific instance or it's going
to be biased to a high or low value with
the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms these three
advantages of the support vector machine
make it a very powerful tool to add to
your repertoire of machine learning
tools now we did promise you a used case
study we're actually going to dive into
some python programming and so we're
going to go into a problem statement and
start off with the zoo so in the zoo
example we have family members going to
the zoo when we have the young child
going dead is that a group of crocodiles
or alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work especially
as a young child and so we can see the
parents sitting here thinking well what
is the difference between a crocodile
and an alligator well one crocodiles are
larger in size alligators are smaller in
size snout width the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout and of course in the modern day
and age the father is sitting here
thinking how can i turn this into a
lesson for my son and he goes let a
support vector machine segregate the two
groups i don't know if my dad ever told
me that but that would be funny now in
this example we're not going to use
actual measurements and data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up but let's
roll up our sleeves and we'll talk about
that more in just a moment as we break
into our python script so here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into a python editor in just a
moment but let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover first we're
going to cover in the code the setup how
to actually create our svm and you're
going to find that there's only two
lines of code that actually create it
and the rest of it is done so quick and
fast that it's all here in the first
page and we'll show you what that looks
like as far as our data because we're
going to create some data i talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blobs and we'll go through that
in just a second and then the second
part is we're going to take this and
we're going to bump it up a notch we're
going to show you what it looks like
behind the scenes but let's start with
actually creating our setup i like to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook
because it's very easy to use but you
can use any of your favorite python
editors or setups and go in there but
let's go ahead and switch over there and
see what that looks like so here we are
in the anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupyter notebook with python
we're using python 3. i believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and
you'd have to look at the sklearn and
make sure if you're using a 2x version
an earlier version let's go and put our
code in there and one of the things i
like about the jupiter notebook is i go
up to view and i'm going to go ahead and
toggle the line numbers on to make it a
little bit easier to talk about and we
can even increase the size because this
is edited in this case i'm using google
chrome explorer and that's how it opens
up for the editor although anyone any
like i said any editor will work now the
first step is going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as np and matplot library dot pi plot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python we need that
because part of the platform we're using
uses that for the numpy array and i'll
talk about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus the standard python array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use np for numpy the map plot library
is how we're going to view our data so
this has uh you do need the np for the
sk learn module but the map plot library
is purely for our use for visualization
and so you really don't need that for
the svm but we're going to put it there
so you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at and
then finally we're gonna i'm gonna jump
one ahead to line number four that's the
sklearn.datasets.samplesgenerator
import and make blobs and i told you
that we were going to make up data and
this is a tool that's in the sk learning
to make up data i personally don't want
to go to the zoo get in trouble for
jumping over the fence and probably get
eaten by the crocodiles or alligators as
i work on measuring their snouts and
width and length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your your setup and you're not sure
about what data you're going to put in
there you can create this blob and it
makes it real easy to use and finally we
have our actual svm the sklearn import
svm on line three so that covers all our
imports we're going to create remember i
use the make blobs to create data and
we're going to create a capital x and a
lowercase y equals make blobs in samples
equals 40 so we're going to make 40
lines of data it's going to have two
centers with a random state equals 20 so
which each each group is going to have
20 different pieces of data in it and
the way that looks is that we'll have
under x
an x y plane so i have two numbers under
x and y will be zero one that's the two
different centers so we have yes or no
in this case alligator or crocodile
that's what that represents and then i
told you that the actual sk learner the
svm is in two lines of code and we see
it right here with clf equals svm dot
svc kernel equals linear and i set sql
to one although in this example since we
are not uh regularizing the data because
we want to be very clear and easy to see
i went ahead you can set it to a
thousand a lot of times when you're not
doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
it'll be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit x comma y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and i'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish
on the other side that's our two sets of
data they represent one represents
crocodiles and one represents alligators
and then we have our measurements in
this case we have like the width and
length of the snout and i did say i was
going to come up here and talk just a
little bit about our plot and you'll see
plt that's what we imported we're going
to do a scatter plot that means we're
just putting dots on there and then look
at this notation i have the capital x
and then in brackets i have a colon
comma 0. that's from numpy if you did
that in a regular array you'll get an
error in a python array you have to have
that in a numpy array it turns out that
our make blobs returns a numpy array and
this notation is great because what it
means is the first part is the colon
means we're going to do all the rows
that's all the data in our blob we
created under capital x and then the
second part has a comma zero we're only
going to take the first value and then
if you notice we do the same thing but
we're going to take the second value
remember we always start with zero and
then one so we have column zero and
column one and you can look at this as
our x y plots the first one is the x
plot and the second one is the y plot so
the first one is on the bottom 0 2 4 6 8
and 10 and then the second one x of the
one is the 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 going up the
left hand side s equals 30 is just the
size of the dot so we can see them it
says real tiny dots and then the c map
equals plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
uh fit was done in two lines of code a
lot of times there'll be a third line
where we regularize the data we set it
between like minus one and one and we
reshape it but for this it's not
necessary and it's also kind of nice
because you can actually see what's
going on and then if we wanted to we
wanted to actually run a prediction
let's take a look and see what that
looks like and to predict some new data
and we'll show this again as we get
towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case i'm giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width and length 5 6
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets and then i have the brackets
inside and the reason i do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case i'm processing two lines and
then i'm just going to print and you'll
see clf dot predict new data so the clf
and the dot predict part is going to
give us an answer and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see 0 one so
predicted the first one the three four
is going to be on the one side and the
five six is going to be on the other
side so one came out as an alligator and
one came out as a crocodile now that's
pretty short explanation for the setup
but really we want to dug in and see
what's going on behind the scenes and
let's see what that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
and we did actually generating the
original model and you'll see here that
we go through a few steps and i'll move
this over to our editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid that and
show you how not to redo that and then
we're going to go in there and add in
those lines we're going to see what
those lines look like and how to set
those up and finally we're going to plot
all that on here and show it and you'll
get a nice graph with the what we saw
earlier when we were going through the
theory behind this where it shows the
support vectors and the hyperplane and
those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 it has plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and i'm
going to paste that code in and you'll
see that the plot show has moved down
below let's scroll up a little bit and
if you look at the top here of our new
section one two three and four is the
same code we had before and let's go
back up here and take a look at that
we're gonna fit the values on our svm
and then we're going to plot scatter it
and then we're going to do a plot show
so you should be asking why are we
redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here okay so this is how we
display a nice graph with our results in
our data ax is very standard used
variable when you talk about plt and
it's just setting it to that axis the
last axis in the plt it can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable xx equal
to np.line space x limit 0 x limit one
comma thirty and we've done the same
thing for the y space and then we're
gonna go in here and we create a mesh
grid and this is a numpy command so
we're back to our numbers python let's
go through what these numpy commands
mean with the line space and the mesh
grid we've taken x x small s x x equals
n p line space and we have our x limit
zero and our x limit one and we're going
to create 30 points on it and we're
going to do the same thing for the
y-axis now this has nothing to do with
our evaluation it's all we're doing is
we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between 0
and the x limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the y and then
the mesh grid loops those all together
so it forms a nice grit so if we were
going to do this say between the limit 0
and 10 and do 10 points we would have a
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on
you can just imagine a point at each
corner one of those boxes and the mesh
grid combines them all so we take the yy
and the xx we created and creates the
full grid and we've set that grid into
the yy coordinates and the xx
coordinates now remember we're working
with number and python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being x comma 1 you know x comma y
and then x 2 comma y 2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital yy and a
column of x's capital x x with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array x y array now that we've
created the stack of data points we're
going to do something interesting here
we're going to create a value z and the
z equals the clf that's our that's our
support vector machine we created and
we've already trained and we have a dot
decision function we're going to put the
x y in there so here we have all this
data we're going to put that x y in
there that data we're going to reshape
it and you'll see that we have the xx
dot shape in here this literally takes
the xx resets it up connected to the y
and the z value lets us know whether it
is the left hand side is going to
generate three different values the z
value does and it'll tell us whether
that data is a support vector to the
left the hyperplane in the middle or the
support vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so it's
900 points of data and we separated
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot library we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
contour capital xx capital yy these have
been reshaped to fit those lines z is
the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have three levels of data
the alpha is just makes it kind of
see-through so it's only 0.5 of the
value in there so when we graph it the
data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line styles this is where we set the two
support vectors to be dash dash lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does and
then finally we take our ax dot scatter
we're going to go ahead and plot the
support vectors but we've programmed it
in there so that they look nice like the
dash dash line and the dashed line on
that grid and you can see here when we
do the clf dot support vectors we are
looking at column 0 and column 1 and
then again we have the s equals 100 so
we're going to make them larger and the
line width equals 1 face colors equals
none let's take a look and see what that
looks like when we show it and you can
see we get down to our end result it
creates a really nice graph we have our
two support vectors and dashed lines and
they have the near data so you can see
those two points or in this case the
four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth we're going to
cover the k nearest neighbors like
referred to as k n n and k n is really a
fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's the basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there
watching the black cat cross their path
no dear you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now
unless they live a place where there's
not many cats or dogs so if we look at
the sharpness of the claws the length of
the ears and we can see that the cat has
a smaller ears and sharper claws than
the other animals its features are more
like cats it must be a cat
sharp claws length of ears and it goes
in the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how his neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to 3 we're going to look at
the three nearest neighbors we're going
to say this is a square and if we put k
equals a 7 we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around and you can see as the k changes
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get he's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using like this case
squares and triangles if it's even you
want to make your k value odd that helps
it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use k and n when data is labeled so
you need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
as normal or underweight so we see right
here we have two variables you know true
false they're either normal or they're
not they're underweight on the basis of
the given data we have to classify the
below set as normal or underweight using
knn so if we have new data coming in
that says 57 kilograms and 177
centimeters is that going to be normal
or underweight to find the nearest
neighbors we'll calculate the euclidean
distance according to the euclidean
distance formula the distance between
two points in the plane with the
coordinates x y and a b is given by
distance d equals the square root of x
minus a squared plus y minus b squared
and you can remember that from the two
edges of a triangle we're computing the
third edge since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around
the distance d1 is the square root of
170 minus 167 squared plus 57 minus 51
squared which is about 6.7 and distance
2 is about 13. and distance 3 is about
13.4 similarly we will calculate the
euclidean distance of unknown data point
from all the points in the data set and
because we're dealing with small amount
of data that's not that hard to do it's
actually pretty quick for a computer and
it's not a really complicated mass you
can just see how close is the data based
on the euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what we're just voting normal
normal normal three votes for normal
this is going to be a normal weight so
majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of k nn positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes
as a data scientist the first thing you
should be looking at is insulin well you
know if someone has insulin they have
diabetes because that's why they're
taking it and that could cause issue in
some of the machine learning packages
but for a very basic setup this works
fine for doing the k n and the next
thing you notice is it didn't take very
much to open it up i can scroll down to
the bottom of the data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
uh very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments i can create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can use a simple
pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case it's going
to open up chrome because that's my
default that i use and since the script
is pre-done you'll see i have a number
of windows open up at the top the one
we're working in and uh since we're
working on the k n predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and i'm
also going to go up here and click on
cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then i'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
i'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run as python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports we're going to import
the pandas as pd import numpy is np
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our trained test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take can get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so that they're
all uniform between -1 and 1. and then
the actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so that we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set in
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i use always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the n a n in num p n
a n is what that stands for is none it
doesn't exist so the first thing we're
doing here is we're replacing the zero
with a numpy none there's no data there
that's what that says that's what this
is saying right here so put the zero in
and we're going to play zeros with no
data so if it's a zero that means the
person's well hopefully not dead hope
they just didn't get the data the next
thing we want to do is we're going to
create the mean which is the integer
from the data set from the column dot
mean where we skip n a's we can do that
that is a pandas command there the skip
n a so we're going to figure out the
mean of that data set and then we're
going to take that data set column and
we're going to replace all the npn with
the means why did we do that we could
have actually just taken this step and
gone right down here and just replaced
zero and skip anything were except you
could actually there's a way to skip
zeros and then just replace all the
zeros but in this case we want to go
ahead and do it this way so you could
see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value then we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see it skipped a bunch
in the middle because that's what it
does if you have too many lines in
jupiter notebook it'll skip a few and
and go on to the next in a data set let
me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
of the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we printed it
in here is outcome well that's not part
of the training data that's part of the
answer yes column nine but it's listed
as eight number eight so zero to eight
is nine columns so uh eight is the value
and when you see it in here zero this is
actually zero to seven it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the sk learn right
there and we simply put in our x and our
y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you see it i have to
look that up and then the test size test
size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any print out other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scal the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column and then our x train equals sc
underscore x dot fit transform so we're
creating the scalar on the x train
variable and then our x test we're also
going to transform it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to go and run
this if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key columns that shouldn't be zero
and we replace that with the means of
those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here and we split the data so now
we have our test data and our training
data and then we've taken and we've
scaled the data so all of our data going
in no no we don't tr we don't train the
y part the y train and y test that never
has to be trained it's only the data
going in that's what we want to train in
there then define the model using k
neighbors classifier and fit the train
data in the model so we do all that data
prep and you can see down here we're
only going to have a couple lines of
code where we're actually building our
model and training it that's one of the
cool things about python and how far
we've come it's such an exciting time to
be in machine learning because there's
so many automated tools let's see before
we do this let's do a quick length of
and let's do y we want let's just do
length of y
and we get 768 and if we import math we
do math dot square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test
and when i run that we get
12.409 i want to show you where this
number comes from we're about to use 12
is an even number so if you know if
you're ever voting on things remember
the neighbors all vote don't want to
have an even number of neighbors voting
so we want to do something odd and let's
just take one away we'll make it 11. let
me delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11.
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix y test
y predict so those are the two values
we're going to put in there and let me
go ahead and run that and print it out
and the way you interpret this is you
have the y predicted which would be your
title up here you could do uh let's just
do p-r-e-d
predict it across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to write in here actual
that means that this column here down
the middle that's the important column
and it means that our prediction said 94
and prediction in the actual agreed on
94 and 32 this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with a third
row down here in the column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero has a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the f1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our f1 score
the f1 takes into account both sides of
the balance of false positives where if
we go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics in running
an sk learn and running the knn the k
nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
point eight one eight was pretty close
to what we got and we can pretty much
round that off and just say we have an
accuracy of eighty percent it tells us
it is a pretty fair fit in the model so
what is k-means clustering
k-means clustering is an unsupervised
learning algorithm in this case you
don't have labeled data unlike in
supervised learning so you have a set of
data and you want to group them and as
the name suggests you want to put them
into clusters which means objects that
are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number
so we need to tell the system how many
clusters we need to perform so if k is
equal to two there will be two clusters
if k is equal to three three clusters
and so on and so forth that's what the k
stands for and of course there is a way
of finding out what is the best or
optimum value of k for a given data we
will look at that so that is k means
clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about the
runs scored by the people ordered by the
player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and boilers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is
so there are information there is
information on the y-axis about the run
scored and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the boilers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to two and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from the centroid and the
distance from this center right this
point is taken and the distance is found
from this centroid and the center and so
on and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids
and then whichever distance is less that
point is assigned to that centroid so
for example in this case visually it is
very obvious that all these data points
are assigned to this centroid and all
these data points are assigned to this
centroid and that's what is represented
here in blue color and in this yellow
color the next step is to actually
determine the central point or the
actual centroid for these two clusters
so we have this one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of these new
clusters and this process is actually
repeated now what might happen is some
of these points may get reallocated in
our example that is not happening
probably but it may so happen that the
distance is found between each of these
data points once again with these
centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is
repeated the process of calculating the
distance and repositioning the centroid
is repeated till the repositioning stops
which means that the algorithm has
converged and we have the final cluster
with the data points and the centroids
so this is what you're going to learn
from this session we will talk about the
types of clustering what is k-means
clustering application of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is done
using distance measure so we will talk
about the common distance measures and
then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b c def we start by
combining b and c form one cluster d e
and e form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add bc to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is the top down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have abcdef we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down
into a b c d
e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k-means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics
are compared and all objects having
similar characteristics are clubbed
together so that's how k means
clustering is done we will see it in
more detail as we move forward and fuzzy
c means is very similar to k means in
the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k-means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
systems search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this and
similarly in case of
wireless sensor networks the clustering
algorithm plays the role of finding the
cluster heads which collects all the
data in its respective cluster so
clustering especially k means clustering
uses distance measure so let's take a
look at what is distance measure so
while these are the different types of
clustering in this video we will focus
on k-means clustering so distance
measure tells
how similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure it's nothing but the
square of the euclidean distance as the
name suggests so instead of taking the
square root we leave the square as it is
and then we have manhattan distance
measure in case of manhattan distance it
is the sum of the distances across the
x-axis and the y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors
formed by joining the points from the
origin so that is the cosine distance
measure okay so that was a quick
overview about the various distance
measures that are supported by k means
now let's go and check how exactly
k-means clustering works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of k what
should be the best value of k how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of k we specify that and
then the system will assign that many
centroids so it picks randomly that to
start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
i have been formed it calculates the
main position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across
so how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares
and the lower this value is the better
the cluster is that means all these
points are very close to each other so
we use this within sum of squares as a
measure to find the optimum number of
clusters that can be formed for a given
data set so we create clusters or we let
the system create clusters of a variety
of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k
the within ss is measured and the value
of k which has the least amount of
within ss or wss that's taken as the
optimum value of k so this is the
diagrammatic representation so we have
on the y-axis the within sum of squares
or wss and on the x-axis we have the
number of clusters so as you can imagine
if you have k is equal to 1 which means
all the data points are in a single
cluster the within s value will be very
high because they are probably scattered
all over the moment you split it into
two there will be a drastic fall in the
within ss value that's what is
represented here but then as the value
of k increases the decrease the rate of
decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of k
should be either 2 or 3 or at the most 4
but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned or
repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here but after
recalculating repositioning it is
observed that this is closer to c1 than
c2 so this is the new grouping so some
points will be reassigned and again the
centroid will be calculated and if the
centroid doesn't change so that is a
repetitive process iterative process and
if the centroid doesn't change once the
centroid stops changing that means the
algorithm has converged and this is our
final cluster with this as the centroid
c1 and c2 as the centroids these data
points as a part of each cluster so i
hope this helps in understanding the
whole process iterative process of
k-means clustering so let's take a look
at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
central point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process
for x2 calculate its distance from each
of the centroids c1 c2 c3 up to ck and
find which is the lowest distance and
assign x2 to that particular centroid
same with x3 and so on so that is the
first round of assignment that is done
now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of these newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two and three so we again
calculate the distance of x1
from the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence so
let's take a detailed look at it at each
of these steps so we randomly pick k
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two
we now have all the points all the data
points grouped into k groups because we
we wanted to create k clusters right so
we have k groups each one may be having
a certain number of input values they
need not be equally distributed by the
way based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step 3
we actually calculate the centroid of
each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in python notebook
using pattern notebook but before that
let's find out what's the problem that
we are trying to solve the problem
statement is let's say walmart wants to
open a chain of stores across the state
of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales so
how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual
k-means clustering process
so we will assign
each of these points to the centroids
and then check whether they are the
optimal distance which is the shortest
distance and assign each of the points
data points to the centroids and then go
through this iterative process till the
whole process converges and finally we
get an output like this so we have four
distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and
the centroids are like the location
where the store should be the optimum
location where the store should be so
that's the way we determine the best
locations for the store and that's how
we can help walmart find the best
locations for the stores in florida so
now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are learning
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupyter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how
k-means clustering is used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well okay so let's
get started okay so this block is
basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify how many clusters we want
so centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually provides
now from
here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality of the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then we create an
instance of means and we specify the
value of k this n underscore clusters is
the value of k remember k means in k
means k is basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as with any other
machine learning functionality fit is
what we use the function or the method
rather fit is what we use to
train the model here there is no real
training kind of thing but that's the
call okay so we are calling fit and what
we are doing here we are just passing
the data so x has these values
the data that has been created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster 1
this is 2 3 and so on or i will actually
start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and 3 maybe
and then for each of the observations it
will assign based on which cluster it
belongs to it will assign a value so
that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these uh
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have how many about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here each
of them the cluster number is given and
the cluster number goes from 0 to 3. so
there are four clusters so the numbers
go from 0 1 2 3. so that's what is seen
here okay now so this was a quick
example of generating some dummy data
and then clustering that okay and this
can be applied if you have proper data
you can just load it up into x for
example here and then run the game so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code
at each step what it is doing and then
we will see a couple of more examples of
how k-means clustering
can be used in maybe some real life
examples real life use cases all right
so in this case here what we are doing
is basically implementing the k means
clustering
and there is a function or a library
calculates for a given two pairs of
points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign the
data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points we
calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position which is the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid
the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case also with
that is actually convergence right so
for example the change is 0.0001 we can
consider that as convergence otherwise
what will happen is this will either
take forever or it will be never ending
so that's a small flaw here so that is
something additional checks may have to
be added here but again as mentioned
this is not the most sophisticated
implementation uh this is like a kind of
a rough implementation of the k-means
clustering okay so if we execute this
code this is what we get as the output
so this is the definition of this
particular function and then we call
that find underscore clusters and we
pass our data x and the number of
clusters which is 4
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of an implementation of k means
clustering
and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used in maybe some real-life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory so that is the
scenario where something like this can
be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm and this
will then create clusters of only 16
clusters so this this colors there are
millions of colors and now we need to
bring it down to 16 colors so we use k
is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to a 16 color so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though the image quality is definitely
reduced a little bit
so this is an example which we are going
to now see in python notebook let's go
into the python node and once again as
always we will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let we load that
and this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and
this is the shape of this image which is
basically what is the shape is nothing
but the overall size right so this is
427 pixel by 640 pixel and then there
are three layers which is this three
basically is for rgb which is red green
blue so color image will have that right
so that is the shape of this now what we
need to do is data let's take a look at
how data is looking so let me just
create a new cell and show you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix
and each one has about for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are large the numbers are a large so we
need to normalize them to between zero
and one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between 0 and 1. and the way to do that
is divide by 255 so we divide china by
255 and we get the new values in data so
let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here
and take a look at how data is looking
all right so this is how data is looking
and now you see this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between 0 and 1. this
is one of the things we need to do all
right so after that the next thing that
we need to do is to visualize this and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points
and plot it and check and see how this
looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are these this is
how the 16 colors
would look so this is red against green
and this is red against blue there is uh
quite a bit of similarity between this
original color schema and the new one
right so it doesn't look very very
completely different or anything like
that now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look uh how this is looking now we can
compare both the images so this is our
original image and this is our new image
so as you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been
lost
it pretty much looks like the original
image yes we can see that for example
here there is a little bit it appears a
little dullish compared to this one
right because we kind of took off some
of the finer details of the color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16
and then we render the image once again
and we will see that the color the
quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is
even more
intricate and has probably much
complicated color schema so this is the
image now once again we can take a look
at the shape which is 427 by 640 by 3
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will
also bring this as you can see the
numbers are much big so we will much
bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as the next step we
will go ahead and visualize this how it
looks does the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see this looks much
richer in color but at the same time and
this probably doesn't have as we can see
it doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably not that
sophisticated okay so that's pretty much
it so we have seen two examples of how
color compression can be done
using k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering we talk about the principal
component
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction principle
component analysis what is it
important pca terminologies and you'll
see it abbreviated normally as pca
principal component analysis pca
properties pca example and then we'll
pull up some python code in our jupyter
notebook and have some hands-on demo on
the pca and how it's used dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company bpex isomax and they have
the item the tire the axle an order id a
price number and a quantity in order to
predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number i don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just once we want to get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it why would we want to store two
whole extra columns when we added into
that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good
clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four what
makes data easy for plotting you have a
better interpretation when we're looking
at it principle component analysis
so what is it
uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with a
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because
if you look at the end result we have
the different colors all lined up so
what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling a lot of
the people in the class are missing so
we have a huge amount off to the right
of blank space maybe from up here again
we have the back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it you say
hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data
it's not
you really can't do it by what you think
is going to be the best we need to have
some kind of mathematical formula so
it's consistent and so it makes sense in
the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the most common ones out
there where they have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the
width-to-length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my
iris
pedal example
when we look at the similarity in pca we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind we're usually talking about 36 40
variables
almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different variables they're looking
at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the x y
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x y this time from a different
direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get two principal components namely pc1
and pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc-1 and not the
pc2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the back-end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective
which would help in understanding how
pca analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under pca
and important terminologies are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions um
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features minimal and then you have the
principal component new variables that
are constructed as linear combinations
or mixtures of the initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in the ratio instead
which is a single number versus two
separate numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those point all those points fall
onto the line
important properties important
properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense uh you're
not going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through principal components are
orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2
we want to make sure that pc1 does not
equal pc2 we don't want to have the same
two principal points
when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers
increase
this is important to understand if
you're going to create
one principle
component
everything is summarized into that one
component as we go to two components the
priority
how much it holds value decreases as we
go down so if you have five different
points each one of those points is going
to have less value than just the one
point which has everything summarized in
it
how pca works
i said there was more in the back end we
talked about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene vector is like a
translation for
moving the data
from x equals one to x equals two or
whatever we're altering it and the ign
value is the final value that we
generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them lie within similar
boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean
over the standard deviation
the covariance matrix computation
covariance matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
attribute values the variance is denoted
by var and the covariance is denoted by
cov
on the right we can see the covariance
matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance
table for more than two attributes in a
multi-dimensional data set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature or two features
we're usually looking at 25 30 features
going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the iogene values and
the i-gene vectors
i-gene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
i gene vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
i gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change uh the vector b
to the b
prime as denoted on the chart
and so when we have like multiple
variables how do we calculate that new
variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has
hygiene vectors of the components that
we decide to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start looking at
the back end of this and we'll do this
in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k columns or variables
now for this matrix we would construct a
variable space with as many dimensions
as the variable
but for our simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm it represents the maximum
variance direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means uh inside our python
scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example i believe there's even
like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our
jupiter i'm in chrome and we go ahead
and create a new python three
and for ease of use our team in the back
was nice enough to put this together for
me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries
the first thing i like to do whenever
i'm looking at
any new setup
well you know what let's do let's do the
libraries first we're going to do our
basic libraries which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
are data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on matplot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook map plot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but i put
it in there either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
one of the reasons the cancer data set
is it has like 36 35 different features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so
what we're looking for in all this
is um well let's take a look at the
description let's go in here and pull up
the description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our pca setup
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different
measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data in this
case our target
and if you dig deep enough to the target
let's actually do this
let's go ahead and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target
names
run that
yeah so the target name is is it
malignant or is it b9 um so in other
words is this
a dangerous growth or is it something we
don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data
and you know let me go up a just a notch
here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right that's
all you have to do
so let's go ahead and look at our data
uh our we're going to use our pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data columns equals cancer feature
equals feature names so remember up here
we already loaded the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
um that's just this list of names here
in the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head
and you can see here we have the mean
radius the mean texture mean perimeter
i don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because
like many of the data that most of the
data that comes in half the time we
don't even know we're looking at
we're just handed a bunch of stuff as a
data scientist going what the heck is
this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there we have no idea what
these feature means or where they come
from we want to just look at the data
and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it as we've noticed before
it's difficult to visualize high
dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components and visualize the
data this new two-dimensional space with
a single scatter plot
before we do this we need to go ahead
and scale our data
now
i haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead
let me go and run this code
uh so the code for this
is
from sklearn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals 2.
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
uh which you have to put in there pretty
much
and then you also might look at the svd
solver it's on auto right now but you
can override that and do different
things with it it does a pretty good job
as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
there we go
to our methods
if you notice we have fit
we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction
it's used to look at the data again
we're in the describe setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it
we've already looked at our minimum
maximum we've already looked at what's
in each quarter we've done a full
description of the data this is part of
describing the data
that's the biggest thing i take away
when i come zooming in here and of
course i have examples of it down here
if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full randomize there's different things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
going to set that equal to pca transform
scaled data
so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us
what's going on here we've taken 30
features i think i said 36 or something
like that but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and
plot these and take a look and see
what's going on
and uh
we're just going to use our plt figure
we're going to set the figure size on
here here's our scatter plot
xpca
x underscore pca of
one these are two different
perceptions we're using
and then
you'll see right here c for color cancer
equals target
and so remember we have zero we have one
and if i remember correctly zero was
malignant one was b9
uh so everything in the zero column's
gonna be one color and the other color
is gonna be one and then we're gonna use
the plasma map just kind of telling you
what color it is add some labels first
principle component second principle
component and we'll go ahead and run
this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different
columns in it
we can look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when i'm looking at
this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign
and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be malignant or i think i
had that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something
in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate i would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps
and we're not going to have a clear
result on it
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently
versus going in and saying just cutting
into the can into the cancers so the
body absorbs it and it dissipates versus
uh
actively going in there removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things that's a big
difference you know as far as what's
going to happen here in that middle line
where the overlap is going to be huge
that's domain specific going back to the
data
we can see here
clearly by using these two components we
can easily separate these two classes
so the next step is what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent
i don't know what principle component
one looks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered pca object and
so we talk look at that we can go ahead
and do look at the pca components this
is in our model we built we've trained
it we can run that and you can see
here's the actual components
it's
the two components have each have their
own array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using
and these actually give weight to what
features are doing what
so in this numpy matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing
what this means and so let me go ahead
and just put this down i've already got
it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is uh
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's neat about a data frame is when
we get to seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and
and set it up for us when we want
and so we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little
color graph here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right we have a scale so we can
see we have the dark colors all the way
to the really light colors which are
what's really shining there this is like
the primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is
on some of this
so you have some interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to
a post scribe you can also use this to
try to guess as what these things mean
and what you want to change to get a
better result
regularization in machine learning
so our agenda on this one is fitting the
data
understanding linear regression
bias and variance
what is overfitting
what is underfitting and those are like
the biggest things right now in data
science is overfitting and under fitting
what does that mean
and what is regularization and then
we'll do a quick hands-on demo to take a
look at this
so fitting the data let's start with
fitting the data and we talk about what
is data fitting it's a process of
plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going a little deeper on there
so we might have in this case just to
two dimensions we have an efficiency of
the car and we have the distance
traveled in 1 000 kilometers
and so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship and a linear
relationship
very specifically linear means line
the line used to represent the
relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have linear relationship
linear regression
so let's start with uh how linear
regression works a linear regression
finds a line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two variables
and so you can see here we have the
efficiency of the car
versus the distance traveled and you can
see this nice straight line drawn
through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line that now becomes
a plane
it gets a little more complicated with
multiple variables but they all come
down to this linear kind of drawing a
line through your data and finding what
fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example let's
say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store
and suppose we have two lines we're
going to draw l1 and l2 and we're going
to kind of guess which one we think is
the best fit
and which claim to describe the
relationship between the variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line l1
and each data point and add them all and
find the mean distance
and i want you to think about that when
we
square something if it's a negative or
positive number it no longer matters
because a minus 2 squared is 4 2 squared
is 4. so we're removing what side of the
line is on and we're just looking for
the error in this case the mean distance
of each of the little dotted lines you
see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called mean square error or
loss function
and we talk about loss how far off are
we that's what we're really talking
about what did we miss uh and we have a
positive distance and a negative
distance and of course when we square it
it is neither it just becomes a positive
error
and so we take the mean
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as mse
if i look in the code and i'm going
through my python code and i see mse i
know that's a mean squared error
and we take all the dotted lines and we
calculate this error we add them all
together and then we average it or find
the means
and in this case
they ran a demo on this and it was
1127.27
for our l1 line
now we find the loss function for line
l2 in a similar fashion and we get the
mean square error to be 6397
and it's computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function or the mean square
error is less for l1 than l2 hence l1 is
the best fit line
uh this process describes a lot of
machine learning processes it was we're
going to keep guessing and get as close
as we can to find the right answer we
have to have some way to invite to
calculate this and figure out which
one's the best and the mean square error
is one of the better fits to doing for
doing this and most commonly used
we really want to talk about bias and
variance
very important terms to know in machine
learning
and with linear regression
so bias
bias occurs when an algorithm has
limited flexibility to learn from data
variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have the two different
setups
bias you can think is very generalized
where variance is very specific
and so we talk about bias such models
pay very little attention to the
training data and over simplify the
model
therefore the validation error or
prediction error and training error
follow similar trends
and uh with bias if you oversimplify it
so much you're going to miss
your
local
if if you have like a really
good fit you're going to miss it you're
you're going to just kind of
guess what the average is and that's
what your answer is going to be
with variance a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other
such models always lead to a high error
on training and test data as a bias does
where variants such models usually
perform very well on training data but
have high error rates on test data
and i want you to think about this um
when we're talking about a bias
the error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of
getting an average we're not really
fitting it close
with variance we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to nail it every time if you're
doing categorical testing that's a car
that's a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants
suddenly a
truck has to have certain features
and it might have to be red
because you had so many red pictures so
if it has if it's an 18-wheeler it has
to be red if it's blue then it has to be
a bicycle
that's the kind of variance we're
talking about where it picks up on
something and it cannot get the right
answer unless it gets a very specific
data
and we see that so that as you're
testing it your models
and you programmed it you got to look
for
how i trained it what is coming out and
if it's not if it's not looking good on
either bias or if it's not looking good
on the training or on the test data
then your bias then your bias in your
data
if it really looks good on the training
data then that's going to be your
variance you've over fitted the data
and those are very important things to
know when you are building your models
in regression of any kind or any kind of
setup for predicting
so in dark games if all the data found a
particular pointer this can be
considered as a biased throw and the
player aims for the particular score
for variance if all the darts fall on
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual
predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting uh when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details along with the noise
and the data tries to fit each data
point on the curve
you can see that
um
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever it's
fitted every point on the data stream
there's no average there's no
two points that might have that you know
y might have two different answers
because uh if the wind blows a certain
way um and the efficiency of your car
maybe you have a headwind
so your car might alter how efficient it
is as it goes and so there's going to be
this variance on here and this says no
you can't have any variance with you
know the this is it's going to be
exactly this it can't be any you can't
be the same speed or the same car and
have a slightly different efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the prediction
so you'll get like a really high error
on here
and so
reasons for overfitting
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage values in it
you can spend so much time cleaning your
data
and it's so important it's so important
that if you have if you have some kind
of
something wrong with the data coming in
it needs to be addressed whether it's a
source of the data maybe they use in
medical different measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus hospital
b or even off of machine a and machine b
that's testing something and those those
numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance
again wind is a good example i was
talking about that with the car
you may have 100 tests but because the
wind's blowing it's all over the place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data is going to
also cause this problem you only have a
few points and you try to plot
everything
the model is too complex
this comes up a lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked
and so you have to go back back break it
up and find out actually what correlates
and what doesn't
so
what is underfitting a scenario where
machine learning models
can either learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict
or classify a new data point and you can
see here we have our efficiency of our
car and our line drawn and it's just
going to be way off for both the
training and the predicting data
as the model doesn't fully learn the
patterns it accepts every new data point
during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue
you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias
we've seen this in all kinds of things
from
[Music]
the mod the most common is the driving
cars to facial identification or
whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have uh
five people from india and 10 people
from
africa and 20 people from the u.s you
created a bias
because it's looking at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size i was just
talking about
so we have a model with a high bias we
have size of training data used it's not
enough the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when it needs a slight
shift to it for other reasons
so what is a good fit
uh a linear curve that best fits the
data is neither overfitting or
underfitting models but is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting
lines going up and down every point is
trying to be include included
underfitting
the line really is off from where the
data is and then a good fit is got to
get rid of that minimize that
error coming through regularization is
taking the guess work out you're looking
at this graph and you're going oh which
one is that really over fit or is that
under fit that's pretty hard to tell
so we talk about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate the linear regression models
and to minimize the adjusted loss
function and prevent overfitting or
under fitting
so what that means in this case we're
going to go ahead and take a look at a
couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the ridge regularization
and the lasso regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the
mlp the multi-layered positron in the sk
learn module you could bring in the
ridge module and you can bring in the
lasso module
so when we talk about
ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares of the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals
lambda times the sum of w
squared or the absolute value of w
depending on how you're doing it now
remember we talked about error whether
we either square it or we absolute value
it
because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but it is more common to
square the value
and then we have our um in this case the
lambda is going to be the penalty for
the errors we've thrown in a greek
character for you just to confuse
everybody
and w is the slope of the curve of the
line
so uh we're going to look at this and
we're going to draw a line this is going
to be like a linear regression model so
if you had in sklearn you could import
just a standard linear regression model
it would plot this line across whatever
data we're working on
and we look at this of course we're just
extrapolating this i know they use some
specific data but you don't want to get
into the actual domain
and so for a linear regression line
let's consider two points that are on
the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero uh considering the two
points on the line we'll go ahead and do
lambda equals one we'll set our w is
going to be one point four
then the cost function equals zero plus
one times one point four squared which
equals 1.96
so
really don't get caught up too much in
the math on this other than
understanding
that this is something that's very easy
for a computer to calculate and if you
ever see the loss plus the len plus the
lambda times w the sum of w squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when they put
all the calculations through
of the two points we end up with the
0.0.62
so we've now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model
and the ridge regression model plots a
little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and i find this true on a lot of data i
work with i'll end up using either the
ridge regression model or the lasso mars
regression model for fitting especially
dealing with a lot of like stock markets
daily
setup they come out slightly better you
get a slightly better
fit
and so we have our lasso we just talked
about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals uh
instead of doing a squared we're just
going to do the absolute value and so if
you remember this is where ridge
regression changes where's my ridge
regression model we're squaring the
value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of this of the squared individuals
and here is our
lambda symbol again penalty for errors
and w equals the slope of the curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like i said i use these two
models a lot uh the ridge and this is
important this is
this is kind of the meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use some of
it is you just do it a bunch of times
and then you figure it out
ridge regularization is useful when we
have many variables with relatively
smaller data samples
the model does not encourage convergence
towards zero but is likely to make them
closer to zero and prevent overfitting
the lasser regularization model is
preferred when we are fitting a linear
model with fewer variables
so in the la in the iris thing we had
four or five variables as they measured
the different leaf pieces uh you might
be doing the measurements on the cancer
project which has 36 different variables
so as we get down to the iris with four
variables
lasso lar will probably uh work pretty
good where you might use the ridge
regularization with more model with if
you have something significantly larger
and it encourages the coefficients of
the variables to go towards zero because
of the shape of the constraint which is
an absolute value
and with any of this we want to go ahead
and
do a demo and lasso and ridge regression
so let's take a look and see what that
looks like in our code and bring up our
jupyter notebook
we'll start with our imports pandas is
pd import numpy is np import matplot
library as plt
sklearn we're going to import our data
sets it's kind of more generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together
we have our sklearn model selection
we're going to import our train test
split for splitting our data up
and then we'll bring in our linear
regression model
and we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up
and then load our data set we're just
talking about that
you could just
have imported the load boston and boston
data set in there instead of loading all
the data sets
and then once we've loaded our data set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data and see what we got here
let me just go and pop that down there
and
go and run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our
boston
data we're going to look we put it into
our pandas data frame
the boston data set and then the boston
columns we want to see what's going on
with them
we have our target
we have the house price
etc and so our x equals boston
eye location
now remember in pandas the new updates
to pandas they want eye location if
you're going to pull data we used to be
able to leave this off
but it does something different it
creates a slice versus a direct
setup so make sure using that eye
location and the i the output so this is
all just bringing our data together
and we can see here if we do we print
the boston
panda's head
we can see here all of our different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the x and the y
the x is
everything
except for the last column
where y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column and then y is all the rows
but just the last column so y is our
house price
and the x is the
crimsian industry chas knox and all
these other different
statistics they've collected for house
sales in boston
there we go oops control
so we'll go ahead and split our data x
train and our x
test y train y test equals the train
test split which we imported
and we have our boston you could have
easily used the x and y on here as
opposed to boston
eye location
and we'll create our test size we're
going to take 25 of the data and put it
in as a test
and then we'll go ahead and run this
i need an extra drink there
uh so we have our train and test and
then of course the print the train data
shape
i love doing this kind of thing whenever
i'm working with this data print out the
shape
make sure everything looks correct uh so
that we have 127 by 13 and 127 by one
379 by 13. they should match and if
they're if the the data sets are not
quite matching
then you know something's wrong and
you're going to get all those errors i
don't know how many times i've gone
through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird has
happened when i'm cleaning the data
this is pretty straightforward and
simple because the data comes in a nice
pre-package is all clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple linear regression model
and we'll call this lreg lrag linear
regression and we're going to go ahead
and fit that linear regression model to
x-train and y-train
then we'll generate the prediction on
the test set
so here's our l-reg y predict
with our x test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error mse i told you you'll see mse used
a lot
um people use it in variables and things
like that it's pretty common
and we get our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference squared
and then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot so if it's in
your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see see these
kinds of numbers coming up
but if it's not it's just a bunch of
numbers and that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo and
then we're going to go ahead and plot
these so we can see what's going on
and this is always kind of fun it's
always nice to have a nice visual of
what you're looking at and you can see
here
when we plot the coefficient scores on
and we
the guys in the back did a great job
putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice and setting up the
columns
you can see here
uh your nox has like just a huge
coefficient
when i look at a table like this i look
for what has very little
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change and what has huge changes
and that flags you for all kinds of
things as you're working with the data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this now
our motive is to reduce the coefficient
score so now we want to take these and
and
bring them down as much as we can
and for that we're going to work with
the ridge regression on here
so let's start by going we're going to
import our ridge model the red
regression from the sk learn library or
the scikit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our ridge r equals
alpha equals 1. and i mentioned that
earlier
when i work with the ridge model
you'll see alpha equals one if you set
alpha equal to zero that's a standard
linear regression model so you have
alpha equals one two three four and you
usually use one two or three four and a
standard integer on there
and we'll go ahead and fit the ridge
model on there with our x train and our
y train data
generate a prediction for that
for our x test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error
just like we did before this should all
look familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the ridge coefficients
for our data and see what that looks
like
now
if i jump up and down between these two
you'll get a headache
[Laughter]
you'll still see the knox value let's
just look at the knocks because that was
the biggest value it's a minus nine here
and if we go back up here the nox value
is a minus 18. so right off the bat i'm
seeing a huge change
um in the biggest coefficient there
so if we're going to do that nice setup
we want to go ahead and just print it
and see what that looks like
here we go and we've
set up our plot subplots and again the
team put together some nice colors so it
makes it look good we're doing an x bar
based on the columns
and our
l regress coefficients color equals
color x spine bottom and so forth
so just put together a nice little graph
and you're starting to see uh one this
when you compare this if you put on the
same graph as this one up here this is
up here minus 18.
this is at minus nine
and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above
the same thing with these values here
they might look the same but they're
actually all
almost half the value on here
and then finally you can do the same
thing for the lasso regression
this would all look uh very similar as
far as what we worked on before
and i'm just going to print that on here
and run it
and again let's go up to
knox look where nox is it's all the way
down to zero
and if we look at our next biggest
coefficient it's minus 0.8 and really
here's our
22.73
let me go up here
16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number
16.69
and so we look at this
if i was running this and doing a
working on a project with this i would
look at these numbers i start with the
16.69
come down here and compare it to
16.78 6 9 is better than 7 8.
so from the very beginning we might
start looking at this first model for
overall
predicting
but there's other factors involved we
might know that
the nox value is central and the other
ones aren't quite as good and so we
might start looking at just certain
setups like what is our what is this
particular coefficient because it might
have a certain meaning to us and so
forth and so you can look at all those
different
items in there again but the bottom
dollar is our first model did better
than our other two models our mean
square error on the test set
continues to come down on this
in this video you will learn about an
interesting machine learning topic that
is supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning
let's discuss each of them in detail and
understand when to use these algorithms
along with their applications
now there are a number of algorithms
used in the field of machine learning to
solve complex problems
each of these algorithms can be
classified into a certain category so
the different types of machine learning
algorithms are supervised learning
unsupervised learning and reinforcement
learning
now let's look at the definition of each
of these learning techniques
supervised learning uses labeled data to
train machine learning models
labeled data means that the output is
already known to you the model just
needs to map the inputs to the outputs
an example of supervised learning can be
to train a machine that identifies the
image of an animal
below you can see we have a trained
model that identifies the picture of a
cat
unsupervised learning uses unlabeled
data to train machines unlabeled data
means there is no fixed output variable
the model learns from the data discovers
patterns and features in the data and
returns the output here is an example of
an unsupervised learning technique that
uses the images of vehicles to classify
if it's a bus or a truck
so the model learns by identifying the
parts of a vehicle such as the length
and width of the vehicle the front and
rear end covers roof hoods
the types of wheels used etc based on
these features the model classifies if
the vehicle is a bus or a truck
reinforcement learning trains a machine
to take suitable access and maximize
reward in a particular situation
it uses an agent and an environment to
produce actions and rewards
the agent has a start and an end state
but there might be different parts
for reaching the end state like a maze
in this learning technique there is no
predefined target variable
an example of reinforcement learning is
to train a machine that can identify the
shape of an object given a list of
different objects such as
square triangle rectangle
or a circle in the example shown the
model tries to predict the shape of the
object which is a square here
now
let's look at the different machine
learning algorithms that come under
these learning techniques
some of the commonly used supervised
learning algorithms are linear
regression logistic regression support
vector machines k nearest neighbors
decision tree random forest and naive
bayes
examples of unsupervised learning
algorithms are k-means clustering
hierarchical clustering db scan
principle component analysis and others
choosing the right algorithm depends on
the type of problem you are trying to
solve
some of the important reinforcement
learning algorithms are queue learning
monte carlo sarsa and deep queue network
now let's look at the approach in which
these machine learning techniques work
so supervised learning takes labeled
inputs and maps it to known outputs
which means you already know the target
variable
unsupervised learning finds patterns and
understands the trends in the data to
discover the output so the model tries
to label the data based on the features
of the input data
while reinforcement learning follows
trial and error method to get the
desired solution
after accomplishing a task the agent
receives an award
an example could be to train a dog to
catch the ball if the dog learns to
catch a ball you give it a reward such
as a biscuit
now
let's discuss the training process for
each of these learning methods
so supervised learning methods need
external supervision to train machine
learning models and hence the name
supervised
they need guidance and additional
information to return the result
unsupervised learning techniques do not
need any supervision to train models
they learn on their own and predict the
output
similarly reinforcement learning methods
do not need any supervision to train
machine learning models
and with that
let's focus on the types of problems
that can be solved using
these three types of machine learning
techniques so supervised learning is
generally used for classification and
regression problems
we'll see the examples in the next slide
and unsupervised learning is used for
clustering and association problems
while reinforcement learning is reward
based so for every task or for every
step completed there will be a reward
received by the agent
and if the task is not achieved
correctly
there will be some penalty used
now let's look at a few applications of
supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning
as we saw earlier supervised learning
are used to solve classification and
regression problems for example you can
predict the weather for a particular day
based on humidity precipitation wind
speed and pressure values
you can use supervised learning
algorithms to forecast sales for the
next month or the next quarter for
different products similarly you can use
it for stock price analysis or
identifying if a cancer cell is
malignant or benign
now talking about the applications of
unsupervised learning we have customer
segmentation
so based on customer behavior likes
dislikes and interests you can segment
and cluster similar customers into a
group
another example where unsupervised
learning algorithms are used is customer
churn analysis
now let's see what applications we have
in reinforcement learning
so reinforcement learning algorithms are
widely used in the gaming industries to
build games it is also used to train
robots to perform human tasks
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
reinforcement learning by simply learn
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
we're going to cover reinforcement
learning today and what's in it for you
we'll start with why reinforcement
learning we'll look at what is
reinforcement learning
we'll see what the different kinds of
learning strategies are that are being
used today in computer models under
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement
we'll cover important terms specific to
reinforcement learning we'll talk about
markov's decision process and we'll take
a look at a reinforcement learning
example but we'll teach a tic-tac-toe
how to play
why reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us
further the data provided might not be
reliable learning from a small subset of
actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if i'm taking one
step forward and left what happens if i
pick up a 50 pound object how does that
change how a robot would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here it learned how to
walk this is going to slow the growth
that technology is capable of machines
need to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climb a
mountain
real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment
and we can adjust for it and kind of
explore and play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer
machine learning aren't able to do that
very well there's a couple of them that
can be used or integrated to see how it
goes
is what we're talking about with
reinforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains a model
to return an optimum solution for a
problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take different paths to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important is we're
looking for unique solutions we want the
best solution but you can't find it
unless you try it so we're looking at
our different
systems or different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning and with the
supervised learning that is probably the
most controlled environment we have a
lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks
there's all kinds of things in between
decision trees
the data provided is labeled data with
output values specified
and this is important because we talk
about supervised learning you already
know the answer for all this information
you already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so you're supervised
learning you already know that
the outcome for tomorrow for you know
going back a week you're looking at
stock
you can already have like the graph of
what the next day looks like so you have
an answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves problems by mapping labeled input
to known output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and unsupervised
learning is really interesting because
it's now taking part in many other
models they start with a row we have an
unsupervised learning model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning is part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions
used to solve association with
clustering problems unlabeled data is
used
no supervision solves problems by
understanding patterns and discovering
output
so you can look at this and you can
think
some of these things go with each other
they belong together so it's looking for
what connects in different ways and
there's a lot of different algorithms
that look at this
when you start getting into those are
some really cool images that come up
of what unsupervised learning is how it
can pick out say
the area of a donut
one model will see the area of the donut
and the other one will divide it into
three sections based on its location
versus what's next to it so there's a
lot of stuff that goes in with
unsupervised learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market
in machine learning or growing market
it's very it's very infant stage
as far as how it works and what's going
to be capable of
the machine learns from its environment
using rewards and errors used to solve
reward based problems
no predefined data is used no
supervision
follows trail and error problem solving
approach
so again we have a random first you
start with a random i try this it
works and this is my reward doesn't work
very well maybe or maybe it doesn't even
get you where you're trying to get it to
do and you get your reward back and then
it looks at that and says well let's try
something else
and it starts to play with these
different things finding the best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years
so these are really good to know
we have the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual
entity that has however you're doing it
whether you're using a neural network or
a
cue table or whatever combination
thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the model
and you have your environment
the training situation that the model
must optimize to is called its
environment
and you can see here i guess we have a
robot who's trying to get chest full of
gyms or whatever and that's the output
and then you have your action this is
all possible steps that can be taken by
the model and it picks one action and
you can see here it's picked three
different routes to get to the chest of
diamonds and gems
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this if you're
playing like a video game this is the
screen you're looking at so when you go
back here
the environment is a whole
game board so if you're playing one of
those mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on uh but then you have your
current position where are you on that
game board what's around that what's
around you
if you were talking about a robot the
environment might be moving around the
yard
where it is in the yard and what it can
see what input it has in that location
that would be the current position
condition returned by the model and then
the reward to help the model move in the
right direction it is rewarded points
are given to it to appraise some kind of
action
so yeah you did good or didn't do as
good trying to maximize the reward and
have the best reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action and present
state
this is part of the model what is your
action that you're you're going to take
what's the policy you're using to have
an output from your agent
one of the reasons they separate
policy as its own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
of a different options
and then the policy well how am i going
to pick the best based on those
predictions i'm going to guess at
different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work
so it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works
let's go and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look consider what a dog
that we want to train uh so the dog
would be like the agent so you have your
your puppy or whatever
uh and then your environment is gonna be
the whole house or whatever it is where
you're training them
and then you have an action we wanna
teach the dog to fetch
so action equals fetching
and then we have a little biscuit so we
can get the dog to perform various
actions by offering incentives such as a
dog biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself
so you have you know so we start off
with fetching it goes oh i get a biscuit
for that it tries something else you get
a handshake or begging or something like
that and goes oh this is also reward
based and so it kind of explores things
to find out what will bring his biscuit
and that's very much like how reinforced
model goes as it
looks for different rewards how do i
find can i try different things and find
a reward that works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explorer's environment
this quality of model is called
exploration so there's a little
randomness going on in exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
is a reinforcement learning policy used
to map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
solutions and receive rewards
and you'll see here's all of our
different uh vocabulary we just went
over we have a reward our state our
agent our environment interaction and so
even though the environment kind of
contains everything um
that you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment's
going to put out a reward in state that
goes into the agent
the agent then looks at this state or it
looks at the reward usually
first and it says okay i got rewarded
for whatever i just did or it didn't get
rewarded
and it looks at the state
and then it comes back and if you
remember from
policy the policy comes in
and then we have a reward the policy is
that part that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and it
says hey
what's a good action that will probably
be similar to what i did or um sometimes
they're completely random but what's a
good action that's going to bring me a
different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today
and so a lot of them actually have
templates
based on this you can pull in and start
using
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works
you can see your environment sends it
says hey this is the agent did this if
you're a character in a game this
happened and it shoots out a reward in a
state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says i'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment
it affects the environment the
environment then changes depending on
what the action was
and then it has a new state and a new
reward that goes back to the agent
so in the diagram shown we need to find
the shortest path between node a and d
each path has a reward associated with
it and the path with a maximum reward is
what we want to choose
the nodes a b c d denote the nodes to
travel from node
a to b
is an action reward is the cost of each
path and policy is each path taken
and you can see here a can go uh to b
or a can go to c right off the bat or
can go right to d
and if explored all three of these
you would find that a going to d was a
zero reward
a going to c and d would generate a
different reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here and so when we start
looking at this diagram you start to
realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see
and so they take up a lot of work
or a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems and
we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in the tic tac toe game
but you can see here uh once it's gone
through these and it's explored it's
going to find the a c d
is the best reward it gets a full 30
points for it
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
reinforcement learning
demo
in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a
tic-tac-toe game you'll be playing this
game against the machine learning model
and we'll go ahead we're doing it in
python so let's go ahead and go through
i always not always actually have a lot
of python tools let's go through
anaconda which will open up a jupiter
notebook seems like a lot of steps but
it's worth it to keep all my stuff
separate and it's also has a nice
display when you're in the jupiter
notebook for doing python
so here's our anaconda navigator i open
up the notebook which is going to take
me to a web page and i've gone in here
and created a new uh python folder in
this case i've already done it and
enabled it to change the name to
tic-tac-toe and then for this example uh
we're going to go ahead and
import a couple things we're going to
import numpy as np we'll go ahead and
import pickle numpy of course is our
number array and then pickle's just a
nice way sometimes for
storing different information different
states that we're going to go through on
here
and so
we're going to create a class called
state we're going to start with that
and there's a lot of lines of code to
this class that we're going to put in
here
don't let that scare you too much
there's not as much here
it looks like there's going to be a lie
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class state
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it
we have our board
it's a tic tac toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board
we have player one player 2
is end we're going to create a board
hash
we'll look at that in just a minute
we're just going to store some
information in there symbol player
equals one
so there's a few things going on as far
as the initialization
then something simple we're just going
to get the hash
of the board you get the information
from the board on there which is
columns and rows
we want to know when a winner occurs so
if you get three in a row that's what
this whole section here is for
let me go ahead and
scroll up a little bit
and you can get a copy of this code if
you send a note over to simply learn
we'll send you over
this particular file and you can play
with it yourself and see how it's put
together
i don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this because this is just some
real general python coding
but you can see here we're just going
through all the rows
and you add them together and if it
equals three three in a row same thing
with columns
uh diagonal so you gotta check the
diagonal that's what all this stuff does
here is it just goes through the
different areas actually let me go ahead
and put
there we go
um and then it comes down here and we do
our sum and it says true
minus three just says did somebody win
or is it a tie
so you gotta add up all the numbers on
there anyway just in case they're all
filled up and next we also need to know
available positions
these are ones that don't no one's ever
used before this way when you try
something or the computer tries
something it's not going to give it an
illegal move that's what the available
positions is doing
then we want to update our state
and so you have your position going in
we're just sending in the position that
you just chose and you'll see there's a
little user interface we put in there we
can
pick the row and column in there
and again
i mean this is a lot of code
so really it's kind of a thing you'd
want to go through and play with a
little bit and just read through it get
a copy of it a great way to understand
how this works and here is a given
reward
so we're going to give a reward
result equals self winner
this is one of the hearts of what's
going on here
is we have a result self.winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result that the result equals one here's
our feedback
uh if it doesn't equal one then it gets
a zero so it only gets a reward in this
particular case
if it wins
and that's important to know because
different
systems of reinforced learning
do rewarding a lot differently depending
on what you're trying to do this is a
very simple example with a
3x3 board
imagine if you're playing a video game
certainly you only have so many actions
but your environment is huge you have a
lot going on in the environment and
suddenly a reward system like this
is going to be just
it's going to have to change a little
bit it's going to have to have different
rewards and different setup and there's
all kinds of advanced ways to do that as
far as weighing you add weights to it
and so
they can add the weights up depending on
where the reward comes in so it might be
that you actually get a reward in this
case you get the reward at the end of
the game
and i'm spending just a little bit of
time on this this is an important thing
to note but there's different ways to
add up those rewards it might have like
if you take a certain path
the first reward
is going to be weighed a little bit less
than the last reward because the last
reward is actually winning the game or
scoring or whatever it is
so this reward system gets really
complicated in some of the more advanced
uh setups
in this case though
you can see right here that they give a
0.1 and a 0.5 reward
just for getting picking the right value
and something that's actually valid
instead of picking an invalid value so
rewards again that's like key it's huge
how do you
feed the rewards back in
then we have a board reset that's pretty
straightforward it just goes back and
resets the board at the beginning
because it's going to try out all these
different things while it's learning
it's going to do it by trial and error
so you have to keep resetting it
and then of course there's the play we
want to go ahead and play rounds equals
depends on what you want to do on here
you can set this
different you can obviously set that to
higher level but this is just going to
go through and you'll see in here
that we have player 1 and player 2.
this is this is the computer playing
itself uh one of the more powerful ways
to learn to play a game
or even learn something that isn't a
game is to have two of these models
that are basically trying to beat each
other and so they always they keep
finding explore new things this one
works for this one so this one tries new
things
it beats this we've seen this in chess i
think with some big one where they had
the two players in chess with
reinforcement learning
is one of the ways they train one of the
top
computer chess playing algorithms
so this is just what this is it's going
to choose an action it's going to try
something and the more i try stuff
the more we're going to record the hash
we actually have a board hash where they
self get the hash
set up on here where it stores all the
information
and then once you get to a win
one of them wins it gets the reward
uh then we go back and reset and try
again and then kind of the fun part we
actually get down here is uh we're going
to play
with a human so we'll get a chance to
come in here and see what that looks
like
when you put your own information in
and then it just comes in here and does
the same thing it did above it gives it
a reward for its things
or sees if it wins or ties
um
looks at available positions all that
fun of fun stuff
and then finally we want to show the
board
so it's going to print the board out
each time
really
as an integration is not that exciting
what's exciting
in here is one looking at this reward
system whoops play one more up the
reward system is really the heart of
this how do you reward the different
setup
and the other
one is when it's playing it's got to
take an action
and so
what it chooses for an action is also
the heart of reinforcement learning how
do we choose that action
and those are really
key to right now where reinforcement
learning is
in
today's technology is
figuring this out
how do we reward it and how do we guess
the next best action so we have our
environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state
which is kind of like what's going on
we're going to return the state
depending on what happens
we want to go ahead and create our agent
in this case our player so each one is
grab that
and so we look at a class player
this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state
uh that it can look at and reward uh so
we want to take a look at this we have
uh name uh self-state this is class
player and when you say class player
we're not talking about a human player
we're talking about um just a the
computer players
and this is kind of interesting so
remember i told you depending on what
you're doing there's going to be a decay
gamma um
explorate
these are what i'm talking about is how
do we train it
as you try different moves it gets to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight and then as you
as you get there the first one let's see
the first move gives you a five reward
the second gives you a two reward and
the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it the 10's gonna count more than the
first step
uh and here's our we're going to get the
board information coming in and then
choose an action this was the second
part that i was talking about that was
so important
so once you have your training going on
we have to do a little randomness and
you can see right here is our np random
uniform so it's picking out a
random number
take a random action
this is going to just pick which row and
which column it is
and so choosing the action
this one you can see we're just doing
random states
choice length of positions action
position
and then it skips in there and takes a
look at the board uh for p in positions
it's actually storing the different
boards each time you go through
so it has a record of what it did so it
can properly weigh the values
and this simply just depends a hash date
what's the last date pinned it to the
to our states on here
here's our feedback
rewards the reward comes in and it's
going to take a look at this and say is
it none
what is the reward and here is that
formula remember i was telling you about
up here
that was important because it has
decay gamma times the reward
this is where
as it goes through each step
and this is really important this is
this is kind of the heart of this of
what i was talking about earlier uh you
have step one
and this might have a reward of two
you have step two i should probably
should have done abc this has a step
three
uh step four
and so on until you get to step in
and this might have a reward of ten
so reward a ten
we're going to add that but we're not
adding
let's say this one right here
let's say this reward here right before
10 was
let's say it's also 10. it just makes
the
math easy so we had 10 and 10.
we had 10 this is 10 and 10 n whatever
it is
but it's time it's 0.9
uh so instead of putting a full 10 here
we only do 9 that's a
0.9
times
10.
and so this formula
as far as the decay times the reward
minus the cell state value uh it
basically adds in it says here's one or
here's two i'm sorry i should have done
this abc would have been easier
so the first move goes in here and it
puts two in here
then we have our self set up on here you
can see how this gets pretty complicated
in the math but this is really the key
is how do we train
our states and we want the the final
state the win to get the most points if
you win you get most points uh and the
first step gets the least amount of
points
so you're really training this almost in
reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now i was need
to sum up my rewards
and i want to sum them up going in
reverse and i want to find the answer in
reverse kind of an interesting
play on the mind when you're trying to
figure this stuff out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here
save the policy
load policy
these are the different things that are
going in between the agent and the state
to figure out what's going on
let's go ahead and load that up
and then finally we want to go ahead and
create a human player
and the human player is going to be a
little different
in that
you choose an action row and column
here's your action
if action is
if action in positions meaning positions
that are available
uh you return the action
if not it just keeps asking you until
you get the action that actually works
and then we're going to go ahead and
append to the hash state which we don't
need to worry about because it returns
the action up here
and feed forward
again this is because it's a human
at the end of the game bat propagate and
update state values
this part isn't being done because
it's not programming uh
the model the model is getting its own
rewards
so we've gone ahead and loaded this in
here
so here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to do
is set up p1 player 1
p2 player 2
and then we're going to send our players
to our state so now it has p1 p2
and it's going to play and it's going to
play 50 000 rounds
now we can probably do a lot less than
this and it's not going to get the full
results in fact you know what
let's go ahead and just do five
just to play with it because i want to
show you something here
oops
somewhere in there i forgot to load
something
there we go
i must just forgot to run this run
oops forgot a reference there for the
board rows and columns three by three
there is actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning
so now i've only set this up
with
see where are we going here
i've only set this up to train
five times
and the reason i did that is we're going
to
come in and actually play it and then
i'm going to change that and we can see
how it differs on there
there we go and then you make it through
a run and we're going to go ahead and
save the policy
so now we have our player 1 and our
player 2 policy
the way we set it up it has two separate
policies loaded up in there
and then we're gonna come in here and
we're gonna do uh player one is gonna be
the computer experience rate zero load
policy one
human player human and we're going to go
ahead and play this i remember only went
through it
just one round of training in fact
minimal training and so it puts an x
there and i'm going to go ahead and do
row 0
column 1.
you can see this is very uh basic on
here
and
so i put in my zero and then i'm going
to go zero block it zero
zero
and you can see right here it let me win
uh just like that i was able to win zero
two
and whoo human wins
so i only trained it five times we're
going to run this again
and this time
instead of five let's do five thousand
or fifty thousand i think that's what
the guys in the back had
and this takes a while to train it
this is where reinforcement learning
really falls apart
look how simple this game is we're
talking about a three by three set of
columns
and so for me to train it on this
i could do a q table which would take
which would go much quicker
you could build a quick q table with
almost all the different options on
there
and
you would probably get a the same result
much quicker
we're just using this as an example
so when we look at reinforcement
learning you need to be very careful
what you apply it to it sounds like a
good deal until you do like a large
neural network
where you're doing you set the neural
network to a learning increment of one
so every time it goes through it learns
and then you do your actions you pick
from the learning
setup and you actually try actions on
the learning setup until you get what
you think is going to be the best action
so you actually feed what you think is
right back through the neural network
there's a whole layer there which is
really fun to play with
and then it has an output well think of
all those processes i mean that is just
a huge amount of work it's going to do
let's go ahead and skip ahead here give
it a moment it's going to take a
minute or two to go ahead and run
now to train it
we went ahead and let it run and it took
a while this this took um i got a pretty
powerful processor and it took about
five minutes plus to run it
and we'll go ahead and
run our player set up on here oops
brought in the last
whoops abroad in the last round so give
me just a moment to re
do the policy save there we go i forgot
to save the policy back in there
and then go ahead and run our player
again
so we've saved the policy then we want
to go ahead and load the policy for p1
as the computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner i'm going to go
ahead and go 1-1 which is the center
and it's gone right up the top and if
you ever played tic-tac-toe you know the
computer has me uh but we'll go ahead
and play it out
row zero
column two
there it is and then it's gone here and
so i'm going to go ahead and go row zero
one
two
no zero one there we go and column zero
that's where i want it
oh and it says okay you your action
there we go boom
uh so you can see here we've got a
didn't catch the win on this it said tie
kind of funny that didn't catch the win
on there
but if we play this a bunch of times
you'll find it's going to win more and
more the more we train it the more the
reinforcement happens
this lengthy training process
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning
as this changes reinforcement learning
will be one of the more powerful
packages evolving over the next decade
or two
in fact i would even go as far as to say
it is the most important
machine learning tool and artificial
intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple tic tac
toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language if you're
translating a language or something from
one language to the other so much of it
is lost if you don't know the context
it's in what's the environments it's in
and so being able to attach environment
and context and all those things
together is going to require
reinforcement learning to do
so again if you want to get a copy of
the tic tac toe board it's kind of fun
to play with run it you can test it out
you can do
you know test it for different
values you can switch from p1 computer
where we loaded the policy 1 to load the
policy 2 and just see how it varies
there's all kinds of things you can do
on there welcome to q learning
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead
what's in it for you today an
introduction to reinforcement learning
what is q learning some important terms
bellman equation
steps in q learning a quick
recap so we're going to go back and do a
reinforcement learning recap and you'll
remember we have our agent our action
our environment and our reward
and the state
and so uh reinforcement learning is a
branch of machine learning that trains a
model to come to an optimum solution for
a problem
by taking decisions by itself
so we look at it we analyze the data
make decisions solve problems
it consists of an environment which an
agent will interact with to learn to
reach a goal or perform an action
and you see here we have the dog
and the action equals fetching
and the first thing uh you're going to
notice here and i'll talk a little bit
more about this
is that our action is kind of a
singularity uh the action isn't a
regression type model where we're
looking at float numbers
or we're trying to predict something
or doing a reinforcement learning where
we're trying to guess the value of the
stock market where you have
5.33 5.33 cents this is very a little
bit different and you'll see why q
learning is so powerful but also where
it falls short
uh the agent is also given reward if the
action performed by it is bringing is
closer to the goal is leading to the
goal this is done to train the model in
the right direction you have a reward of
a hopefully a doggy cookie
and action equals fetching so it gets a
reward it gets to go fetch the ball
reinforcement learning can be divided
based on whether the machine uses a
model to learn or learns by itself
so reinforcement learning it's model
based learn the model given model
and you can think of neural networks i
think are the most common right now used
for reinforcement learning there
certainly are a lot of other options out
there
but you have this black box and you go
back and you send the error back up and
it trains it based on how much of an
error the error could be computed based
on maybe a maximum reward
subtraction or something like that so
the closer you get to
the maximum reward the better
and so we talk about a model free
you have your policy optimization and
your q learning
and
this is kind of the cool thing about q
learning is it can do it's very powerful
on certain things making it very quick
and easy to do a reinforcement learning
so what is q learning q learning is
reinforcement learning policy which will
fill the next best action given a
current state it chooses this action at
random and aims to maximize the reward
and so you can see here's our standard
reinforcement learning graph
by now if you're doing any reinforcement
learning
you should
be familiar with this where you have
your agent your agent takes an action
the action affects the environment
and then the environment sends back the
reward or the feedback and the state
it's the new state the agent's in where
is it at on the chessboard where is it
at in the video game
um if your robot's out there picking
trash up off the side of the road where
is it at on the road
consider an ad recommendation system
usually when you look up a product
online
you get ads which will suggest the same
product over and over again
using q learning
we can make an ad recommendation system
which will suggest related products to
our previous purchase
the reward will be if user clicks on the
suggested product
and again you can see
you might have a lot of products
on your web advertisement or your pages
but it's still not a float number it's
still a set number and that's something
to be aware of when you're using q
learning and you can see here that if
you have a hundred people clicking on
ads and you click on one of the ads it
might go in there and say okay this
person clicked on this ad
what is the best set of ads based on
clicking on this ad or these two ads
afterwards based on where they are
browsing
so let's go ahead and look at some
important terms we talk about q-learning
we have states the state s represents
the current position of an agent in an
environment
the action the action a is the step
taken by the agent when it is particular
state
rewards for every action the agent will
get a positive or negative reward
and again uh when we talk about states
we're usually not with when you're using
a q table you're not usually talking
about float variables you're talking
about true false
and we'll take a closer look at that in
a second
and episodes when an agent ends up in a
terminating state and can't take a new
action
this might be if you're playing a video
game your character stepped in and is
now dead or whatever
uh
q values used to determine how good an
action a taken at a particular state s
is q a of s
and temporal difference a formula used
to find the q value by using the value
of the current state and action and
previous state in action
and various i mean there's bellman's
equation which basically is the equation
that
kind of covers what we just looked at in
all those different terms
the bellman equation is used to
determine the values of a particular
state and deduce how good it is to be in
take that state the optimal st the
optimal state will give us the highest
optimal value
factor influencing q values the current
state and action that's your sa so your
current state and your action
uh then you have your previous date in
action which is your s i guess prime i'm
not sure how the how they reference that
s prime a prime so this is what happened
before
uh then you have a reward for action so
you have your r reward
and you have your maximum expected
future reward
and you can see there's also a learning
rate put in there and a discount rate
so we're looking at these just like any
other model we don't want to have an
absolute
final value on here we don't want it to
if you do absolute values instead of
taking smaller steps you don't really
have that approach to
the solution you just have a jump and
then pretty soon if you jump one
solution out that's what's going to be
the new solution whichever one jumps up
really high first
kind of ruining the whole idea of doing
a random selection i'll go into the
random selection in just a second steps
in q learning
step one create an initial q table with
all values initialized to zero
again we're looking at
zero one uh so are you you know here's
our action we start we're an idle we
took a wrong action we took a correct
action and int
and then we have our actions fetching
sitting and running
of course we're just using the dog
example and choose an action and perform
it update values in the table and of
course when we're choosing an action
we're going to kind of do something
random and just randomly pick one so you
start out and you sit and you have then
then depending on that
action you took you can now update the
value for sitting after you start from
start to sitting
get the value of the reward and
calculate the value the value q value
using the bellman equation
and so now we attach a reward to sitting
and we attach all those rewards we
continue the same until the table is
filled with or an episode ends
and
my memory is going to come back to the
random side of this and there's a few
different formulas they use for the
random
setup to pick it i usually look whatever
q model i'm using
do their standard one because someone's
usually gone in and done the math
for the optimal
spread
but you can look at this if i have
running has a reward of 10 sitting as a
reward of seven fetching has a reward of
five
um
just kind of without doing like a a
means to you know using the bell curve
for the means value and like i said
there's some math you can put in there
to pick so that you're more like so that
running has even a higher chance
but even if you're just going to do an
average on this
you could do an average a random number
by adding them all together
so you get 10 plus 7 plus 5 is
22 you could do zero to 22
or zero to 21 but one to 22
one to five would be fetching uh and so
forth you know the last ten
so you can just look at this as what
percentage are you going to go for that
particular option
and then that gets your random setup in
there and then as you slowly increment
these up
you see that
if you're idle
where's one here we go sitting at the
end
if you're at the end of wherever you're
at sitting gets a reward of one
where's the good one on here oh wrong
action running for a wrong action gets
almost no reward so that becomes very
very less likely to happen
but it still might happen it still might
have a percentage of coming up
and that's where the random programming
and q learning comes in the below table
gives us an idea of how many times an
action has been taken and how positively
correct action or negatively wrong
action it is going to affect the next
state
so let's go ahead and dive in and pull
up a little piece of code and see what
this looks like
[Music]
in python
in this demo we'll use q learning to
find the shortest path between two given
points
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
if you've seen my videos before
i like to do it in the
anaconda jupiter notebook
setup just because it's really easy to
see and it's a nice demo
and so here's my anaconda this one i'm
actually using python python36
environment that i set up in here
and we'll go ahead and launch the
jupiter notebook on this
and once we're in our jupyter notebook
which has the kernel loaded with python3
we'll go ahead and create a new python3
folder in here
and we'll call this
q
learning
and to start this demo
let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's
imported
and like a lot of these uh model
programs when you're building them you
spend a lot of time putting it all
together
and then you end up with this really
short answer at the end
uh and we'll we'll take a look at that
as we come into it so we go ahead and
start with our location to state uh so
we have uh l1 l2 these are our nine
locations one to nine
and then of course the state is going to
be zero one two 3 4. it's just a mapping
of our location to a integer on there
and then we have our actions our actions
are simply
moving from
one location
to another so i can go to i can go to
location zero i can go to location one
two three four five six seven eight uh
so these are my actions i can choose
these are the locations of our state
and if you remember earlier i mentioned
that the limitation is that you you
don't want to put in
a continually growing table because you
can actually create a dynamic queue
table where you continually add in new
values as they arise
because um if you have float values this
just becomes infinite and then you're
remembering your computer is gone or you
know does it's not going to work
at the same time you might think well
that kind of really limits the the q uh
learning setup
but there are ways to use it in
conjunction with other systems
and so you might look at
uh well i do
i've been doing some work in stock
and one of the questions that comes out
is to buy or sell the stock
and the stake coming in
might be
you might take a concrete way called
buckets
where anything that you predict is going
to return more than a certain amount of
money
um the error for that stock that you've
had in the past you put those in buckets
and suddenly you start putting creating
these buckets you realize you do have a
limited amount of information coming in
you no longer have a float number you
now have
bucket one two three and four
and then you can take those buckets
put them through a
q learning table and come up with the
best action which stock should i buy
it's like gambling stock is pretty much
gambling if you're doing day trading
you're not doing long term
investments and so you can start looking
at it like that a lot of the
current fees say that the best
algorithms used for day traders redoing
it on your own
is really to ask the question do i want
to trade the stock yes or no and now you
have it in a q learning table and now
you can take it to that next level and
you can see where that can be a really
powerful tool
at the end of doing a basic linear
regression model or something
um what is the best investment and you
start getting the best reward on there
uh and the so if we're gonna have
rewards these rewards we just create
it says if basically if you're
this should match our q table because
it's going to be
you have your state and you have your
action across the top if you remember
from the dog
and so we have whatever state we're in
going down and then the next action and
what the reward is for it
and of course if you were actually doing
a
something more connected your reward
would be based on
the actual environment it's in
and then we want to go ahead and create
a state to location
so we can map the indexes
so just like we defined our rewards
we're going to go and do state to
location
and you can see here it's a dictionary
set up for location state in location to
state with items
and
we also need to
define what we want for learning rates
you remember
we had our two different rates
as far as like learning from the past
and learning from the current so we'll
go ahead and set those to
0.75 and the alpha set to 0.9
and we'll see that when we do the
formula
and of course any of this code send a
note to our simply learn team they'll
get you a copy of this code
on here let's go ahead and pull
there we go
the next two sections
um
since we're going to keep it
short and sweet
here we go so let's go ahead and create
our agent um so our agent
is going to have our initialization
where we send it all the information
uh we'll define ourself gamma equals
gamma we could have just set the gamma
rate down here instead of submitting it
it's kind of nice to keep them separate
because you can play with these numbers
on our self alpha
then we have our location state we'll
set that in here we have our choice of
actions
um we're going to go ahead and just
embed the rewards right into the agent
so obviously this would be coming from
somewhere else instead of from
uh self-generated and then a self state
to location equals our state to location
uh dictionary
and we go ahead and create a q learning
table and i went ahead and just set the
q learning table up to
zero to zero what what what the setup is
location to state how many of them are
there
and this just creates an array of zero
to zero set up on there
and then the big part is the training we
have our rewards new equals a copy of
self.rewards
ending state equals the self-location
state in location so this is whatever we
end up at rewards new equals ending
state plus ending state equals 999 just
kind of goes
to a dead end
and
we start going through iterations
and we'll go ahead let's do this
so this we're gonna come back and we're
gonna call call it on here uh let me
just erase that
switch it to an arrow
there we go
uh so what we're doing is we're gonna
send in here to train it we're gonna say
hey
i want to iterate through this a
thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be
instead of iterating you might have your
external environment and they're going
back and forth and you iterate through
outside of here
but just for ease of use our agent is
going to come in here and iterate
through this
sometimes i'll put this iteration in
here
and i'll have it call the environment
and say hey this is what i did what's
the next state and the environment does
this thing right in here as i iterate
through it
and then we want to go ahead and pick a
random state to start with
that's what's going on here you have to
start somewhere
and then you have your playable actions
we're going to start with just an empty
thing for playable actions and we'll
fill that up
so that's what choices i have
and so we're going to iterate through
the rewards matrix to get the states
directly reachable from the randomly
chosen current state assign those states
to a list named playable actions
and so you can see here we have a range
nine i usually use length of whatever
i'm looking at which is our locations or
states as they are uh we have a reward
so we want to look at the current the
rewards uh the new reward
is our
is in our chart here of rewards
underscore new uh current state
plus j
j being what is the next state we want
to try
and so we go ahead and do our playable
actions and we append j
and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better reward
and then of course we go ahead and
choose our next state
so we have our random choice playable
actions
and if you remember
i mentioned on this let me just go ahead
and let's just do a free form
when we were talking about the next
state
this right here just does a random
selection
instead of a random
you might do something where uh whatever
the best selection is
which might be option three
here and then so you can see that it
might use a bell curve and then option
two over here might have a bell curve
like this oops
and we start looking at these averages
and these spreads
or we can just add them all together and
pick the one that kind of goes in all of
those
so those are some of the options we have
in here we just go with a random choice
that's usually where you start play with
it
and then we have our
rewards section down here
and so we want to go ahead and find well
in this case the temporal difference
so you have your rewards new plus the
self gamma and this is the formula we
were looking at
this is bellman's equation here
so we have our current value our
learning rate our discount rate involved
in there the reward system coming in for
that
and we can add it all together
this is of course our
maximum expected future set up in here
so this is all of our our bellman's
equation that we're looking at here
and then we come up in here and we
update our q table that's all this is on
this one
that's right here we have
self cue current state next date and we
add in our alpha because we don't want
to we don't want to train all of it at
once in case there's slight difference
is coming in there we want to slowly
approach the answer
and then we have our route equals the
start location
and next location equals start location
so we're just incrementing we took a
step forward
and then finally remember i was telling
you how we're going to do all this and
just have some simple thing at the end
or just generates a simple path
we're going to go ahead and and get the
optimal route we want to find the best
route in here
and so we've created a definition for
the optimal route down here
just scroll down for that
and we get the optimal route we go ahead
and put the information in including the
q table self
uh start location in location next
location route q
and it says while next location is not
equal to in location so while we can
still go
our start location equals self location
to state start location so we already
have our best value for the start
location uh the next state looks at the
q table and says hey what's uh the next
one with the best value and then the
next location we go ahead and pull that
in and we just append it that's what's
going on down here
and then our start location equals the
next location and we just go through all
the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this
and now that we have our q table our
q agent loaded
we're going to go ahead and take our q
agent
load them up with their alpha gamma that
we set up above
along with the location step action
reward state to location
and
uh our goal is to
plot a course between l9 and l1
and we're gonna go through a hundred a
thousand iterations on here
and so when i run that it runs pretty
quick
uh why is this so fast um
if you've been running neural networks
and you've been doing all these other
models you sit here and wait a long time
well we're very small amount of data
these are all integers these aren't
float values there's not a the math is
not heavy on the on the processing end
and this is where q tables are so
powerful if you have a small amount of
information coming in
you very quickly uh get an answer off of
this even though we went through it a
thousand times to train it and you'll
see here we have l nine eight five two
and one and that's based on our reward
table we had set up on there and this is
the shortest path going between these
different
setups in here
and if you remember on our reward table
you can see that if you start here you
can go to here there's places you can't
go that's how this reward table was set
up so i can only go to certain places
so kind of a little maze set up in there
and you can play with it this is really
fun
set up to play with
and you can see how you can take this
whole code and you can like i was saying
earlier you can embed it into another
setup and model and predictions where
you put things into buckets and you're
trying to guess the best investment the
best course of action
long as you can take that course of
action and and uh
reduce it down to a yes no um or if
you're using text
you can use a one hot encoder which word
is next there's all kinds of things you
can do with a cue table
depending on just how much information
you're putting in there what is machine
learning hello my name is richard
kirschner i'm with the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead today we're
covering what is machine learning what's
in it for you we're going to cover the
basics of machine learning what is
machine learning artificial intelligence
versus machine learning versus deep
learning how does machine learning work
types of machine learning machine
learning pre-requisites applications of
machine learning here we have our
looks a little bit like frankenstein our
frankenstein looking robot today let me
tell you what is machine learning
machine learning works on the
development of computer programs that
can access data and use it to
automatically learn and improve from
experience
watch a robot builder construct a house
in two days this was back in july 29
2016 so that's pretty impressive this
amount of time to continue to grow in
his development and it's smart enough to
leave spaces in the brickwork for wiring
and plumbing and can even cut and shape
bricks to size
amazon echo relies on machine learning
and with more data it becomes more
accurate play your favorite music order
pizza from domino's voice control your
home request rides from uber have you
ever wondered the difference between ai
machine learning and deep learning
artificial intelligence a technique
which enables machines to mimic human
behavior this is really important
because this is how we are able to gauge
how well our computations or what we're
working on works is the fact that we're
mimicking human behavior we're using
this to replace human work and make it
more efficient and make it more
streamlined and more accurate and so the
center of artificial intelligence is the
big picture of all this put together ibm
deep blue chess electronic game
characters those are just a couple
examples of artificial intelligence
machine learning a technique which uses
statistical methods enabling machines to
learn from their past data so this means
if you have your input from last time
and you have your answer you use that to
help prove the next guess it makes for
the correct answer ibm watson google
search algorithm email spam filters
these are all part of machine learning
and then deep learning which is a subset
of machine learning composing algorithms
that allow a model to train itself and
perform tasks
alphago natural speech recognition these
are a couple examples deep learning is
associated with tools like neural
networks where it's kind of a black box
as it learns it changes all these things
that are as a human we would have a very
hard time tracking and it's able to come
up with an answer from that now let's
see how machine learning works
first we start with training the data
once we've trained the data the train we
go into the machine learning algorithm
which then puts the data into a
processing which then goes down to
machine another machine learning
algorithm and then we take new data
because you have to test whatever you
did to make sure it works correctly and
we put that into the same algorithm once
we do that we check our prediction we
check our results and from the
prediction if we've set aside some
training date and we find that it didn't
do a good job predicting it and it gets
a thumbs down as you see then we go back
to the beginning and we retrain the
algorithm and a lot of times it's not
just about getting the wrong answer it's
about continually trying to get a better
answer so you'll see the first time you
might be like oh this is not the answer
i want depending on what domain you're
working in whether it's medical
economical business stocks whatever you
try out your model and if it's not
giving you a good answer you retrain it
if you think you can get a better answer
you retrain it and you keep doing that
until you get the best answer you can
let's see the types of machine learning
supervised learning unsupervised
learning there's a number of ways to
divide up machine learning and how it
works these are two main categories you
can divide it into supervised learning
we have a known amount of data so in
this case we have a bunch of apples we
have a machine learning algorithm it
goes through the process it goes through
and trains the model based on that known
data and then once you've trained your
model on the known stuff you can then
put an unknown data in there and you get
a new response and of course in this
particular one it's an apple so it's
trying to figure out whether it's an
apple or another fruit there are many
different algorithms you can use for
computing this information for doing
this supervised training just to list
the some of the top ones that are
currently being used and by no means not
there's more than just this so by no
means this isn't the complete list
there's polynomial regression there's a
random forest there's linear regression
there's logistic regression there's
decision trees there's k-nearest
neighbors and there's naive bayes like i
said this is just a short list of some
of the many tools that are out there
nowadays and if you have supervised
learning then we should also look at
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning so we have unknown data in this
case you can see we have a bunch of
fruit and we might not have labeled it
we don't know we've never had anybody
look at it and say this is what this is
and we take that data and we put it
through the machine learning algorithm
and then that goes through the
processing and then the trained model
and what the trained model says hey can
i see a pattern here and from that
pattern it divides it up into a response
in this case apples and pairs you can
see some of these things look just like
the other and it tries to put them all
together so that you get similar things
in similar groups and again we have a
nice list of algorithms here and this is
not the only algorithms used for this so
don't limit yourself to this just these
these are just some of the primary ones
used today and of course we have the
k-means clustering singular value
decomposition fuzzy means partial least
squares a priori hierarchical clustering
principle component analysis
machine learning pre-requisites computer
science fundamentals and programming so
any of the machine learning out today
you have to know some basic scripting or
programming intermediate statistical
knowledge you have to understand a
little bit about probabilities if a is
current how likely is b going to happen
if there's clouds overhead how likely is
it going to rain
linear algebra and intermediate calculus
the linear algebra is very important
because you have to understand basically
drawing a line through the data points
and what that means that's the most
fundamental linear regression model as
you draw a line through all your data
and you use that line to compute new
values intermediate calculus means you
need to have a little bit of
understanding of what a differential
equation is you really don't need to be
an expert because the computer does all
the heavy lifting for you but it's
important to know the terms when they
come up unless you're doing some
advanced programming on the actual
models themselves and data wrangling and
cleaning i would say this might be the
biggest one in here is you have to start
getting a grip on how to clean up your
data there's a saying is bad data in bad
data out good data in you're more likely
to have good data out
some applications of machine learning
instant segmentation object detection
instant segmentation you can see here
where they use machine learning to go in
there and find where the different cats
are and the different objects are in the
picture and then in segmentation it
actually cuts them out kind of a fun one
especially if you have a google pixel
phone and you can do little animation
objects on top of your ongoing pictures
you're taking or movies
number plate detection you can see here
where we have a card it comes in there
and it finds a number plate on the car
once it's done that it can then do
automatic translation automatic
translation is we pick up some symbols
in this case on a machine and it does
machine translation so that you can know
what it's saying even if you don't speak
that language let's look at another
example machine learning based on the
amount of rainfall how much would be the
crop yield so we here we have our crops
we have our rainfall and we want to know
how much we're going to get from our
crops this year so we're going to
introduce two variables independent and
dependent the independent variable is a
variable whose value does not change by
the effect of other variables and is
used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as x in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in this is kind of
random data from any kind of project we
want to divide it up into numerical and
categorical so numerical is numbers age
salary
height where categorical would be
a description the color a dog's breed
gender categoricals limited to very
specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at a different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far we
have a lot of data and we draw a
straight line through it multiple linear
regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why it'd be multiple
linear regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance
i'm sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and x being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever x is m
in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the y2
minus y1 and x2 minus x1 and finally we
have c which is the coefficient of the
line or where it happens to cross the
zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
wiz and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e that's
opened up that just means summation
that's all that is so when you see the
sigma character it just means we're
adding everything in that row and for
computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the xy points and create
all the information you need so in the
top half you can see where we've broken
that down into pieces and as it goes
through the first two points it computes
the squared value of x the squared value
of y and x times y and then it takes all
of x and adds them up all of y adds them
up all of x squared adds them up and so
on and so on and you can see we have the
sum of equal to 15 the sum is equal to
20 all the way up to x times y where the
sum equals 66. this all comes from our
formula for calculating a straight line
where y equals the slope times x plus
the coefficient c so we go down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum of x times
y which we computed one line at a time
there and that's just the 66 and take
all that and you subtract it from the
sum of x times the sum of y and those
have both been computed so you have 15
times 20. and on the bottom we have the
number of lines times the sum of x
squared easily computed as 86 for the
sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values and we're going to go ahead and
plot them we're going to predict them so
y equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit lines should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart we can see x
and you can see y what we actual values
were and you can see why i predict it
you can easily see where we take y minus
y predicted and we get an answer what is
the difference between those two and if
we square that y minus y prediction
squared we can then sum those squared
values that's where we get the 0.64 plus
the 0.36 plus 1 all the way down until
we have a summation equals 2.4 so the
sum of squared errors for this
regression line is 2.4 we check this
error for each line and conclude the
best fit line having the least e square
value in a nice graphical representation
we can see here where we keep moving
this line through the data points to
make sure the best fit line has the
least square distance between the data
points and the regression line now we
only looked at the most commonly used
formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic multiple linear
regression let's take a brief look at
what happens when you have multiple
inputs so in multiple linear regression
we have uh well we'll start with the
simple linear regression where we had y
equals m plus x plus c and we're trying
to find the value of y now with multiple
linear regression we have multiple
variables coming in so instead of having
just x we have x1 x2 x3 and instead of
having just one slope each variable has
its own slope attached to it as you can
see here we have m1 m2 m3 and we still
just have the single coefficient so when
you're dealing with multiple linear
regression you basically take your
single linear regression and you spread
it out so you have y equals m1 times x1
plus m2 times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its r d trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it it's such
a visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupyter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipe
as plt and then seaborn as sns seaborn
works with the matplot library so you
have to always import matplot library
and then seaborn sits on top of it and
we'll take a look at what that looks
like you could use any of your own
plotting libraries you want there's all
kinds of ways to look at the data these
are just very common ones and the
seaborne is so easy to use it just looks
beautiful it's a nice representation
that you can actually take and show
somebody and the final line is the amber
scion map plot library inline that is
only because i'm doing an inline ide my
interface in the anaconda jupiter
notebook requires i put that in there or
you're not going to see the graph when
it comes up let's go ahead and run this
it's not going to be that interesting so
we're just setting up variables in fact
it's not going to do anything that we
can see but it is importing these
different libraries and setup the next
step is load the data set and extract
independent and dependent variables now
here in the slide you'll see companies
equals pd.read csv and it has a long
line there with the file at the end 1000
companies dot csv you're going to have
to change this to fit whatever setup you
have and the file itself you can request
just go down to the commentary below
this video and put a note in there and
simply learn we'll try to get in contact
with you and supply you with that file
so you can try this coding yourself so
we're going to add this code in here and
we're going to see that i have companies
equals pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the i location
and because this is companies as a pd
data set i can use this nice notation
that says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so x is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what panda is one
of the things pandas is really good
about is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carries
return i don't know about you but i go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents compared
to the administration cost of a hundred
and thirty six thousand eight hundred
ninety seven dollars and eighty cents so
on so on helps to create the profit of
192 261 and 83 cents that makes no sense
to me whatsoever no pun intended so
let's flip back here and take a look at
our next set of code where we're going
to graph it so we can get a better
understanding of our data and what it
means so at this point we're going to
use a single line of code to get a lot
of information so we can see where we're
going with this let's go ahead and paste
that into our
notebook and see what we got going and
so we have the visualization and again
we're using sns which is pandas as you
can see we imported the map plot library
dot pi plot as plt which then the
seaborn uses and we imported the
seaborne as sns and then that final line
of code helps us show this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file and other means and that's the
matplot library in line with the amber
sign at the beginning so here we come
down to the single line of code seaborne
is great because it actually recognizes
the panda data frame so i can just take
the companies dot core for coordinates
and i can put that right into the
seaborn and when we run this we get this
beautiful plot and let's just take a
look at what this plot means if you look
at this plot on mine the colors are
probably a little bit more purplish and
blue than the original one we have the
columns and the rows we have r and d
spending we have administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r d spending is going
to be the same as r d spending and the
same thing with administration costs
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark
diagonal row that shows that this is the
highest corresponding data that's
exactly the same and as it becomes
lighter there's less connections between
the data so we can see with profit
obviously profit is the same as profit
and next it has a very high correlation
with r d spending which we looked at
earlier and it has a slightly less
connection to marketing spending and
even less to how much money we put into
the administration so now that we have a
nice look at the data let's go ahead and
dig in and create some actual useful
linear regression models so that we can
predict values and have a better profit
now that we've taken a look at the
visualization of this data we're going
to move on to the next step instead of
just having a pretty picture we need to
generate some hard data some hard values
so let's see what that looks like we're
going to set up our linear regression
model in two steps the first one is we
need to prepare some of our data so it
fits correctly and let's go ahead and
paste this code into our jupyter
notebook and what we're bringing in is
we're going to bring in the sklearn
pre-processing where we're going to
import the label encoder and the one hot
encoder to use the label encoder we're
going to create a variable called label
encoder and set it equal to capital l
label capital e encoder this creates a
class that we can reuse for transferring
the labels back and forth now about now
you should ask what labels are we
talking about let's go take a look at
the data we processed before and see
what i'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column zero which is r and d
spending column one which is
administration column two which is
marketing spending and column three is
state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
as just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look what this
data is doing you'll see you have an
array of arrays and then each array is a
row of numbers and if i go ahead and
just do row 0 you'll see i have a nice
organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why
because the computer has automatically
transformed our header into the setup
and it's automatically transferring all
these different variables so when we did
the encoder the encoder created two
columns and what we need to do is just
have the one because it has both the
variable and the name that's what this
piece of code does here let's go ahead
and paste this in here and we have x
equals x colon comma one colon all this
is doing is removing that one extra
column we put in there when we did our
one hot encoder and our label encoding
let's go ahead and run that and now we
get to create our linear regression
model and let's see what that looks like
here and we're going to do that in two
steps the first step is going to be in
splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set and we have
a testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sk learn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different uh models you usually see that
a capital x and you see the train and
the test and the lowercase y what this
is is x is our data going in that's our
rnd spin our administration our
marketing and then y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity that's what we're going
to shoot for in this tutorial the next
part train test split we take x and we
take y we've already created those x has
the columns with the data in it and y
has a column with profit in it and then
we're going to set the test size equals
point two that basically means twenty
percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're going to put them off
to the side so since we're using a
thousand lines of data that means that
200 of those lines we're going to hold
off to the side to test for later and
then the random state equals 0. we're
going to randomize which ones it picks
to hold off to the side we'll go ahead
and run this it's not overly exciting
because it's setting up our variables
but the next step is the next step we
actually create our linear regression
model now that we got to the linear
regression model we get that next piece
of the puzzle let's go ahead and put
that code in there and walk through it
so here we go we're going to paste it in
there and let's go ahead and since this
is a shorter line of code let's zoom up
there so we can get a good look and we
have from the sklearn
linear underscore model we're going to
import linear regression now i don't
know if you recall from earlier when we
were doing all the math let's go ahead
and flip back there and take a look at
that do you remember this where we had
this long formula on the bottom and we
were doing all this summarization and
then we also looked at setting it up
with the different lines and then we
also looked all the way down to multiple
linear regression where we're adding all
those formulas together all of that is
wrapped up in this one section so what's
going on here is i'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor dot fit in this case we do
x train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor dot
predict x test going in and this gives
us y predict now because i'm in jupiter
inline i can just put the variable up
there and when i hit the run button
it'll print that array out i could have
just as easily done print why predict so
if you're in a different ide that's not
an inline setup like the jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side it's going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals m1 times x1 plus m2
times x2 and so on and so on plus c the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope one
times column one variable plus slope two
times column two variable all the way to
the m into the n and x to the n plus c
the coefficient or in this case you have
minus eight point eight nine to the
power of two et cetera et cetera times
the first column and the second column
and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus one zero three
zero nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now i told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning i said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look at what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us that we know are true the y
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a
0.9352 that's the r2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93 percent correct but
you do want that in the upper 90s oh and
higher shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the r2 score and if
r-squared value of 0.91 or 9-2 as we got
on our model remember it does have a
random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression all right what
is logistic regression as i mentioned
earlier logistic regression is an
algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the x and y axis x is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between zero and one and as we
can imagine it is intuitive as well as
the number of years are on the lower
side maybe one year two years or three
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down the probability
of your car breaking down within two
years of your last service are 0.1
probability similarly 3 years is maybe
0.3 and so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was 6 or 7
years there is almost a certainty that
your car is going to break down that is
what this graph shows so this is an
example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variable's outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about so
here the outcome is discrete and not a
continuous value so this is how the
logistic regression curve looks let me
explain a little bit what exactly how
exactly we are going to
determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistical regression
curve a threshold has to be said saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be 0 or 1
but based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say
an output of 0.29 is considered as 0
which means that the car will not break
down so that's the way logistic
regression works now let's do a quick
comparison between logistic regression
and linear regression because they both
have the term regression in them so it
can cause confusion so let's try to
remove that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say at the hr
team of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
us it is trained and it learns from this
labeled information so that when a new
employees information is fed based on
the rating it will determine what should
be the height so this is a linear
regression problem
linear regression example now salary is
a continuous value you can get 5
5 600 it is not discrete like a cat or a
dog or an apple or a banana these are
discrete or a yes or no these are
discrete values right so this way you
are trying to find continuous values is
where we use linear regression so let's
say just to extend on the scenario we
now want to find out whether this
employee is going to get a promotion or
not so we want to find out if that is a
discrete problem right a yes or no kind
of a problem in this case we actually
cannot use linear regression even though
we may have labeled data so this is the
label data so based on the employee
rating these are the ratings and then
some people got the promotion and this
is the ratings for which people did not
get promotion that is a no and this is a
rating for which people got promotion we
just plotted the data about whether a
person has got an employer has got
promotion or not yes no right so there
is nothing in between and what is the
employees rating okay and ratings can be
continuous that is not an issue but the
output is discrete in this case whether
employee got promotion yes no okay so if
we try to plot that and we try to find a
straight line this is how it would look
and as you can see it doesn't look very
right because looks like there will be
lot of errors thus root mean square
error if you remember for linear
regression would be very very high and
also the the values cannot go beyond
zero or beyond one so the graph should
probably look somewhat like this clipped
at zero and one but still the straight
line doesn't look right therefore
instead of using a linear equation we
need to come up with something different
and therefore the logistic regression
model looks somewhat like this so we
calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and
this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is one minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from 0 to
infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to 0 and when the probability
becomes 1 then the value of the odds is
1 by 0 that will be infinity but the
probability itself remains between 0 and
1. now this is how an equation of a
straight line looks so y is equal to
beta 0 plus beta 1 x where beta0 is the
y-intercept and beta1 is the slope of
the line if we take the odds equation
and take a log of both sides then this
would look somewhat like this and the
term logistic is actually derived from
the fact that we are doing this we take
a log of dx by 1 minus px this is an
extension of the calculation of odds
that we have seen right and that is
equal to beta0 plus beta1 x which is the
equation of the straight line and now
from here if you want to find out the
value of p x you will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of px like this px is equal
to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of minus
beta 0 plus beta 1 x and recall this is
nothing but the equation of the line
which is equal to y y is equal to beta 0
plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not is
going to be sunny or not but it's going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupiter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and there the image has a number
one two three four and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's take a
look at the code and see what we are
doing so i will not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images or a
sample of these images and
then we split the data into training and
test as i mentioned earlier
and we can do some exploratory analysis
and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we got we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right
so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 percent because the diagonals should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagnose the cells other than
the diagonals should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a two here there are there's
a one here but most of them are along
the diagonal this what does this mean
this means that the
number that has been fed is 0 and the
number that has been detected is also 0
so the predicted value and the actual
value are the same so along the
diagonals that is true which means that
let's let's take this diagonal right if
the maximum number is here that means
that like here in this case it is 34
which means that 34 of the images that
have been fed or rather actually there
are two misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four and out of which 34 have
been predicted correctly as number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight and another one has been predicted
as number nine so these are two
misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal model which has let's say
hundred percent accuracy everything will
be only in the diagonal there will be no
numbers other than zero in all other
cells so that is like a hundred percent
accurate model okay so that's uh just of
how to use this matrix uh how to use
this confusion matrix i know the name
is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix but actually it is not very
confusing it's very straightforward so
you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and the
predicted value and the actual value is
exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are i think 37 plus
five yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of digit 3 and
the accuracy is only 37 of them have
been accurately predicted three of them
have been predicted as number seven and
two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see how the code
looks so this is the code in
in jupiter notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code
then
here we will visualize the shape of
these digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
by 64. these are like 8x8 images so
that's that's what is reflected in this
shape now from here onwards we are
basically once again importing some of
the libraries that are required like
numpy and matplot and we will take a
look at uh some of the sample images
that we have unloaded so this one for
example creates a figure and then we go
ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at zero one two three four so this is
how the image is this is how the data is
okay and uh based on this we will
actually train our logistic regression
model and then we will test it and see
how well it is able to recognize so the
way it works is the pixel information so
as you can see here this is an 8 by 8
pixel kind of a
image and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn
for which a number what is the pattern
of the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training we split the data
into training and test so that the
training data set is used to train the
system so we pass this probably multiple
times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77. so when we say test size
as 20.23
that means 23 percent of that entire
data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is uh called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train and y underscore train
for the training data set and what is x
underscore train these are these are the
features right which is like the
independent variable and why underscore
train is the label right so in this case
what happens is we have the input value
which is or the features value which is
in x underscore train and since this is
the labeled data for each of them each
of the observations we already have the
label information saying whether this
digit is a zero or a one or a two so
that this this is what will be used for
comparison to find out whether the the
system is able to recognize it correctly
or there is an error for each
observation it will compare with this
right so this is the label so the same
way x underscore train y underscore
train is for the training data set x
underscore test y underscore test is for
the test data set okay so let me go
ahead and execute this code as well and
then we can go and check quickly what is
the how many entries are there and in
each of these so x underscore train the
shape is 13 83
by 64. and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape we see is four one
four so actually there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library and which is
a part of scikit learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line
is where we are passing
our data the training data set right
this is our the the predictors and
this is our target we are passing this
data set to train our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning
activities in machine learning projects
we spend a lot of time for the training
part of it okay so here the data set is
relatively small so it was pretty quick
so all right so now our model has been
trained using the training data set and
we want to see how accurate this is so
what we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for
a particular value new input you use the
predict method okay so let's run the
predict method and we pass this
particular image and
we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10
seems to be fine so let me just go ahead
and test the entire data set okay that's
basically what we will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentage of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 percent accurate okay so that's on
this part now what we can also do is we
can um also see this accuracy using what
is known as a confusion matrix so let us
go ahead and try that as well
so that we can also visualize how well
this model has
done so let me execute this piece of
code which will basically import some of
the libraries that are required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual values same as
the predicted value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is basically how
we read the confusion matrix now how do
we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so
on and divide that by the total number
of test observations that will give you
the percentage accuracy using a
confusion matrix now let us visualize
this confusion matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way uh using a heat map so
we will create a heat map with some
we'll add some colors as well it's uh
it's like a more visually visually more
appealing so that's the whole idea so if
we let me run this piece of code and
this is how the heat map looks
and as you can see here the diagonals
again are all the values are here most
of the values so which means reasonably
this seems to be reasonably accurate and
yeah basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as i
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test values or the
total number of observations in test
data set okay so this is the confusion
matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we we picked up randomly a few of them
so this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero actual
value is of course zero
then this is the image of nine
so this has also been predicted
correctly nine and actual value is nine
and this is the image of one and again
this has been predicted correctly as
like the actual value okay so this was a
quick demo of logistic regression how to
use logistic regression to identify
images
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in
deep decision tree is a tree shape
diagram used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
current or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is the diameter greater than two if
false is going to be a what looks to be
a red chili and if it's true it's going
to be a bell pepper from the capsicum
family so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
and the different parts we're going to
be using we'll start with entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
ten and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went
into the different parts of our tree and
they call the leaf node leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision so it's the final end at the
bottom the decision node has two or more
branches this is where we're breaking
the group up into different parts and
finally you have the root node the
topmost decision note is known as the
root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals all get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with the gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base two of
the same the percentage of that animal
let's try to calculate the entropy for
the current data set and take a look at
what that looks like and don't be afraid
of the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gather and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case it says yellow fence two over
eight two elephants over a total of
eight times log base two two over eight
plus one monkey over total of eight log
base two one over eight and plus two
over eight of the tigers log base 2 over
8. and if we plug that into our computer
or calculator i obviously can't do logs
in my head we get an entropy equal to
0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we'll
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human is probably pretty
easy to split it let's see if you're
right if you guessed the color yellow
you're correct let's say the condition
that gives us the maximum gain is yellow
so we will split the data based on the
color yellow if it's true that group of
animals goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has to decreased
considerably however we still need some
splitting of both the branches to attain
an entropy value equal to zero so we
decided to split both the nodes using
height as the condition since every
branch now contains single label type we
can say that entropy in this case has
reached the least value and here you see
we have the giraffes the tigers the
monkey and the elephants all separated
into their own groups this tree can now
predict all the classes of animals
present in the data set with a hundred
percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to be pay their loan or
not for this bank and from that we want
to generate a problem statement to
predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing i need is
i need something to edit my python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
i'm using the anaconda jupiter notebook
now you can use any python ide you like
to run it in but i find the jupyter
notebook is really nice for doing things
on the fly and let's go ahead and just
paste that code in the beginning and
before we start let's talk a little bit
about what we're bringing in and then
we're going to do a couple things in
here we have to make a couple changes as
we go through this first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as np that's very standard when
we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
numbers it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn import tree and that's just
the basic tree function is needed for
the decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name
and you'll see it's on my c drive and
this is very lengthy setup on here where
i stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below
and request it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have
sklearn.cross validation and if you
research this and go to the sklearn site
you'll find out that you can actually
just swap it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score house
number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head
this is one of the nice things when we
did the uh balance data from the panda
read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas
module for head another beautiful thing
in the data set that we can utilize so
let's put that on our sheet here and we
have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
panda's print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas do such a wonderful job of making
this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet or open office cal or trying
to look at a word doc where it's all
scrunched together and hard to read you
can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to
train and build our data tree and to do
that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at its source and
target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember i always start with zero zero
is a yes or no and that's whether the
loan went default or not so we want to
start with one if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so it's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x-trade or the y-train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropical decision tree classifier
it automatically prints out what's in
that decision tree there's a lot of
variables you can play with in here and
it's quite beyond the scope of this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of three now the max depth
if you remember above when we were doing
the different graphs of animals means
it's only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves is five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so i'll have at least three splits i'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom
now that we've created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that their different tools have the
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use and
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not in this case though we
need to test out the data and just see
how good our sample is how good of our
tree does at predicting the loan
payments and finally since anaconda
jupiter notebook works as a command line
for python we can simply put the y
predict e in to print it i could just as
easily have put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 of a thousand so you
should have about 300 answers in here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our why predict came
out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from that's coming from here down
here from sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit's going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not so why random forest it's
always important to understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with
the random forest the first one is
there's no overfitting if you use of
multiple trees reduce the risk of
overfitting training time is less
overfitting means that we have fit the
data so close to what we have as our
sample that we pick up on all the weird
parts and instead of predicting the
overall data you're predicting the weird
stuff which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area
and they took a slightly different set
of statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works
and let's look at what is a random
forest random forest or random decision
forest is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as a final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switched from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well it goes hmm
orange or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy
everything on the decision tree and how
it makes the decision is based on
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever's coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set 1 and a data set 2 we just
split it in two and if you look at these
new
data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less
so for the first one
whatever comes in there it's going to
sort that data and it's going to say
okay if this data goes this direction
it's probably an apple and if it goes
into the other direction it's probably a
lemon so that brings us up to
information gain it is the measure of
decrease in the entropy after the data
set is split what that means in here is
that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals
decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision we should
have a name for the nodes above it and
they call those decision nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this bowl was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dre a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple we
have a diameter
three three one three three one and we
have a label apple lemon grapes apple
lemon grapes and how do we split the
data we have to frame the conditions to
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest
it's very key to note that we're looking
for the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty high
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl full of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of 0
as you can see there's only one kind of
label left for this branch so no further
splitting is required for this node
however this node on the right is still
requires a split to decrease the entropy
further so we split the right node
further based on color if you look at
this if i split it on color that pretty
much cuts it right down the middle it's
the only thing we have left in our
choices of color and diameter too and if
the color is yellow it's going to go to
the right bowl and if it's false it's
going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with a hundred percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy along with our grapes up
there so we've looked at kind of a basic
tree
in our forest but what we really want to
know is how does a random forest work as
a whole so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
gonna start with the first tree that
looks like this
just like we did in the example this
tree looks at the diameter if it's
greater than or equal to three it's true
otherwise it's false so one side goes to
the smaller diameter one side goes to
larger diameter and if the color is
orange it's going to go to the right
true we're using oranges now instead of
lemons and if it's red it's going to go
to the left false we build a second tree
very similar but split differently
instead of the first one being split by
a diameter this one when they created it
if you look at that first bowl it has a
lot of red objects so it says is the
color red because that's going to bring
our entropy down the fastest and so of
course if it's true it goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right and
then it looks at the shape false or true
and so on and so on and tree three is
the diameter equal to one and it came up
with this because there's a lot of
cherries in this bowl so that would be
the biggest split on there is is the
diameter equal to one that's going to
drop the entropy the quickest and as you
can see it splits it into true if it
goes false and they've added another
category does it grow in the summer and
if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees so you can see
them all in one image so this would be
three completely different trees
categorizing a fruit and let's take a
fruit now let's try this and this fruit
if you look at it we've blackened it out
you can't see the color on it so it's
missing data remember one of the things
we talked about earlier is that a random
forest works really good if you're
missing data if you're missing pieces so
this fruit has an image but maybe the
person had a black and white camera when
they took the picture and we're going to
take a look at this and it's going to
have they put the color in there so
ignore the color down there but the
diameter equals three we find out it
grows in the summer equals yes and the
shape is a circle and if you go to the
right you can look at what one of the
decision trees did this is the third one
is a diameter greater than equal to
three is the color orange well it
doesn't really know on this one but if
you look at the value and say true and
you go to the right tree two classifies
it as cherries is the color equal red
is the shape of circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry when
you add that all together the majority
of the vote says orange so the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it i don't know about
you but i'm getting tired of fruit so
let's switch and i did promise you we'd
start looking at a case example and get
into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coating we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupyter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn.ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the
other modules that we bring in and one
is going to be pandas we're going to
import pandas as pd pd is a common term
used for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us
where when you create a pandas data
frame it looks like an excel spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code panda
is just wonderful because it plays nice
with all the other modules in there and
then we have numpy which is our numbers
python and the numbers python allows us
to do different mathematical sets on
here we'll see right off the bat we're
going to take our np and we're going to
go ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupiter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the imports
and i'm going to paste the code down
here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet and in this excel
spreadsheet we have set the columns so
up on the top you can see the four
different columns and then we have the
data iris.data down below it's a little
confusing without knowing where this
data is coming from so let's look at the
bigger picture and i'm going to go print
i'm just going to change this for a
moment and we're going to print all of
iris and see what that looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary
you'll have a key
or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it so
feature names which we actually used
over here under columns is equal to an
array of sepal length steeple width
petal length pedal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns and if you scroll down
far enough you'll also see data down
here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head it'll print the
first five lines of the dataset in there
along with the headers if you have it in
this case we have the column header set
to iris features and in here you'll see
that we have zero one two three four in
python most arrays always start at zero
so when you look at the first five it's
going to be zero one two three four not
one two three four five so now we've got
our iris data imported into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code
we're gonna take a look at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupyter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here and
before i run it
i want to look at a couple things going
on so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target
now these are both in the pandas setup
on here so in pandas we can do either
one i could have just as easily done
iris and then in brackets target
depending on what i'm working on both
are acceptable let's go ahead and run
this code and see how this changes and
what we've done is we've added the
target from the iris data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're going to add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you that where you
where that's different where you can
alter that and do it slightly
differently but let's go ahead and put
this into our script up to that now and
here we go we're going to put that down
here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy
numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1 and we're going to do it
for each of the rows that's where the
length df comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved and we're
going to use that to train it and then
the other 25 we're going to hold off to
the side and use that to test it later
on so let's flip back on over and see
what the next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test 75 and train 25
percent in test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
original data frame with the iris data
in it
and if df is train equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width pedal
length and pedal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter
and this is one of the fun thing about
jupiter notebooks is i'm just building
the code as we go and then we need to go
ahead and create the labels for the
other part so let's take a look and see
what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead and convert the species on
here into something the computer
understands so let's put this code into
our script and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd dot factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what's factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has satoshi satoshi satosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and vera color
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end
and then species is just that column
factorize goes in there looks at the
fact that there's only three of them so
when i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
0 is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is the
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and it printed out y instead of print
y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these different meanings of
all these different settings on here
some of them are self-explanatory if you
kind of think about it a little bit like
max features as auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we had the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this we're looking at a
lot of stuff here so you might have in
this case there's probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf nodes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is limiting the process and
making sure we don't overwhelm a system
and there's some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false warm start
is if you're programming it one piece at
a time externally since we're not we're
not going to have like we're not going
to continually train this particular
learning tree and again like i said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the sk learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit our train our features and our
target y so now we have our training
model
what's next if we're going to create a
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length simple width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here so you can
see what features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2 and we're going to
put those in and we're going to predict
what our
new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts 0 0 0 1 2 1 1 2 2 2 and and
again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf.predict
probability so we're running it just
like we ran it up here but this time
with this we're going to get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here that this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a 1 for setosa it predicts a
0 for virginica and it predicts a 0 for
versa color and so on and so on and so
on and let's um you know what i'm going
to change this just a little bit let's
look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says uh setosa
gets zero votes virginica gets point
five votes versus color gets point five
votes but let's just go with the
virginica since these two are equal and
so on and so on down the list you can
see how they vary on here so now we've
looked at both how to do a basic predict
of the features and we've looked at the
predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and
if you remember correctly this was the
the names that we've been talking about
this whole time the setosa virginica
versus color and then we're going to go
ahead and do the prediction again we've
run that we could have just set a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we're going
to run it again
dot predict test features remember that
returns the zeros the ones and the twos
and then we're going to set that equal
to predictions so this time we're
actually putting it in a variable and
when i run this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versa color
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together
the first one is our predictions and i
went ahead and did uh predictions
through 25. let's just do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species i remember i could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says setosa satoshi satosa
setosa and they match
so the first one is what our
forest is doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm gonna because i'm on the
jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're going to create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas and
we're doing a cross tab this function
takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
percent accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting before we wrap it up so let's
flip back on over to my script in here
we're going to take this line of code
from up above i don't know if you
remember it but predix equals the iris
dot target underscore names so we're
going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
last week my son and i visited a fruit
shop dad is that an apple or a
strawberry so the question comes up what
fruit do they just pick up from the
fruit stand after a couple of seconds
you could figure out that it was a
strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh why not build
a model which can predict an unknown
data and in this we're going to be
looking at some sweet strawberries or
crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and already labeled as such
we already have a bunch of apples we
know our apples and are labeled as such
then once we train our model that model
then can be given the new data and the
new data is this image in this case you
can see a question mark on it and it
comes through and goes it's a strawberry
in this case we're using the support
vector machine model svm is a supervised
learning method that looks at data and
sorts it into one of two categories and
in this case we're sorting the
strawberry into the strawberry site at
this point you should be asking the
question how does the prediction work
before we dig into an example with
numbers let's apply this to our fruit
scenario we have our support vector
machine we've taken it and we've taken
labeled sample of data strawberries and
apples and we draw on a line down the
middle between the two groups this split
now allows us to take new data in this
case an apple and a strawberry and place
them in the appropriate group based on
which side of the line they fall in and
that way we can predict the unknown as
colorful and tasty as the fruit example
is let's take a look at another example
with some numbers involved and we can
take a closer look at how the math works
in this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set a female where
you have their height and weight 174 65
174 88 and so on and we'll need a sample
data set of the male they have a height
179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's go
ahead and put this on a graph so we have
a nice visual so you can see here we
have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we draw on two lines through the data in
the middle that separates them in from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as possible in technical terms we
can say the distance between the support
vector and the hyperplane should be as
far as possible and this is where the
support vectors are the extreme points
in the data set and if you look at this
data set they have circled two points
which seem to be right on the outskirts
of the woman and one on the outskirts of
the men and hyperplane has a maximum
distance to the support vectors of any
class now you'll see the line down the
middle and we call this the hyperplane
because when you're dealing with
multiple dimensions it's really not just
a line but a plane of intersections and
you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest negative point
which is on the women's side the sum of
d plus and d minus is called the
distance margin or the distance between
the two support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender hopefully that's clear how
that works on a visual level as a data
scientist you should also be asking what
happens if the hyperplane is not optimal
if we select a hyperplane having low
margin then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called referred to as the ls vm so
far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a 1d view of the data to
a two-dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1d input and
transfer it to a 2-dimensional output as
you can see in this picture here the 1d
when transferred to a 2-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets what if we
make it even more complicated how do we
perform an svm for this type of data set
here you can see we have a two
dimensional data set where the data is
in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
both algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and documents so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be over fitted to
a very specific instance or it's going
to be biased to a high or low value with
the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms these three
advantages of the support vector machine
make it a very powerful tool to add to
your repertoire of machine learning
tools now we did promise you a used case
study we're actually going to dive into
some python programming and so we're
going to go into a problem statement and
start off with the zoo so in the zoo
example we have family members going to
the zoo we have the young child going
dead is that a group of crocodiles or
alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work especially
as a young child and so we can see the
parents sitting here thinking well what
is the difference between a crocodile
and an alligator well one crocodiles are
larger in size alligators are smaller in
size snout width the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout and of course in the modern day
and age the father is hitting here
thinking how can i turn this into a
lesson for my son and he goes let a
support vector machine segregate the two
groups i don't know if my dad ever told
me that but that would be funny now in
this example we're not going to use
actual measurements and data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up but let's
roll up our sleeves and we'll talk about
that more in just a moment as we break
into our python script so here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into a python editor in just a
moment but let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover first we're
going to cover in the code the setup how
to actually create our svm and you're
going to find that there's only two
lines of code that actually create it
and the rest of it is done so quick and
fast that it's all here in the first
page and we'll show you what that looks
like as far as our data cause we're
going to create some data i talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blobs and we'll go through that
in just a second and then the second
part is we're going to take this and
we're going to bump it up a notch we're
going to show you what it looks like
behind the scenes but let's start with
actually creating our setup i like to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook
because it's very easy to use but you
can use any of your favorite python
editors or setups and go in there but
let's go ahead and switch over there and
see what that looks like so here we are
in the anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupiter notebook with python
we're using python 3. i believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and
you'd have to look at the sklearn and
make sure if you're using a 2x version
an earlier version let's go and put our
code in there and one of the things i
like about the jupiter notebook is i go
up to view and i'm going to go ahead and
toggle the line numbers on to make it a
little bit easier to talk about and we
can even increase the size because this
is edited in this case i'm using google
chrome explorer and that's how it opens
up for the editor although anyone any
like i said any editor will work now the
first step is going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as np and matplot library dot pi plot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python we need that
because part of the platform we're using
uses that for the numpy array and i'll
talk about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus the standard python array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use np for numpy the map plot library
is how we're going to view our data so
this has uh you do need the np for the
sk learn module but the map plot library
is purely for our use for visualization
and so you really don't need that for
the svm but we're gonna put it there so
you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at and
then finally we're gonna i'm gonna jump
one ahead to line number four that's the
sklearn.datasets.samplesgenerator
import make blobs and i told you that we
were going to make up data and this is a
tool that's in the sk learning to makeup
data i personally don't want to go to
the zoo get in trouble for jumping over
the fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as i work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your
setup and you're not sure about what
data you're going to put in there you
can create this blob and it makes it
real easy to use and finally we have our
actual svm the sk learn import svm on
line three so that covers all our
imports we're going to create remember i
used to make blobs to create data and
we're going to create a capital x and a
lowercase y equals make blobs in samples
equals 40. so we're going to make 40
lines of data it's going to have two
centers with a random state equals 20.
so each
each group is going to have 20 different
pieces of data in it and the way that
looks is that we'll have under x
an x y plane so i have two numbers under
x and y will be 0 1 that's the two
different centers so we have yes or no
in this case alligator or crocodile
that's what that represents and then i
told you that the actual sk learner the
svm is in two lines of code and we see
it right here with clf equals svm dot
svc kernel equals linear and i set sql
to one although in this example since we
are not uh regularizing the data because
we want to be very clear and easy to see
i went ahead you can set it to a
thousand a lot of times when you're not
doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
it'll be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit x comma y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and i'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish on the other side
that's our two sets of data they
represent one represents crocodiles and
one represents alligators and then we
have our measurements in this case we
have like the width and length of the
snout and i did say i was going to come
up here and talk just a little bit about
our plot and you'll see plt that's what
we imported we're going to do a scatter
plot that means we're just putting dots
on there and then look at this notation
i have the capital x and then in
brackets i have a colon comma 0. that's
from numpy if you did that in a regular
array you'll get an error in a python
array you have to have that in a numpy
array it turns out that our make blobs
returns a numpy array and this notation
is great because what it means is the
first part is the colon means we're
going to do all the rows that's all the
data in our blob we created under
capital x and then the second part has a
comma 0. we're only going to take the
first value and then if you notice we do
the same thing but we're going to take
the second value remember we always
start with zero and then one so we have
column zero and column one and you can
look at this as our x y plots the first
one is the x plot and the second one is
the y plot so the first one is on the
bottom 0 2 4 6 8 and 10 and then the
second one x of the one is the 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 going up the left hand side s
equals 30 is just the size of the dot so
we can see them it says real tiny dots
and then c map equals plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
fit was done in two lines of code a lot
of times there'll be a third line where
we regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case i'm giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width and length 5 6
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets and then i have the brackets
inside and the reason i do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case i'm processing two lines and
then i'm just going to print and you'll
see clf dot predict new data so the clf
and the dot predict part is going to
give us an answer and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see 0 1 so
predicted the first one the 3 4 is going
to be on the one side and the 5 6 is
going to be on the other side so one
came out as an alligator and one came
out as a crocodile now that's pretty
short explanation for the setup but
really we want to dug in and see what
it's going on behind the scenes and
let's see what that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
and we did actually generating the
original model and you'll see here that
we go through a few steps and i'll move
this over to our editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid that and
show you how not to redo that and then
we're going to go in there and add in
those lines we're going to see what
those lines look like and how to set
those up and finally we're going to plot
all that on here and show it and you'll
get a nice graph with the what we saw
earlier when we were going through the
theory behind this where it shows the
support vectors and the hyperplane and
those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 it has plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and i'm
going to paste that code in and you'll
see that the plot show has moved down
below let's scroll up a little bit and
if you look at the top here of our new
section 1 2 3
and four is the same code we had before
and let's go back up here and take a
look at that we're gonna fit the values
on our svm and then we're gonna plot
scatter it and then we're gonna do a
plot show so you should be asking why
are we redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here okay so this is how we
display a nice graph with our results in
our data ax is very standard used
variable when you talk about plt and
it's just setting it to that axis the
last axis in the plt they can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable xx equal
to np.line space x limit 0 x limit 1
comma 30 and we've done the same thing
for the y space and then we're going to
go in here and we create a mesh grid and
this is a numpy command so we're back to
our numbers python let's go through what
these numpy commands mean with the line
space and the mesh grid we've taken x x
small s x x equals np line space and we
have our x limit 0 and our x limit 1 and
we're going to create 30 points on it
and we're going to do the same thing for
the y axis now this has nothing to do
with our evaluation it's all we're doing
is we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between 0
and the x limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the y and then
the mesh grid loops those all together
so it forms a nice grid so if we were
going to do this say between the limit 0
and 10 and do 10 points we would have a
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on
you can just imagine a point at each
corner one of those boxes and the mesh
grid combines them all so we take the y
y and the x x we created and creates the
full grid and we've set that grid into
the y y coordinates and the x x
coordinates now remember we're working
with numbi and python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being x comma 1 you know x comma y
and then x 2 comma y 2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital y y and a
column of x's capital x x with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array x y array now that we've
created the stack of data points we're
going to do something interesting here
we're going to create a value z and the
z equals the clf that's our that's our
support vector machine we created and
we've already trained and we have a dot
decision function and we're going to put
the x y in there so here we have all
this data we're going to put that x y in
there that data and we're going to
reshape it and you'll see that we have
the x x dot shape in here this literally
takes the xx resets it up connected to
the y and the z value lets us know
whether it is the left hand side is
going to generate three different values
the z value does and it'll tell us
whether that data is a support vector to
the left the hyperplane in the middle or
the support vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so it's
900 points of data and we separated
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot library we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
contour capital xx capital yy these have
been reshaped to fit those lines z is
the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have three levels of data
the alphas just makes it kind of
see-through so it's only 0.5 of the
value in there so when we graph it the
data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line styles this is where we set the two
support vectors to be dash dash lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does and
then finally we take our ax dot scatter
we're going to go ahead and plot the
support vectors but we've programmed it
in there so that they look nice like the
dash dash line and the dashed line on
that grid and you can see here when we
do the clf dot support vectors we are
looking at column zero and column one
and then again we have the s equals one
hundred so we're gonna make them larger
and the line width equals one face
colors equals none let's take a look and
see what that looks like when we show it
and you can see we get down to our end
result it creates a really nice graph we
have our two support vectors and dashed
lines and they have the near data so you
can see those two points or in this case
the four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth today we're
going to cover the k nearest neighbors
like referred to as k n n and k n is
really a fundamental place to start in
the machine learning it's the basis of a
lot of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work
and then we'll dive in to my favorite
part the use case predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not that is
a very common and popular used data set
as far as testing out models and
learning how to use the different models
in machine learning by now we all know
machine learning models make predictions
by learning from the past data available
so we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there watching the black cat cross their
path no deer you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller lengths of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and goes
in the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5.
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red
so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to three we're going to
look at the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals a 7 we classify as a
triangle depending on what the other
data is around and you can see as the k
changes depending on where that point is
that drastically changes your answer and
we jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get it's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of
knn the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using like in this
case squares and triangles if it's even
you want to make your k value odd that
helps it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use knn when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in this says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13 and distance 3 is
about 13.4 similarly we will calculate
the euclidean distance of unknown data
point from all the points in the data
set and because we're dealing with small
amount of data that's not that hard to
do it's actually pretty quick for a
computer and it's not a really
complicated mass you can just see how
close is the data based on the euclidean
distance hence we have calculated the
euclidean distance of unknown data point
from all the points as shown where x1
and y1 equal 57 and 170 whose class we
have to classify so now we're looking at
that we're saying well here's the
euclidean distance who's going to be
their closest neighbors now let's
calculate the nearest neighbor at k
equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what we're just voting normal
normal normal three votes for normal
this is going to be a normal weight so
majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hence as per k and n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knn positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the knn
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly you can use any particular
editor for python but i like to use for
doing uh very basic visual stuff the
anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the anaconda navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home i
can choose my application we're going to
be using python36 i have a couple
different versions on this particular
machine if i go under environments i can
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where i can install
different packages so if i click on that
button and open the terminal i can use a
simple pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case it's going
to open up chrome because that's my
default that i use and since the script
is pre-done you'll see have a number of
windows open up at the top the one we're
working in and since we're working on
the k n predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not let's go and put
that title in there
and i'm also going to go up here and
click on cell actually we want to go
ahead and first insert a cell below and
then i'm going to go back up to the top
cell and i'm going to change the cell
type to markdown that means this is not
going to run as python it's a markdown
language so if i run this first one it
comes up in nice big letters which is
kind of nice remind us what we're
working on and by now you should be
familiar with doing all of our imports
we're going to import the pandas as pd
import numpy is np pandas is the pandas
data frame and numpy is a number array
very powerful tools to use in here so we
have our imports so we've brought in our
pandas our numpy our two general python
tools and then you can see over here we
have our train test split by now you
should be familiar with splitting the
data we want to split part of it for
training our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take can get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between -1 and 1. and then the
actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sklearn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set in
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead
and do it as a data set column equals
dataset column.replace this is this is
still pandas you can do a direct there's
also one that's that you look for your
nan a lot of different options in here
but the nan in numpy n a n is what that
stands for is none it doesn't exist so
the first thing we're doing here is
we're replacing the zero with a numpy
none there's no data there that's what
that says that's what this is saying
right here so put the zero in and we're
going to play zeros with no data so if
it's a zero that means the person's well
hopefully not dead hope they just didn't
get the data the next thing we want to
do is we're going to create the mean
which is the integer from the data set
from the column dot mean where we skip n
a's we can do that that is a pandas
command there the skip n a so we're
going to figure out the mean of that
data set and then we're going to take
that data set column and we're going to
replace all the npna in with the means
why did we do that we could have
actually just taken this step and gone
right down here and just replaced zero
and skip anything were except you could
actually there's a way to skip zeros and
then just replace all the zeros but in
this case we want to go ahead and do it
this way so you could see that we're
switching this to a non-existent value
then we're going to create the mean well
this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
the printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see it skipped a bunch
in the middle that's what it does if you
have too many lines in jupiter notebook
it'll skip a few and go on to the next
in a data set let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
off the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we put it in
here is outcome well that's not part of
the training data that's part of the
answer yes column nine but it's listed
as eight number eight so zero to eight
is nine columns so uh eight is the value
and when you see it in here zero this is
actually zero to seven it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split
that's part of the sklearn right there
and we simply put in our x and our y
we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you see that i'd
have to look that up and then the test
size test size is 0.2 that simply means
we're going to take 20 percent of the
data and put it aside so that we can
test it later that's all that is and
again we're going to run it not very
exciting so far we haven't had any print
out other than to look at the data but
that is a lot of this is prepping this
data once you prep it the actual lines
of code are quick and easy and we're
almost there with the actual writing of
our knn we need to go ahead and do a
scale the data if you remember correctly
we're fitting the data in a standard
scalar which means instead of the data
being from you know 5 to 303 in one
column and the next column is 1 to 6.
we're going to set that all so that all
the data is between -1 and 1. that's
what that standard scalar does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scalar with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the x
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scalar we're going
to call it sc underscore x for the
scalar and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our x train equals sc underscore x
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x train variable and then
our x test we're also going to transform
it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to run this
if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key
columns that shouldn't be zero and we
replace that with the means
of those columns
that way that they fit right in with our
data models we've come down here we
split the data so now we have our test
data and our training data and then
we've taken and we scaled the data so
all of our data going in no no we don't
tr we don't train the y part the y train
and y test that never has to be trained
it's only the data going in that's what
we want to train in there then define
the model using k neighbors classifier
and fit the train data in the model so
we do all that data prep and you can see
down here we're only going to have a
couple lines of code where we're
actually building our model and training
it that's one of the cool things about
python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do
y we want let's just do length of y
and we get 768 and if we import math we
do math dot square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11.
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix why
test y predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the y predicted which would be
your title up here you could do uh let's
just do p-r-e-d
predict it across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32 this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here in the column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero has a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct
but our prediction said another 15 out
of that 15 it classified as incorrect so
you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion matrix then we're going to go
ahead and print the f1 score let me just
run that and you see we get a 0.69 in
our f1 score
the f1 takes into account both sides of
the balance of false positives where if
we go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent tells us it is a pretty fair fit
in the model what is k-means clustering
k-means clustering is an unsupervised
learning algorithm in this case you
don't have labeled data unlike in
supervised learning so you have a set of
data and you want to group them and as
the name suggests you want to put them
into clusters which means objects that
are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if k
is equal to two there will be two
clusters if k is equal to three three
clusters and so on and so forth that's
what the k stands for and of course
there is a way of finding out what is
the best or optimum value of k for a
given data we will look at that so that
is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about
the runs scored by the people ordered by
the player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and boilers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is so there are information there
is information on the y-axis about the
run score and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to 2 and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from the centroid and the
distance from this center right this
point is taken and the distance is found
from this centroid and the center and so
on and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids
and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine
the central point or the actual centroid
for these two clusters so we have this
one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point of the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of this new clusters
and this process is actually repeated
now what might happen is some of these
points may get reallocated in our
example that is not happening probably
but it may so happen that the distance
is found between each of these data
points once again with these centroids
and if there is if it is required some
points may be reallocated we will see
that in a later example but for now we
will keep it simple
so this process is continued till the
centroid repositioning stops and that is
our final cluster so this is our so
after iteration we come to this position
this situation where the centroid
doesn't need any more repositioning and
that means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is repeated the process of calculating
the distance and repositioning the
centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that the
algorithm has converged and we have the
final cluster with the data points and
the centroids so this is what you're
going to learn from this session we will
talk about the types of clustering what
is k-means clustering application of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
done using distance measure so we will
talk about the common distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
the glomerative clustering is a
bottom-up approach we begin with each
element as a separate cluster and merge
them into successively larger clusters
so for example we have a b c def we
start by combining b and c from one
cluster d and e form one more then we
combine d e and f one more bigger
cluster and then add bc to that and then
finally a to it compared to that
divisive clustering or divisive
clustering is a top down approach we
begin with the whole set and proceed to
divide it into successively smaller
clusters so we have abcdef we first take
that as a single cluster and then break
it down
into a b c d
e f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k-means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics are compared and all
objects having similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done we will see it
in more detail as we move forward and
fuzzy c means is very similar to k means
in the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c-mails
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
systems search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance so
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells
how similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have square
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure it's nothing but the
square of the euclidean distance as the
name suggests so instead of taking the
square root
we leave the square as it is and then we
have manhattan distance measure in case
of manhattan distance it is the sum of
the distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this
we can do by trial and error so we
specify a certain number maybe k is
equal to 3 or 4 or 5 to start with and
then as we progress we keep changing
until we get the best clusters or there
is a technique called elbow technique
whereby we can determine the value of k
what should be the best value of k how
many clusters should be formed so once
we have the value of k we specify that
and then the system will assign that
many centroids so it picks randomly that
to start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position
the position of the centroid moves
compared to the randomly allocated one
so it's an iterative process once again
the distance of each point is measured
from this new centroid point and if
required the data points are reallocated
to the new centroids and the mean
position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across
so how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss that is taken as the optimum
value of k so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y-axis
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x-axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to 1 which means all the
data points are in a single cluster the
within s value will be very high because
they are probably scattered all over the
moment you split it into two there will
be a drastic fall in the within ss value
that's what is represented here
but then as the value of k increases the
decrease the rate of decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of k
should be
either two or three or at the most four
but beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned
or repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
this new position and c1 is in this new
position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is
the repetitive process iterative process
and if the centroid doesn't change once
the centroid stops changing that means
the algorithm has converged and this is
our final cluster with this as the
centroid c1 and c2 as the centroids
these data points as a part of each
cluster so i hope this helps in
understanding the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroid c1 c2
c3 to ck and find which is the lowest
distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of this newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two
and three so we again calculate the
distance of x1
from the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence
so let's take a detailed look at each of
these steps so we randomly pick k
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two
we now have all the points all the data
points
grouped into k groups because we we
wanted to create k clusters right so we
have k groups each one may be having a
certain number of input values and they
need not be equally distributed by the
way based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step 3
we actually calculate the centroid of
each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the
new centroids so as i said earlier there
may be a reallocation so we now have a
new set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in python notebook
using pattern notebook but before that
let's find out what's the problem that
we are trying to solve the problem
statement is let's say walmart wants to
open a chain of stores across the state
of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity's sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual k-means clustering
process
so we will assign
each of these points to the centroids
and then check whether they are the
optimal distance which is the shortest
distance and assign each of the points
data points to the centroids and then go
through this iterative process till the
whole process converges and finally we
get an output like this so we have four
distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and
the centroids are
like the location where the store should
be the optimum location where the store
should be so that's the way we
determine the best locations for the
store and that's how we can help walmart
find the best locations for their stores
in florida so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are running
running the code
live all right so this is the code for
k-means clustering in jupyter notebook
we have a few examples here which we
will demonstrate how k-means clustering
is used and even there is a small
implementation of k-means clustering as
well okay so let's get started okay so
this block is basically importing the
various libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit-learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify how many clusters we want
so centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us and this is how it
looks as you can see visually also we
can figure out that there are four
distinct classes or clusters in this
data set and that is what make blobs
actually
provides
now from here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then we create an
instance of k-means and we specify
the value of k this n underscore
clusters is the value of k remember k
means in k means k is basically the
number of clusters that you want to
create and it is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as
with any other machine learning
functionality fit is what we use the
function or the method rather fit is
what we use to
train the model here there is no real
training kind of thing but that's the
call okay so we are calling fit and what
we are doing here we are just passing
the data so x has these values the data
that has been created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster 1
this is 2 3 and so on or i will actually
start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and 3 maybe
and then for each of the observations it
will assign based on which cluster it
belongs to it will assign a value so
that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have how many about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here each
of them the cluster number is given and
the cluster number goes from 0 to 3. so
there are four clusters so the numbers
go from 0 1 2 3. so that's what is seen
here okay now so this was a quick
example of generating some dummy data
and then clustering that okay and this
can be applied if you have proper data
you can just load it up into x for
example here and then run the game so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code uh at each step what it is doing
and then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k-means clustering can
be used in maybe some real life examples
real life use cases all right so in this
case here what we are doing is basically
implementing the k means clustering and
there is a function or a library
calculates for a given two pairs of
points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid
is the closest and accordingly we assign
that data
or the data point to that particular
centroid or cluster and once that is
done for all the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position which is the
center position right so we calculate
the new centroid and then we check if
the new centroid is the coordinates or
the position is the same as the previous
centroid
the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case
also with that is actually convergence
right so for example the change is
0.0001 we can consider that as
convergence otherwise what will happen
is this will either take forever or it
will be never ending so that's a small
flaw here so that is something
additional checks may have to be added
here but again as mentioned this is not
the most sophisticated implementation uh
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
okay so if we execute this code this is
what we get as the output so this is the
definition of this particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data x and the
number of clusters which is four
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of an implementation of k-means
clustering
and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how
k-means clustering is used in maybe some
real-life scenarios or use cases in the
next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory uh so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and then we
will flatten it so the reshaping is
basically we have the image information
is stored in the form of pixels and if
the image is like for example 427 by 640
and it has three colors so that's the
overall dimension of the of the initial
image we just reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm
and this will then create clusters of
only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors and now we
need to bring it down to 16 colors so we
use k is equal to 16. and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to a 16 color so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is a
the new image looks as you can see there
is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though the image quality is definitely
reduced a little bit
so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node and once again as always we
will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let me load that
and this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and
this is the shape of this image which is
basically what is the shape is nothing
but the overall size right so this is
427 pixel by 640 pixel and then there
are three layers which is this three
basically is for rgb which is red green
blue so color image will have that right
so that is the shape of this now what we
need to do is data let's take a look at
how data is looking so let me just
create a new cell and show you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix and
each one has about four for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are large the numbers are a large so we
need to normalize them to between zero
and one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between 0 and 1 and the way to do that
is divide by 255 so we divide china by
255 and we get the new values in data so
let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
and let me just insert
uh probably a cell here and take a look
at how data is looking all right so this
is how data is looking and now you see
this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between zero and one
this is one of the things we need to do
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are these this is
how the 16 colors
would look so this is red against green
and this is red against blue there is uh
quite a bit of similarity between this
original color schema and the new one
right so it doesn't look very very
completely different or anything like
that now we apply this the newly created
colors to the image and we can take a
look how this is looking now we can
compare both the images so this is our
original image and this is our new image
so as you can see there is not a lot of
information
that has been lost it pretty much looks
like the original image yes we can see
that for example here there is a little
bit uh it appears a little dullish
compared to this one right because we
kind of took off some of the finer
details of the color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k-means clustering and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16
and then we render the image once again
and we will see that the color the
quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so this is
the image now once again we can take a
look at the shape which is 427 by 640 by
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will
also bring this as you can see the
numbers are much big so we will much
bigger so we will now have to
scale them down to values between 0 and
1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
those the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and
now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see
this looks much richer in color but at
the same time and this probably doesn't
have as we can see it doesn't look as
rich as this one but nevertheless the
information is not lost the shape and
all that stuff and this can be also
rendered on a slightly a device which is
probably
not that sophisticated okay so that's
pretty much it so we have seen two
examples of how color compression can be
done
using k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using
blob to just execute the k-means
clustering hey everyone welcome to this
live session by simply learn in today's
session we will take you through the
most debated topic that has taken the
world by storm yes you guessed it right
we are talking about coronavirus but
before we proceed make sure to subscribe
to our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update in this session we
will learn about what coronavirus really
is how did it emerge and what are its
symptoms then we will see what has been
its impact so far in terms of the total
cases emerging the total number of
deaths reported and the total number of
recoveries across the globe we will
analyze the outbreak of coronavirus
across different regions visualize them
using charts and graphs and predict the
number of upcoming confirmed cases for
the next 10 days that is between the
16th of march to the 25th of march using
linear regression model and support
vector machines in python finally we
look at the various safety measures that
you can take to save yourself from
getting attacked by coronavirus
before we begin let me clarify that this
video majorly focuses on how you can use
machine learning algorithms to make
predictions on such sensitive issues we
will certainly cover the current
scenario and the impact it has created
worldwide but there is nothing to panic
at all make sure you take all the
necessary precautions to stay safe also
the predictions may vary from the
current situation that you see as the
data was taken from kegel that may have
some variations this is only to make you
learn how you can perform analysis on
such data sets and derive insights from
the prediction
so let's start with what is coronavirus
coronaviruses first discovered in 1960s
are a family of viruses that cause
illness ranging from common cold to
severe diseases such as medallist
respiratory syndrome and severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronaviruses can
be transmitted between animals and human
beings and hence they are xenotech
now let's see how coronavirus emerged in
december 2019 the city of wuhan in hubai
province which is china's seventh
largest city comprising 11 million
residents became the center of a
pneumonia outbreak of unknown cause the
chinese health authorities conducted an
immediate investigation of these cases
to identify and control its spread by
isolating suspected patients closely
monitoring the contacts and obtaining
detailed clinical and epidemiologic data
the source of coronavirus 2019 or covet
19 is believed to be a wet market in
wuhan which sold both dead and live
animals including fish and birds
let's see the symptoms of coronavirus
covid19 is characterized by symptoms
such as cold curve running nose sore
throat and fever illness can be more
severe for some people and can lead to
pneumonia or breathing difficulties
older people and people with other
medical conditions such as asthma
diabetes or heart disease may be more
vulnerable to becoming severely ill
the noble corona virus is now a public
health emergency of international
concern
people across the globe are racing to
cut short their vacations and rebook
flights home
as most countries continue to lock down
cities and towns amid the spread of
coronavirus as per the world health
organization till the 15th of march the
total debts reported globally stood at
while more than 100 000 people were
infected worldwide on the 11th of march
the world health organization declared
covet 19 as pandemic
on the screen you can see the total
coronavirus cases till the 13th of march
across the globe
most of the countries have been affected
by the spread of coronavirus
china south korea iran italy france
spain and germany are some of the
countries that got hit the most
next you see china italy iran and the
united states of america have the
highest number of deaths reported till
the 13th of march
the next map shows you the total
recovered cases across different parts
of the world china italy iran and south
korea have the most number of patients
who have recovered
now let's move on to the most important
part of this video where we will analyze
the outbreak of coronavirus cases across
different countries and visualize them
using different charts and graphs the
data has information from the 22nd of
january till the 15th of march using
this data we will predict the upcoming
cases for the next 10 days using
algorithms such as linear regression and
support vector machines in python
now let me go ahead and show you the
data sets that we will be using for this
analysis
so for this analysis we'll be using
three csv files
so here you can see we i have opened all
the three files the first data set is
regarding the confirmed cases it has
columns such as province or the state
country or the region latitude longitude
and the number of confirmed cases that
came up in all these days
similarly
the second data set is regarding the
deaths of patients
22nd of jan till
the 15th of march
and the third data set is regarding the
number of recovered cases
during the same time interval
now
let's start with understanding the code
for this demo where we will use support
vector machine and linear regression to
build our model and predict the total
number of confirmed cases that may come
up in the next 10 days again to clarify
our prediction may vary from the current
scenario that you actually see since
this data set was taken from kegel which
is usually for learning purposes i have
already implemented the code on jupyter
notebook i'll run through each cell of
code and explain to you what it does
first we will import all the necessary
libraries that are important for this
analysis as you can see
we are importing libraries such as numpy
and pandas that are used for numerical
computations and manipulations then i am
importing matplotlib library for
visualizing the data and the model
followed by math and time
after that from the skllen library i am
importing certain functions such as
train test split
sbr to build the model
and so on we are also using matrix
functions such as mean squared error and
main absolute error and so on
now let me run this cell by hitting
shift plus enter
we have successfully run that cell now
we will load all the three data sets one
by one for that i have used the pandas
library and read underscore csv function
which you can see here
i have provided the location of the file
followed by the file name and the
extension of the file which is dot csv
i've loaded all the three data sets into
three variable names now let me run all
the three cells to import all the three
data sets
i'll hit shift enter
scroll down
we'll load the death's
data set and the recovered data set
now to display the data sets i'm using
dot head function to see the top five
rows from the data
you can see the top 5 rows from the
confirmed underscore cases data set
similarly
you can check the top 5 rows from the
reported data set
from the deaths reported data set
and from the recovered cases as well
after that
i am extracting all the column names
from the confirmed cases data frame
using the dot keys function
let me run it
so below you can see
all the columns being displayed
then we are extracting only the date
columns that have information of
confirmed cases death cases and
recovered cases using the dot loc
function
the first parameter that is colon tells
you we need all the rows
while the second parameter tells you
that we need data from the fourth column
till the last column which are the date
values
now let me run all the three
you can go ahead
to see the outbreak cases using
confirmed dot head
here you can see it has only the date
columns and the values for each of the
dates
after that in the next cell i am finding
the total confirmed cases death cases
and the recovered cases and appending
them to four empty lists
we are also calculating the total
mortality rate which is nothing but the
total death sum divided by the total
confirmed cases
you can see
i have declared four empty lists namely
world cases total deaths mortality rate
and total recovered then
i am running a for loop
taking the date variables into
consideration so for each of the date
values
we are summing the total confirmed cases
the death cases and the recoveries
after that i am appending the values to
the four empty lists that we had created
now let me run it
moving ahead let me display each of the
newly created variables one by one
so if i run confirmed underscore sum you
can see the total number of confirmed
cases
which is nearly one lakh sixty seven
thousand four hundred and forty nine
now if i run this one it will tell you
the total number of deaths that have
been reported which is 6440
and the total number of recoveries stand
at 76.34
similarly if i run world cases
you can see
this kind of an array
which have been listed date wise
in the next step i am converting all the
dates and the cases in the form of a
numpy array using np dot array function
let me run it
now i can display all the newly created
arrays by passing the variable names
so if i run days since
22nd of jan
you can see it will list you the total
number of days that were present from
the 22nd of jan till the 15th of march
now if i run world cases you can see it
has an array
which has values of the total number of
cases that emerge between
22nd of march
till
the 15th of march
similarly
if i run the total deaths variable
you can see it it lists all the death
values between 22nd of jan till
15th of march
and finally for the total recovered
cases
now since our prediction will be for the
next 10 days
so i have created a variable called days
in future
and assigned a value of 10. then i am
adding the last 10 days to the total
number of days we have now let me show
you the value of future forecast by
running this cell
you can see below
future forecast
has given us a total of
64 days
next we are converting all the integers
into date time values for better
visualization
so let's run it
now before we start building our code
let's visualize the data using different
charts and graphs and see what has been
the impact of coronavirus so far for
visualization
we need the latest data of 15th of march
so i have extracted the last column
values for all the three data sets
now let me display these for you
i'll run latest underscore confirmed
you can see it gives you all the values
from the 15th of march
similarly i'll go ahead and run the
remaining
latest deaths gives you
the total debts that were reported on
15th of march
across various regions
similarly
for the latest recoveries as well
after that i am finding the list of
unique countries using the dot unique
function
if i run this
so below you can see there are different
countries
so that's thailand japan
singapore malaysia
all the countries across the globe
so in the next cell
i'm basically calculating the total
number of confirmed cases by each
country
so i have created two empty lists
namely country confirmed cases and no
cases
if the cases are greater than zero i am
appending the values to country
confirmed cases else i am appending it
to no cases
next i am finding the number of cases
per country or region
so you can see that china has the
highest number of cases
followed by italy and iran
now in this cell of code we are finding
the list of unique provinces using the
dot unique function again
now there are certain countries that
have been marked as provinces of states
such as the united kingdom denmark and
france
those we are classifying as outliers and
removing them from the list
next we are finding the number of
confirmed cases per province state or
city so for this
we have created two empty lists namely
province confirmed cases and no cases if
the cases are greater than zero i am
appending them to province confirmed
cases else to no cases i am also
removing the areas with no confirmed
cases
now you can see the total number of
cases per province city or
state so here are the values
coming to the next cell
in this piece of code
you're basically handling nan
or missing values
let me just run it
okay
so now that we have done with preparing
the data for visualization
let's build different charts and graphs
to see what we can derive from it
first we'll plot a bar graph to see the
total confirmed cases across different
countries in the beginning
i am giving the size of the graph using
plt.figure so we have 32 by 32 size
then i am passing the unique countries
in the x axis
and the country confirmed cases in the y
axis
i have given a title to this graph
number of coveted 19 confirmed cases in
countries i have also given a label for
the x axis which is number of coveted
confirmed cases we are using plt dot
show that will display the graph
let me run it
as you can see if i scroll down
china
has the highest number of cases followed
by italy iran south korea spain germany
france and so on
now i'll plot another bar graph to see
the total confirmed cases between
mainland china and outside mainland
china
for mainland china i am finding the sum
of all the cases where country or region
equal to equal to china
while for outside mainland china i am
taking the sum of all the confirmed
cases and subtracting china cases
let me now run it
as you can see the total number of cases
outside china is more than mainland
china
now if you want you can also print the
exact values which i have done below
so the total cases outside mainland
china
is around eighty six thousand four
hundred and forty six while in china it
is close to eighty one thousand and the
overall cases till fifteenth of march
stand at one lakh sixty seven thousand
four hundred and forty nine
another thing i have done is to show 10
countries that have the most number of
confirmed cases while the rest of the
countries have grouped into a category
named others
so i have created two empty lists named
visual unique countries and visual
confirmed cases i have taken the 10
countries based on the top 10 cases
while the others category has the
remaining cases
now let's visualize the 10 countries
using a bar graph
so this is how the graph looks like
on the y-axis you have the different
country names you also have
the others category
and on the x axis
you have the number of cases
you can see
china has the highest number of covet 19
cases italy has the second highest while
other countries in total
have the third highest cases
now the same visualization you can do
using a pie chart to check the total
confirmed cases in 10 different
countries i have used a color scheme css
4 colors i have given the figure size 20
by 20
i am using plt.pi function and
plt.legend function to show the
different countries
let me just run it
so here is how
the pie chart looks like
and to the right you can see the
different legends
so this color corresponds to china
while this one corresponds to italy
this is actually others and so on
here i have created another pie chart to
visualize the total confirmed cases in
10 different countries apart from china
it has the same code as ever
but
under plt.pi i have passed columns apart
from china and hence we are using one
colon similarly under plt.legend we have
values apart from china
let me run it
so this is how the pie chart looks like
as you can see italy has the highest
number of cases followed by iran and
then south korea
we also have others in this category
which has
pretty high number of confirmed cases
so now that we have visualized our data
let's start by building our model using
a support vector machine algorithm
support vector machine uses different
parameters to build a model these
parameters are kernel
c gamma epsilon shrinking and svm grid
kernel specifies the kernel type to be
used in the algorithm it must be one of
linear poly rbf sigmoid precomputed or
callable if nothing is given rbf will be
used c is a regularization parameter
gamma is the kernel coefficient of rbf
poly and sigmoid epsilon specifies the
epsilon tube within which no penalty is
associated in the training loss function
shrinking takes boolean values that is
true or false
svm grid has all the values passed as
parameters to it
then
with the help of randomized search cv
function
we are building a model by passing the
necessary parameters finally
we are fitting the data using svm search
dot fit function and passing
xtrain confirmed and white train
confirmed
let me now run it
this might take some time
since we have an epoch or an iteration
defined
here we have given 40 iterations
now we have successfully run that
particular cell
now
let's find the best parameters for the
model
so you can see the result shrinking is
false
kernel it has taken as poly gamma's
value is 0.1 epsilon value is 0.01 and c
value is also 0.01
now you can find the best estimator
using svm search dot best estimator
function
and predict the future forecast using
the predict function
i'll run this
if i run svm underscore confirmed below
you can see the results similarly svm
underscore predict will tell you
the predicted values
for all the dates
now you can check the values of the
testing data after creating the model
for that we'll create a plot with the
svm test predicted data and the y test
confirm data
then i'll print the mean absolute error
and the mean squared error values
so below you can see the graph
and the error values
then i'll plot the total number of
coronavirus cases over time starting
from 22nd of jan
i have given a title number of
coronavirus cases over time so there are
x labels and y labels defined
let me now run it
so here is the graph
on the y y-axis you can see the number
of cases
and on the x-axis you can see the total
number of days by looking at the graph
you can tell after 40 days
the cases were close to 90 000 and now
after 50 plus days the cases have
reached nearly one lakh sixty thousand
the next plot shows you the total
confirmed cases versus the svm predicted
cases that might come up
let me now run it
here you can see the graph
the blue line which is this one
it represents all the confirmed cases
while the dotted purple line is the
prediction from the svm model which is
this one
now we'll predict the values of the
cases for the next 10 days using the svm
algorithm
here is the output
you can see it starts from the 16th of
march till the 25th of march that is the
next 10 days after 15th of march you can
see the total number of upcoming cases
each day
so on 16th of march the model predicts
there will be around 1 lakh 84 000 cases
on 17th of march we might have one lakh
93 000 cases and so on
let us now see how you can predict these
cases using the linear regression model
so
we have imported the linear regression
function from the scikit-learn library
i have fit the model with xtrain and
white trained confirmed data
which is this one
for prediction i have used x test
confirmed data and the future forecast
data
finally in the end i am printing the
values of mae and mse for this model let
me now go ahead and run this code
below you can see it has given us the
value for mean absolute error and mean
squared error
let's now plot the confirmed values from
the test data and the linear predicted
data
so this is how the graph looks like
like we did for the svm model we can
also plot a graph to show the number of
coronavirus cases over time since 22nd
of jan
i'll run this
so here is the graph
the blue line depicts the confirmed
cases while the yellow line tells the
linear ignition predictions
now i'll go ahead and predict the cases
for the next 10 days using linear
regression here you can see the
predictions
it is different from that of the svm
model which had a higher number of cases
now we'll plot the total number of
deaths over time
let me run it
so as you can see from the graph
on the x axis we have time that is the
number of days on the y y-axis we have
the number of deaths
so by day 50
the number of deaths reported have
crossed five thousand
the next cell we are plotting a graph to
visualize the total mortality rate of
coronavirus cases over time
i'll hit shift enter
so here is the graph of mortality rate
of corona virus cases over time
then i am plotting the total number of
coronavirus cases recovered over time
as you can see from the graph
nearly 75 000 people have recovered from
this pandemic
in the next plot
i am checking the number of coronavirus
cases based on deaths and recoveries
so below is how the graph looks like
the green line represents the number of
recoveries and the red line
represents the number of deaths
as you can see there are a lot of
recovered cases which is good news
and finally we are checking the total
number of coronavirus deaths versus
recoveries in a single plot
so here is the graph
the x axis has the number of recoveries
while the y y-axis has the number of
deaths reported so far
with that we have come to the end of the
demo to analyze coronavirus outbreak
globally
now let me address a few questions that
our viewers are asking related to
coronavirus and about this prediction
analysis first question i can see here
is how coronavirus spreads and how to
protect yourself
so coronavirus spreads in a similar way
to flu or the common cold basically in
large droplets produced by curves or
sneezes
germs can leave on surfaces for several
hours
public health england defines the spread
as having close contact with a virus
carrier within 2 meters of the person
for 15 minutes
as mentioned there is no vaccine as of
now to protect yourself you need to take
precautionary measures such as regularly
washing your hands staying away from
crowded places like malls and pubs and
using masks
another question which i can see on the
chat window is who started the
coronavirus to be honest there are a
number of crazy conspiracy theories that
have been circulating that the virus
somehow escaped from a chinese lab
either by accident or design however
this is categorically untrue and
scientists studying its genetic code
have linked it to bats it probably then
jumped to other animals which passed it
on to humans
one more question is can we use time
series analysis and other type of
algorithms to make predictions of the
cases of course you can you can use time
series analysis to predict the upcoming
cases but it would be recommended for
you to have individual data from
different countries you can also use
algorithms such as bayesian ridge and
logistic regression there's another
question can we also predict the death
cases and the recovered cases for the
next 10 days surely you can predict both
the parameters you just need to provide
the total debts and the total recovered
cases information to the splitting step
where we are dividing the data set
with that i think we have covered most
of the important questions related to
this topic
machine learning is the future and yours
can begin today comment below with your
email id to get our latest machine
learning career guide let your journey
begin
finally it's our duty to tell you the
important safety precautions that you
can take to ensure you are not suffering
from the spread of coronavirus since
there is no coronavirus vaccine yet so
here are the measures that you can
follow clean your hands often with soaps
and sanitizers avoid close contact with
people who are ill
always wear a face mask when you are out
practice respiratory hygiene
please avoid gathering in crowded places
do stay at home if you are sick and most
importantly seek medical care early if
you have fever cough or difficulty
breathing
and with that we have reached the end of
this session
welcome to another live session by
simplyloan i would like to thank you all
for actively participating in these
sessions on youtube and facebook
today we will understand how to perform
stock market prediction using machine
learning
so what really is stock market
a stock market is a place or a public
market where you can buy and sell shares
for publicly listed companies
the stocks which are also known as
equities represent ownership in the
company
the stock exchange is the mediator that
allows the buying and selling of shares
amsterdam stock exchange is the oldest
stock exchange that were established in
the top stock exchanges in the united
states are the new york stock exchange
nasdaq american stock exchange and
chicago board operations exchange
in india we have the bombay stock
exchange or the bsc that was established
in 1875 and it's asia's first stock
exchange
we also have the national stock exchange
or nse
now let's understand the importance of
stock market
stock markets help companies to raise
capital
if stock markets did not exist then
companies would have to resort to
borrowing loans from the banks to raise
money for expansion
this would be a trouble for the company
as they would have to repay the loans
with interest
with stock markets companies have the
free hand to create an initial public
offering and raise large amounts of cash
without having to worry about repayment
another reason why the stock market is
important is it helps generate personal
wealth for an individual investor the
stock market provides a platform to
invest your income
and earn a share of the company's profit
stock markets serve as an indicator of
the state of the economy
that is the stock market serves as a
barometer for the economy
a rise of fall in the prices of shares
indicates what cycle the economy is in
such as a recession or a boom
the stock market is considered to be one
of the most widely used sources for
people to invest money in
investors are always looking to invest
in companies with high growth potential
if the stock market is performing well
this increases investment from local
investors
it also attracts foreign direct
investment as people abroad invest in
the local stock exchange
with that
let's now understand stock market
prediction
stock market prediction helps you
determine the future value of company
stock and other financial instruments
traded on an exchange
the whole idea of predicting stock
prices is to gain significant profits
predicting how the stock market will
perform is a difficult task to do
there are a lot of other factors
involved in the prediction such as
physical and psychological factors
rational and irrational behavior etc
all these factors combine to make share
prices dynamic and volatile
this makes it very difficult to predict
stock prices with high accuracy
so we will use machine learning
techniques to predict the stock prices
of two different companies tesla and
google
we'll be using linear regression
algorithm and long short term memory
networks for building our prediction
models
so first
let's understand the basics of linear
regression
linear regression is a very popular
statistical technique used for solving
machine learning problems
it is a supervised learning algorithm
for predicting the output of a
continuous target variable
it can be used to predict the total
revenue of a company or the total units
expected to be sold of a certain product
it can also be used for weather
prediction
and stock price prediction
now here is an example to predict the
total number of ice creams a vendor or a
company can sell based on the
temperature of the day
you can see the green dots represent the
actual data points so the x-axis has the
input variable that is temperature and
the y-axis has the target variable that
is units sold
linear regression uses the linear
equation formula
y is equal to m x plus c
where m is the slope of the line
c is the intercept
we find the coefficients and plot the
regression line
so in this graph the red line is a
regression line the best fit line should
have the least square distance between
the original data points and the
predicted values
now let's see how to predict the stock
prices of tesla using the linear
regression model
so this is the csv data set that we will
be using for our prediction
we have information from the 29th of
june 2010
till the 15th of may 2019
here
open column means the price at which a
stock started trading when the market
opened on a particular day
the close column refers to the price of
an individual stock when the stock
exchange closed market for the day
it represents the last buy sell order
executed between two traders
the high column is the highest price at
which a stock traded during a period
the low
is the lowest price of the period
volume is the total amount of trading
activity during a period of time
the adjusted closing price is a
calculation adjustment
made to the stock's closing price
it is more complex and accurate than the
closing price
the adjustment made to the closing price
depicts the true price of the stock
because the outside factors could have
altered the true price
now before i begin the demo i want to
tell you that if you want to get a copy
of the source code files and the data
sets that i'll be using in this session
then please put your email ids in the
chat section of the video
also please subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to stay updated with
all the latest trending technologies
so here is my jupyter notebook where i
have implemented my linear regression
code
so i'll run through each cell of code
and explain what it does
first
we'll import the necessary libraries for
building our model
so i'm importing pandas numpy and
matplotlib for numerical computation
data manipulation and data visualization
we'll also import the plotly library for
building our graphs
now if you are using plotly for the
first time you will have to install it
and then import it onto jupiter
let me run this cell
so i have successfully imported all my
libraries
next
i load the tesla stock price data set
using the pandas library and the read
underscore csc function
i'll also give the location where my csv
data set is present
now let me import the data set i'll hit
shift enter
so now i have successfully imported my
data set
now let's
see my data sets for that i'll use the
head function
li tesla dot head
so this will return the top five rows
from the data set
in the next cell
i am using the info function to find the
total rows and columns in my data set
the info function will also return the
data type of the variables and check if
there are any null values
there you go
so we have total seven columns and there
are
2193 entries
here you can see the data type of each
column and each column has no null
values
moving ahead
in the next step we are converting the
date column into date time format using
pandas library and two underscore
datetime function
up next let's do some exploratory data
analysis and get more insights from our
data
i am using the print function and a
formatted string lateral that is f
these strings contain replacement fields
which are expressions delimited by curly
braces you can see here
here i am finding out the data frame
contains stock prices between what dates
and the total number of days
so the total number of days can be
calculated by subtracting the maximum
date value and the minimum date value
so let me go ahead and run it
you can see
our stock prices
are from 29th of june 2010
till 15th of march 2019
and the total number of days are
3181 days
now let's see some summary statistics
for our data using the describe function
so the describe function
gives you the count mean standard
deviation the maximum and minimum from
each column the 25th quartile the 50th
quartile and the 75th quartile
let me now go ahead and create a box
plot to visually check our outliers i am
considering five columns open high low
close and
adjusted close
so this is how our box plot looks like
in this cell
we'll plot a graph using the plotly
library that we have imported
we are setting the layout for our graph
using the go layout function
i am providing a title to the graph
i am also setting my x-axis for giving
the title
so
the x-axis will have the date column you
can see it here
we are also defining the title font the
family
size and color
similarly i am providing the layout for
the y-axis
you can see it here
finally i am passing my data list
and the layout created to
plot variable
let me go ahead and run it
now i'll plot my graph using the iplot
function
there you go so we have the stock prices
of tesla plotted in this graph
on x-axis we have the year
from 2011 till 2019
and on the y-axis you have the price
which is basically the close column
you can see from the graph
that initially during 2011 or 2010 the
stock prices were
growing a little lower than expected
but towards 2015 16 and
17 onwards the stock prices grew higher
now
coming to the most important part that
is to build the linear regression model
so in this cell i am importing the
necessary libraries and the respective
functions
first i am importing the train
underscore test underscore split
function from the scikit-learn library
next
i am also importing some pre-processing
functions like min max scalar and
standard scalar from scale library
also
for evaluating the model and finding the
accuracy we'll use the mean squared
error and r squared error from scikit
learn matrix library
let me run it
so we have successfully imported our
required libraries
moving ahead
in the current step
we are splitting the data into training
and testing sets
the x variable contains the independent
features and the y variable has the
dependent variable or the target
variable that is closed column
i am taking the test data size as 0.3 or
30 of the total
and i'm assigning a random state of one
zero one
let's run it
okay
now
i'll perform feature scaling on the
xtrain data set
for that i'm using the standard scalar
dot fit function and passing in my
extrane data
standardization of a data set is a
common requirement for any machine
learning algorithm they might behave
badly if the individual features are not
normally distributed
so that's why feature scaling is
important
with that
it's time for us to import the linear
regression function from the
scikit-learn library
now
using a variable lm which stands for
linear model i'll declare a linear
regression function
and then i'll use the fit method to pass
the training data sets that is extreme
and white rain
so let me run it
now we have successfully created a
linear regression model
next we'll plot the graph for actual and
predicted values for the training data
set
here we'll be creating a scatter plot
and draw our prediction line so i have
used the go.scatter function
i am using
markers for plotting the actual data
points and i have used a line to draw
the prediction line
let me run it
now to plot the graph i use the iplot
function
if i scroll down
you can see
on the x-axis we have the day column
or the day variable
and on the y-axis we have the prices of
our stocks the blue dots represent the
actual stock values if i hover over this
blue dots you can see the actual
values
and
the red line is a predicted
regression line
the final step will calculate the scores
for evaluating our model
so here we are using two matrix one is r
squared error and mean squared error
for finding the r squared error we have
used
r to underscore score function and i am
passing my
y train
as well as x train using the lm predict
function
similarly
for finding the r squared error for
testing data set i am using y test and
lm predict for
x test
likewise
to find the mean squared error value i
have used the y train and y test data
along with predicted xtrain and extras
theta
now let me run it
below you can see the two matrix scores
so our r squared error score is around
0.86 for the training set and it's
around the same value of 0.86 for
testing data set and similarly you can
see the mean squared error as well
with that you saw how to predict the
tesla stock prices using linear
regression model in python
if you want to get a copy of the source
code files and the data sets that i am
using in this session
then please put your email ids in the
chat section we'll share the files over
email
also please subscribe to our channel and
stay updated with all the latest
technologies
now we will understand about long
short-term memory networks
so lstms are a type of recurrent neural
networks for learning long term
dependencies
it is commonly used for processing and
predicting on the basis of time series
data
from the image on the left you can see
lstms have a chain like structure
instead of having a single neural
network layer
there are four interacting layers
communicating with each other in a very
special way
now lstms work in a three-step process
the first step in lstm is to decide
which information to be omitted from the
cell in that particular time step
it is decided by the help of a sigmoid
function
it looks at the previous state that is h
t minus 1 and the current input state
that is x t and computes the function
in the second layer there are two parts
one is the sigmoid function and the
other is the tanh function
or the hyperbolic tangent function
in the sigmoid function it decides which
values to let through that is 0 or 1
the hyperbolic tangent function gives
the weightage to the values which are
passed deciding their level of
importance from -1 to plus 1.
in the third step
it decides what will be your final
output
first it will run a sigmoid layer which
decides which parts of the cell state
make it to the output
then we put the cell state through the
tenets function to push the values to be
between -1 and plus 1
and multiply it by the output of the
sigmoid gate
now let's go to a jupiter notebook and
implement a long short-term memory
network to predict the stock prices of
google
before that let me first show you the
data set that we will be using
so this is my jupyter lab
and on the left you can see we have our
google data sets so we will be using two
data sets for this demo a training data
set and a testing data set
let me show you how the training data
set looks like
i'll open
the csv table
so this is our training data set of
google
it has the same columns like date open
high low close and volume
and if i scroll down you can see
we have data from 2012 till 2016.
we close this
now let me open my google test data set
so this is my test data set
and
we'll be using this data set to evaluate
our model
so first
let me go ahead and import all the
libraries that we'll be needing to
build our lstm model
you can see i'm importing the numpy
pandas and matplotlib library for
numerical computation data manipulation
and data visualization
we are also importing min max scalar
function from scikit-learn
pre-processing library then we have some
built-in functions
from the keras library
such as sequential to analyze a sequence
of data then dense lstm and dropout to
measure the dropout rate
i'll hit shift enter to run this cell
you can see it says we are using
tensorflow backend
now
let me go ahead and import the google
training data set using read underscore
csv function from pandas
i have imported my data set now if you
want to check the head of the data set
you can use data dot head
run again so it will display the top
five rows from the data set
similarly
now let's see the total rows and columns
we have in this data set
and the data types of each variable
we'll use the info function for this
you can see
this is my output
so we have a total of 6 columns and
1258 entries
and here you can see the data type so
date it has taken as object
open it has taken as float
high it has taken as float similarly
close and volume column it has taken as
object
now we will do some pre-processing of
data to transform our closing price
variable to a numeric type
drop the non-available data and keep
only the close column for training the
data
now to convert the close column into
numeric i have used pd dot
to underscore numeric function
now to drop my missing values i have
used drop any function
and similarly
to consider only closing column as my
training data
i am using i lock or index location
now let me run it
now let's once again see the data types
if we scroll down you can see we have
changed the close column data type to
float
earlier it was object now it's float
next
we will rescale our data into values
between zero and one for better
performances
for that
you can use the min max scalar function
and give the range
then i have used fit underscore
transform method to transform the values
and then i am also printing the shape of
my training data let me run it
now we will prepare our data for
training
first we need to prepare our input
sequences with 60 time steps of extreme
data
alongside the respective white train
labels
next we'll be adding another axis for
the batch size since the input for an
lstm network is a 3d tensor so it will
have a sequence length the time steps
and batch size
now we'll build a model containing four
layers of lstm network all followed by a
dropout layer
on the top
we'll also have a final dense layer
which is this one
all of this compiled using an adam
optimizer and a mean squared error as a
loss function
let me run it
next i'll train the data using 20 epochs
and batch size of 32 using the model dot
fit function and passing my x strain and
y train data
this will take some time to run
since it will complete 20 iterations so
you can see it has started with first
epoch and it will run for
epochs now we are into our second epoch
you can see the loss that was incurred
during the training of the first epoch
and that brings us to the end of this
live session on machine learning i hope
you liked it if you have any questions
then please feel free to put them in the
comment section thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you